Hallo Wolfgang.
Sag mal, warst du schon in Freibad?
Es ist zwar heiß, aber Freibad ist nicht so meins.
Was hast du denn gegen Freibäder?
Ich hab gar nichts gegen Freibäder, ich bin nur selbst nicht gern dort.
Also da einfach auch von wissenschaftlichen Themen zu sprechen, an denen man sich mal hält, das ist schwierig.
Das ist sehr eigenartig. Und jetzt auch dieser Verweis auf die Kunstfreiheit ist so nicht gut.
Zweiter wichtiger Punkt, die Kunstfreiheit ist ein hohes Gut. Es gehört sich nicht, dass der Staat vor allem nicht in Form seines Oberhaupts da eingreift oder sogar maßregelt, wenn Anschuldigungen nicht auf realen Gegebenheiten fußen, schon mal gar nicht.
Nun, es gibt die Kunstfreiheit, aber es gibt auch Artikel 1 des Grundgesetzes und da steht die Kunstfreiheit jetzt nicht drüber. Die Kunstfreiheit hat natürlich die Möglichkeit, mit allem zu spielen und da kommt es wieder auf Kontexte an. Aber man kann schon sagen, dass es da wiederum Kriterien gibt.
Also hier eine rote Linie zu ziehen, um den Bundespräsidenten der Bundesrepublik Deutschland zu verbieten oder das noch mal unter Vorbehalt zu stellen, ob er sich bei welcher Rede auch immer zum Thema Antisemitismus äußert, geht definitiv zu weit.
Ja, und das ist ja seine Aufgabe als Bundespräsident. Also selbst wenn man die Rede scheiße findet, muss man ja zur Kenntnis nehmen, der Bundespräsident ist eigentlich nur dafür da, um zu sagen, so soll Gesellschaft sein, so stelle ich mir das vor, Dienstpflicht, wir werden ja noch darüber sprechen, das wäre ein tolles Konzept und genauso kann er auch sagen, unsere Erinnerungskultur kann niemals dulden, das oder so was. Also das ist etwas, was primär Aufgabe des Bundespräsidenten ist. Er hat eigentlich fast keine andere Aufgabe.
Stimmt, genau, das ist keine andere.
Dutzende Journalistinnen haben sich aktiv auf die Suche nach antisemitischen Inhalten gemacht und rein gar nichts gefunden, nichts nada. Wirklich, ich vermute, dass es hier darum geht, dass viele in Deutschland kritische Stimmen aus dem globalen Süden einfach nicht aushalten. Und ich wäre einer der ersten, die antisemitische Inhalte ächten.
So, da muss man sagen, das Interview ist vor diesem eigentlichen Vorfall, aber es gab auch vorher schon ganz klare Indizien und dass alle Journalisten nichts gefunden haben, stimmt so auch nicht, sondern diese Debatte köchelt ja ja schon ziemlich, ziemlich lang. Und was hier auch noch mal betont werden muss, weil hier so getan wird, als sei das jetzt gegen den globalen Süden, gegen Kunst aus dem globalen Süden. Der Kunstmarkt ist internationaler denn je. Große westliche Kunstgalerien haben ein immenses Interesse daran, dass sie zum Beispiel Kunst aus afrikanischen Ländern vertreten haben. Denn man kann damit auch wahnsinnig viel Geld verdienen. Der Kunstmarkt ist ein globaler, weil wir global millionäre Milliardäre haben. Also immer noch so zu tun, als sei das noch alles wie vor 100 Jahren. Das stimmt. Da gibt es auch noch Rassismus und all das. Also natürlich ist der Kunstmarkt nicht frei von den Problemen, die wir auch sonst in der Gesellschaft haben. Aber so zu tun, als sei das noch jetzt alles und hier die weiße Herrschaft über den Kunstdiskurs oder so, das ist nicht der Fall. Und das merkt man auch, wenn man einfach mal in die Kunsthalle nach Mainz geht. Da muss einfach irgendeine Ausstellung, da kann man ja mal gucken, welche Kunst ist dann da jetzt so zu tun, als sei die Documenta da. Große Vorreiter ist totaler Quatsch.
Genau, das fand ich auch noch mal super überraschend. Das hat Danny auch noch mal kurz angeschnitten, weil in Österreich ist Heidi Horten gestorben, als reichste Frau Österreichs, die halt zwei Wochen vor ihrem Tod noch mal ihr eigenes Museum fertiggestellt hat, wo dann die Kunstsammlung vor allem ihres Mannes, der sich auch wieder mit diesen Horten-Kaufhäusern damals schon auch im Dritten Reich nicht besonders Verdienst gemacht hat und so weiter, Kunst ausstellte. Und das Prinzip des Kunstmarkts ist ja, dass so Kuratoren solcher Häuser, also gerade dieser hohen teuren mit Zähnhäuser, so rumgehen und dann so picken. Und in dem Moment, wo ein Werk eines Künstlers in so einer Galerie auftaucht, gewinnt das ganze Öfere dieses Herren oder der Frau einen neuen Wert. Und in der Hinsicht sind in Afrika noch Schätze vergraben, weil wir die europäische Kunst soweit, also es ist jetzt super aufstrebend, die Jung ist neu und so, aber eigentlich muss das ja erst mal so eine Weile.
Aber da sind die Preise ermittelt, das steigt ja noch ein bisschen.
Das ist sozusagen so ein gesättigter Markt, nachdem wir jetzt auch so eine Vermögenspreisinflation hatten und so. Das ist alles gesättigt. Aber in anderen Teilen der Welt gibt es halt noch zu entdecken, so wie man Fußballspieler halt irgendwo sucht und dann plötzlich hat man ihn, nur in dem Fall hängt dann wirklich so ein ganzes Werk dran. So und es muss nur irgendwo mal auftauchen in einer dieser, was weiß ich, in der Hortengalerie dann da in Wien oder so. Und dann hat man plötzlich so ein ganzes, ja wie so ein Goldgrubenfund. Und das ist natürlich bei gerade dieser afrikanischen Kunst, die muss nur so auf kleines Interesse fallen. Und dann kommt man so ein Ding und dann ploppt so ein richtiges Werk plötzlich auf und gewinnt an Wert. Und in der Hinsicht, ja, liegt natürlich ein Aufmerksamkeitsfokus auf diesen Regionen schon seit einer Weile.
Klar. Und das war vor zwei, drei Jahrzehnten Kunst von Frauen aus den Zehner-Zwanziger Jahren. Die wurde zwar auch gesammelt schon immer und die waren jetzt nicht total marginalisiert. Aber plötzlich versuchte man natürlich auch mal zu zeigen, Zwanziger Jahre, warum immer nur diese fünf bekannten Männer, sondern da gibt es ja auch Frauen, die erstaunlich es hervorgebracht haben. Dann fing man an, das zu kuratieren. Man fing an, Ausstellungen zu machen, Kataloge anzufertigen. Und dann kann man sich ja mal ansehen, wie dann die Preisentwicklung bei Hannah Höch oder Paula Modersohn-Becker oder so war.
Das ist ja ein Effekt davon. Ich habe es noch halb im Ohr, ich kenne den Namen der Künstlerin nicht mehr, aber Verena Lüken war vor ein paar Jahren in New York bei einer älteren Malerin, die ihr Leben lang nur in ihrer Wohnung malte.
Maria Lasnek?
Das kann sein. Selbst wenn ich jetzt den richtigen Namen sehe, kann ich mich nicht erinnern. Man könnte noch mal nachgucken. Verena Lüken hat beim Nachrufen im Deutschlandfunk beigetragen, weil sie aus persönlicher Erfahrung und Besuchen kannte. Der Tenor ist dann immer, sie starb mit 100 und wurde aber erst mit 80 richtig berühmt, obwohl sie schon seit 60 Jahren malt. Das sind genau diese nachgetragenen Erfolgsbiografien, die durch dieses, es gibt ja auch noch weibliche Kunst. Sobald man da einmal ein Fokus drauf gelegt hat, hat man sozusagen neue Schätze, in die man investieren kann. Das ist jetzt eben mit Afrika genauso.
Noch ein Clip.
Steinmeier, aber auch seine Entourage haben sich hier allerdings null informiert. Sie reden auf Grundlage einer selbst zentrierten Haltung und einer deutsch-deutschen Inszenierung, wo ich schon beim dritten Punkt wäre. Der wichtige Kampf gegen Antisemitismus in Deutschland darf niemals deutsch zentriert sein, niemals. Steinmeier und viele andere Deutsche reden zwar über Jüdinnen und Juden, über Israel, über Antisemitismus, aber eigentlich reden sie über sich selbst, über ihre Schuld, über ihr schlechtes Gewissen und ihre performative Erinnerungskultur.
So, der eine Verwurf ist ja nicht ganz von der Hand zu weisen, dass es eine Form der deutschen Erinnerungskultur gibt, die so aussieht, wir wollen schnell wieder die Guten sein. Und deswegen prüsten wir uns ein bisschen mit unserem Kampf gegen den Antisemitismus. Meinen den aber vielleicht auch gar nicht so ernst. Aber gut ist ja, dass wir in der Welt wieder entsprechend dastehen. Das ist ja eine Entwicklung, die man seit den 50er Jahren schon beobachten kann. Aber zu sagen, dass der Antisemitismus-Diskurs jetzt deutsch zentriert ist, also man muss sagen, ja, der Antisemitismus hatte auch seine allerschlimmste Ausprägung in Deutschland gehabt. Und deswegen ist es ganz klar, dass da nochmal in einer anderen Weise ein Fokus draufliegt. Und dass auch dadurch, dass dieser Fokus draufliegt, gerade wissenschaftlich, so viel hervorgebracht wurde, was Antisemitismus ist, wie man ihn verhandeln kann, wie man ihn vielleicht bekämpfen kann. All diese Dinge haben wir ja. Und das ist aufgrund dieser Einmaligkeit des Verbrechens. Und dass man jetzt einfach auch so tut und sagt, ja, da sollen jetzt mal, warum beschäftigen sich die Deutschen eigentlich so viel mit Antisemitismus? Das ist so grundfalsch. Und das relativiert auch dann diese globale Perspektive, die von dort ausgeht. Also nur weil es dann das gibt und weil man dann auf Holocaust und so weiter zurückführt, heißt das ja nicht, dass man den Antisemitismus, wenn man ihn thematisieren will, dass man das nicht universalisieren kann.
Genau. Also das ist ein ganz wichtiger Punkt, hier die, wie man in der Soziologie unterscheiden würde, sachliche und zeitlichen Dimensionen zu unterscheiden. Wenn wir heute über Antisemitismus reden, müssen wir das universalistisch tun. Da, wo er auftritt, ist er eine Gefahr. Und die Gefahr kennen wir aber aufgrund seiner Geschichte. Und da spielt Deutschland eine besondere Rolle. Die beiden Sachen muss man so trennen.
Und er macht ja selbst eine Deutschzentrierung, wenn er dann erstmal, wo wir jetzt über indonesische Künstlerkollektive sprechen, dann hören, der Rechtsextremismus gehört zur deutschen Leitkultur. Und eigentlich haben die Deutschen das Antisemitismusproblem. Also natürlich gibt es Antisemitismus in Deutschland. Ich würde sagen, durch diese öffentliche Verächtlichmachung ist sicherlich auch viel verdeckt. Das erlaubt aber dann auch, dass man eine gewisse Sicherheit dann dadurch Juden bietet. Denn es traut sich nun jetzt aus Grund und Grund nicht, jemand einfach mal so antisemitisch zu sein, weil es in dieser Verächtlichmachung, also es hat ja auch einen positiven Effekt. Also das ist, glaube ich, auch etwas, was man gar nicht hoch genug halten kann, dass man wirklich sagt, das geht nicht. Also dass man diese rote Linie immer wieder aufzeigt, weil das auch letztlich dann vielleicht eine bessere wachrüttelnde Funktion hat als jeder intellektuelle Diskurs ständig darüber. Und wenn man aber jetzt über Künstlerkollektive aus dem Ausland spricht, dann muss man auch einfach sagen, ne, wir reden jetzt gerade über den Antisemitismus dort. Das hat jetzt auch jetzt gerade nichts damit zu tun mit AfD oder sonst irgendetwas. Da muss man auch sagen, ne, da könnte man dann sagen, dass es ein bisschen deutsch zentriert.
Ja, also diese Deutschzentrierung, ich finde, es gibt so einen Punkt, den traut man sich selten zu thematisieren, obwohl er soziologisch abgeklärt auf der Hand liegt. Und ich mache jetzt nur mal eine analytische Äquivalenz. Wir haben in der Impfdiskussion erlebt, dass Menschen sich nun deswegen nicht impfen lassen und das auch bewusst und öffentlich so sagen, weil sie dem Staat eins auswischen wollen, nachdem der Staat sie lange im Stich ließ. So, wir haben also, egal woher, Frank-Walter Steinmeier ist auch dadurch, dass er vorher inhaltlich arbeiter Politiker war, jemand, der sich bei vielen verspielt hat und so weiter, haben wir Bewegungen, dass, egal was er thematisch aufgreift, gegengespiegelt wird, allein um nur eine Ablehnung, eine Wut auszudrücken. Was bedeutet, wenn der Bundespräsident oder allgemein die Antisemitismus-Diskussion zu weit oben, in Anführungszeichen, wo man sich doch von den da oben immer so vernachlässigt fühlt, dass das auch zu Antisemitismus provozieren kann, der, wie Antisemitismus aussieht, aber eigentlich eine andere Quelle hat. Also gar nicht aus innerlicher Überzeugung, sondern durch diese Mitläufertum, Trotzhaltung usw. dadurch wieder genährt wird. Das spielt natürlich in so einer wissenschaftlichen Betrachtung schon eine Rolle. Man kriegt es aber nicht transportiert in die eigentliche Arbeit gegen den Antisemitismus, der relativ häufig, relativ weit oben, in Anführungszeichen, was die politischen Erarchien angeht, aufgehangen wird. Also egal, was die thematisieren, man hat dann einfach eine Trotzhaltung dagegen. Wenn die sagen, du sollst jetzt nur noch 120 auf der Autobahn fahren, dann fahre ich besonders 200 oder so. Also aus dieser Gemengelage heraus, da steckt auch so eine kleine Antisemitismus und wirklich eine gefährliche Ideologie drin, die dann eben auch inhaltlich nachgetragen verhärten kann. Also Menschen, die das nur so spielen, können dann wirklich Antisemiten werden, weil sie da ihr Soziales aufgehoben sein und plötzlich spüren. Und da ist tatsächlich eine Gefahr hin, da wir in Deutschland anders und intensiv über Antisemitismus reden, dass auch nochmal ein besonderes deutsches Phänomen ist.
Ich hatte vor ein paar Wochen eine Veranstaltung in Trier. Da waren Wochen gegen Antisemitismus. Und da habe ich etwas Interessantes erfahren. Es gibt eine Studie, ich weiß jetzt leider den Titel dieser Studie nicht, die auch gesagt hat, dass viele Ressentiments und Diskriminierungen durchaus durch Bildung abgebaut werden können. Antisemitismus interessanterweise nicht. Also Antisemitismus ist gleichermaßen auch bei hochgebildeten Leuten zu finden. Und da fallen einem ja direkt aus der Wissenschaft Leute ein. Das ist ganz erstaunlich. Ich will ein Clip spieben, bevor wir uns der Ästhetik widmen, von Michel Friedmann, der das kommentiert hat.
Die Documenta hat sich immer verteidigt, dass natürlich in Deutschland eine besondere Sensibilität, was Judenhass angeht, aufgrund der Geschichte zu sehen ist, dem widerspreche ist. Der Judenhass ist keine deutsche Erfindung. Auschwitz war eine deutsche Erfindung. Und deswegen ist es richtig, dass wir in Deutschland, was Judenhass angeht, null Toleranz haben. Aber Judenhass in Indonesien ist genauso menschenverachtend wie anderswo auch in dieser Welt.
Ja, das ist ja wichtig, das genau so zu sagen.
Da kann man nicht sagen, ach, das ist so eine kulturelle Eigenart. Ne, Antisemitismus ist überall falsch, aber Auschwitz war eine deutsche Erfindung.
Auschwitz war die deutsche Erfindung. Der Antisemitismus ist universalistisch ein Problem. Universal ein Problem, so ist es halt.
Universal ein Problem. Bazon Brock, sagt er dir was?
Bazon Brock ist der Lieblingsphilosoph desjenigen, Matthias, der uns hier zum Beispiel die Musik für diesen Podcast gemacht hat und auch für viele andere Podcasts.
Bazon Brock ist ein Enfant terrible. Ich habe ihn zweimal live erlebt. Es ist hervorragend. Er macht dann Teaching, er führt durch Museen. Drei Stunden spricht er ohne Punkt und Komma und bricht dann einfach irgendwann ab, weil er sagt so, jetzt hören wir auf, aber nicht, weil alles gesagt ist. Und Bazon heißt der Schwätzer. So hat ihn ein Professor genannt. Deswegen hat er sich diesen Künstlernamen genommen. Der wird hier mal eingeleitet im Deutschlandfunk und kommentiert die Documenta.
Einer, der seit der Documenta 4, das war 1968, selber dabei ist als Begründer der Besucherschulen und des Action Teaching. Das ist der Denker im Dienst, der Künstler ohne Werk, der Ästhetikprofessor, der Fluxusvater, der Kultur, der Kunsttheoretiker Bazon Brock. Und ihn habe ich gefragt, ist das eigentlich die erste, in Teilen antisemitische Documenta, die Sie erleben?
Der Antisemitismus ist nur ein kleiner Teil des Kulturalismus.
So, er legt jetzt gleich einen anderen Fokus. Wir sparen uns jetzt diese ganze Aufarbeitung der Debatte. Soll Claudia Roth zurücktreten? Was macht der Bürgermeister von Kassel? Diese ganzen Geschichten. Das interessiert uns nicht. Wir wollen ja die großen Linien verfolgen. Und jetzt sagt Bazon Brock, dieser Antisemitismus, der sich da ausdrückt und auch diese Argumentation, die Friedmann ja jetzt auch vorgeführt hat, dass die falsch ist, diese Ausdruck eines Kulturalismus. Und dann geht das so weiter.
Und die Documenta zeigt ja triumphal und damit also auch als ganz große demonstrative Leistung, was gegenwärtig in der Welt der Fall ist. Nämlich von Erdogan über Putin bis zu Xi. In all diesen totalitär regierten fundamentalistischen Regimen wird die Front des Kulturalismus gestärkt. Das heißt, auch im Westen übernimmt man nun die Führerschaft dieser Kulturen und ihrer Herren.
So, man ist vielleicht noch irritiert, wenn man das Werk von Bazon Brock nicht kennt. Worauf will der da eigentlich hinaus? Kulturalismus.
War der nicht eben gesagt, das ist ein Künstler ohne Werk?
Er ist ein Künstler ohne Werk. Er hat aber natürlich Bücher geschrieben, Texte verfasst. Nun, Kulturalismus, dem gegenüber steht für Bazon Brock die Kunst. Kultur und Kunst müssen wir nicht zusammen denken. Jetzt formuliert erst mal Brock seine Kritik an der Documenta.
Die jetzige Documenta ist ja nichts anderes als eine Versammlung solcher kulturalistischer Formen. Überall heißt es, macht keine Kunst, sondern schafft Freundschaft, hängt miteinander ab, hat eine gute Zeit. Und problemisiert, wie immer ihr wollt, im Namen eurer kulturellen Identität. Nur wird dabei geflüssig vermieden zu sagen, was eigentlich kulturelle Identität sein soll. Es bleibt einfach nur ein Herrschaftsgestus über euch, nämlich die Kultur siegt endgültig über das europäische Prinzip der Kunst- und Wissenschaftsfreiheit, die 600 Jahre existiert hat und enormen Weltkenntnisfortschritt gebracht hat. Damit ist es jetzt zu ändern. Die Documenta jetzt ist sozusagen ein triumphales Zeugnis für das Beenden der westlichen Idee von Autorität durch Autorschaft. Das heißt, von Menschen, hinter denen nichts steht. Keine Bank, kein Papst, kein Militär, keine Kultur, kein gar nichts. Und die trotzdem angehört werden, weil das, was sie sagen, interessant und von Wichtigkeit ist.
Der Künstler nach dem Mittelalter tritt hervor. Albrecht Dürer schreibt plötzlich auf das Bild, wer er ist, nämlich Dürer, macht eine Marke sogar draus, zeigt sich als Christus, sagt also, ich bin jetzt hier der Prophet. Ihr könnt mir folgen, aber ihr könnt, ihr müsst nicht. Wenn ihr meine Autorität folgen wollt, die ich durch meine Autorschaft, seht her, ich bin ein toller Künstler, beweise. Genauso macht der Wissenschaftler das. Der Wissenschaftler schreibt, man kann es nachprüfen und sagen, ja, scheint zu stimmen, oder man sagt, der Schauspieler hat mich beeindruckt, der Redner hat mich beeindruckt, das scheint mir ein kluger Gedanke zu sein. Dem wende ich mich zu, nicht weil die Kirche mir das sagt oder der Vater mir das sagt. Und diese Autorität durch Autorschaft ist eine westliche Erfindung, sagt Bazon Brock, was aber nicht bedeutet, dass die unsere kulturelle Identität ist, sondern das ist eigentlich das, was universalisierbar ist. Wenn man aber sagt, nee, jeder hat da seine Identität und für die ist Antisemitismus das und für die ist das das und so weiter. Und dann kommt man in so einen Denken rein, das eigentlich an das erinnert, was wir schon auch besprochen hatten im letzten Salon, als ich über Universalismus gesprochen habe, bei Shi, wo Shijek das eigentlich ganz gut gefasst hat, wo er sagte, ja, Shi sagt ja, ich bin für Menschenrechte, aber für meine Menschenrechte, also so wie ich die halt austariere.
Genau. Wir haben ja hier das große Programm Spontan-Histerisierung einer Dekade. Was kann man in einem Moment finden, was vielleicht für ein ganzes Jahrzehnt prägend ist? Und ich glaube, ich habe es schon einmal erzählt, einer Schützeichel. Für einen ganz kurzen Moment einer meiner Soziologielehrer, als er nämlich mal einen Professorenposten für ein Semester ersetzt hat oder so. Inzwischen Professor für Soziologie in Bielefeld, glaube ich. Also zumindest angekommen in der Professoren- schaft, was mich sehr freut. Ich glaube in Bielefeld. Und er hat damals zum Punkt gemacht, wenn wir uns die lumanische Systemtheorie anschauen, steckt da so ein gesellschaftstheoretisches Differenzierungsargument drin. Am Anfang wenig Mobilität, wenig Menschen, segmentierte Gesellschaften. Die eine weiß gar nicht, ach, da drüben ist auch noch ein Dorf, auf der anderen Seite der Welt leben auch Menschen und so. Wer ist denn das? Interessiert niemanden, man kennt die nicht und man sieht die auch nicht. Dann in verschiedenen Formen, Stratifizierungen, Zentrum, Peripherie. Also wir haben so sich anbahnende Hierarchisierungen. Es gibt irgendwie einen König und dann so ein Rittertum, ein Adel und so weiter. Der einfache Bauer. Zentrum, Peripherie, vielleicht sogar noch mal so als Stadt. Wir haben so einen Stadtkern, wie bis heute ja die wichtigen Leute mit viel Verdienst arbeiten natürlich im Stadtkern und die anderen ziehen so aus der Peripherie zu. In egal welcher Ausprägung und dann plötzlich diese funktionale Differenzierung. Die Menschen selbst treten in den Hintergrund und nur noch die Prinzipien gelten. Also ich benutze Geld und kaufe damit Sachen, ganz egal woher sie kommen. Das Geld alleine funktioniert. Oder bei der Wissenschaft. Es ist egal, wer es geschrieben hat, solange sich das Experiment wiederholen lässt mit dem gleichen Ergebnis, gilt das einfach als wahr. Der Autor, es gibt halt einen Erfinder, den kann man dann auch feiern, aber mehr als Reputationen und Ansehen kann man ihm nicht verleihen, weil die wissenschaftliche Erkenntnis steht erstmal für sich. Und der Ingenieur, der sie anwendet, dem kann total egal sein, auf welchen Riesen-Schultern er gerade steht und so. Und dann meinte Schützeichel so zu uns, was ist denn dann der nächste? Also glauben wir jetzt wirklich einfach, dass so nach vier, fünf Differenzierungsstufen das aufhört. Was kommt denn als nächstes? Und es war, der 11. September war schon vorbei, aber wir sind auch noch nicht in dieser jetzt gerade Zeit angekommen. Also irgendwann so 2008, 9, 10 vielleicht war das. Und dann meinte er so, vielleicht eine ethnische Differenzierung. Also, dass ich zwei Geld habe und damit auch alles kaufen kann, was mir angeboten wird. Aber ich gehe einfach nicht nach Chinatown und kaufe dort, sondern ich kaufe da, wo ich unter Gleichgesinnten bin. Und sei es nur unter, ich erkenne mich hier wieder, weil keine asiatische Frau mich bedient, die meine Sprache nicht spricht oder so.
Was ja auch in China zu beobachten ist, bei der Jugendkultur, dass die sagen, nee, amerikanische Mode, amerikanische Musik, Produkte wollen wir eigentlich nicht.
Und wir hätten eine ethnische Differenzierung, wenn uns diese Aspekte im Alltag wieder wichtiger sind als zum Beispiel Geld zu sparen beim Einkaufen.
Das war ja auch die große Hoffnung von Friedmann und von Hayek, dass die Diskriminierung durch den Kapitalismus überwunden wird. Die waren dann ein bisschen blauäugig. Es war tatsächlich die Idee, dass sie sagten, man ist ja regelrecht dumm, wenn man nicht seine Sachen da kauft, wo sie am günstigsten sind. Und dann ist doch egal, ob der Verkäufer schwarz oder weiß ist. Und dann glaubten die allein aus so einer Kostennutzenabwägung, wird die Diskriminierung zumindest dann in den jeweiligen Staaten und überwunden werden. Und das scheint sich aber immer mehr als eine Illusion zu empfucken. Und ich finde auch gut, dass Brock hier eigentlich was kontraintuitives macht, nämlich er verbindet ja so ein autoritäres identitätspolitisches Denken von rechts mit einem identitätspolitischen Denken, das ja scheinbar erst mal progressiv sein will, aber man kommt in so eine Reethnifizierung hinein.
Ja, also wir haben ein sehr vermindertes publizistisches Interesse chinesischer Wissenschaftler, weil die einfach wissen, nee, das ist irgendwie gewollt, dass ich hier nicht für die Weltgesellschaft Wissen produziere, sondern für meine kommunistische Partei und so weiter. Also werden da gar nicht so viele wissenschaftliche Paper geschrieben. Beim Thema Geld haben wir sowieso schon, dass wir auch hierzulande sehen, dass Menschen lieber mehr Geld ausgeben, dafür aber unter sich sind. Also das ist ja sowieso so eine Bewegung, die es gibt und die nimmt halt zu und dass wir uns, und das ist ja irre, wir haben es ja auch schon mehrfach thematisiert, klar kann man jetzt den Ölmarkt sich irgendwie anschauen und dann sehen, naja, das Öl, das wir jetzt nicht aus Russland kaufen, geht zuerst nach Indien und wird uns dann aus Indien als indisches Öl verkaufen, wo es aber Russisches ist und so weiter. Also finanziell gesehen und materiell gesehen, kommt das Öl da an, wo es gebraucht wird. Aber in diese Lieferkette wird halt so ein ethnisches, wir kaufen nicht beim Russen plötzlich eingebaut. Und zwar, obwohl es super teuer ist dadurch, aber wir kaufen nicht beim Russen. Und das schlägt sich…
Dann muss ich mal diese Doku ansehen, die ist, glaube ich, bei YouTube über Mark Rich, kennst du den? Der hat in der Schweiz gelebt, war Amerikaner, Israeli. Der hat als die amerikanischen Sanktionen gegen Iran gab, als diese Botschaft da gestürmt wurde und alles, hat der als Unterhändler dann die eigentlichen Ölgeschäfte gemacht, wurde dann nachher 17 Jahre vom CIA gesucht und nicht gefunden. Aber der hat da eigentlich nur die Funktion, dass das Öl da ankommt, wo es gebraucht wird. Aber ja gut, wir können nicht mit den Kommunisten, aber Kuba braucht Öl, ja und weiß ich nicht, Iran will nicht mit Israel handeln, aber die brauchen das Geld von Israel, also muss da mal einer das machen.
Genau, also wenn man Profite aufs Spiel setzt, um solche, ich nenne es jetzt mal grob, ethnischen Differenzierungen einzuhalten, wie auch bei Donald Trump mit dem Soja, dass es halt erst nach Australien verkauft wird und dann nach China landet und dann verdienen nochmal drei Leute mehr in der Lieferkette mit und plötzlich stehen 30 Milliarden Subventionen, die an amerikanische Bauern gezahlt werden müssen und so im Raum. Also dass man so viel Geld aufbringt, nur um nicht direkt mit den Chinesen Handel zu treiben und so, obwohl es eben doch indirekter Handel dann ist, da zeigt sich doch, ja, da ist wirklich gerade so eine Zeitenwende, also diese Segmentierung, die da drinste, diese ethnische Differenzierung, die ist doch von erheblichem Gewicht und gerade wenn man sich beiden anschaut, das bisschen habe ich dann doch mitbekommen aus den Gipfeln, wie er über China redet jetzt und auch die ganze Welt darauf einstimmt, dass hier ein neues kaltes Kriegsszenario diesmal mit China droht und jetzt sozusagen die ethnischen Blöcke gerade organisiert werden. Wer ist hier drinnen, wer ist hier draußen und so, das findet ja gerade statt.
Man merkt es auch so in der Stimmung, ich war vor einer Woche im Beethoven Haus in Bonn und da war ein Konzert mit chinesischer, zeitgenössischer, klassischer Musik und es waren ganz wenige Leute da und ich glaube, das ist zum einen, dass die Leute noch nicht so richtig ins Konzert zurück wollen, aber es liegt auch daran, dass man jetzt sagt, ach nee, so China, da bin ich nicht. Obwohl es dann einfach interessante Kompositionen sind, mit denen man sich mal auseinandersetzen könnte.
Die wissenschaftliche Zusammenarbeit, zum Beispiel beim Thema Weltraum, Amerika, Russland hat den ganzen Kalten Krieg durchgehalten. Das ist auch wichtig. Und jetzt ist er abgerissen.
Und dann haben wir jetzt so gleich diese Debatten über kulturelle Aneignung und so und da muss man immer sagen, nee, Kunst ist immer nur kulturelle Aneignung. Alles andere ist totaler Hubschrauber.
Wo soll sie denn stattfinden?
Die Kunst ist, muss man sich auch vorstellen, als Kinderzimmer, da kann man alles mal durchspielen. Ohne dass Ernste Konsequenzen haben, machen Kinder gerne, spielen Vater, Mutter, Kind, aber ohne dass sie am Ende wirklich eine Ehe eingehen oder was. Und genauso kann man auch sagen, ich greife aus den Kulturen, die es gibt und Ritualen, irgendwas rausspiele damit. Und das ist hier in der Sphäre der Kunst. Aber wenn man natürlich in diesem ethnischen Denken ist, ist das nicht mehr möglich.
Du hast es ja ganz wunderbar. Ich habe ja ein bisschen die Vorgeschichte mitbekommen, von dir erzählt, wie das so ist, von einer Kulturzeit-Interview zu werden. Und jetzt haben sie ja zwei O-Töne von dir dann benutzt und diesen ersten habe ich ja auch gleich ins Intro vom Fernsehpodcast gepackt. Wenn Amazon ein Playbook schreibt, wie ab sofort, also ein Drehbuch dafür, wie Drehbücher geschrieben werden, nämlich dass am Ende der Schauspieler die Identität, die er verkörpert, kennen muss, dann haben natürlich die Autoren des Drehbuchs, der Drehbücher, nicht verstanden, was Fiktion ist und dann zitiert du nämlich nicht die Realität und das ist natürlich bei Kunst genauso. Wenn wir ins Kinderzimmer gehen, ist das nicht der Ernst des Lebens, sondern das ist das Spiel um das Leben. Das kann man beginnen, abbrechen, unterbrechen, sich neue Regeln überlegen und so ist das natürlich bei der Documenta auch. Das ist Kunst. Die darf damit spielen, dass es eine Distanz zur leider emotional erlebten Realität gibt, in der wir uns alle ganz viele Sorgen, die auch nicht unsere eigenen sind, mittlerweile und so weiter machen müssen. Aber es bleibt eben auf dieser anderen Seite von dieser grünen Linie, die da gezogen ist.
Genau und man könnte auch dann verstörendes tun. Also ich muss jetzt noch mal an diese Skateboard-Aktion denken. Das war in Thailand, glaube ich, war das jetzt eben das Beispiel, dass man Skateboards sammelt in Kasse und die bringt man dann mit den Kindern dort vor Ort. In Ag der Kunst wäre eigentlich zu sagen, ja, und das wäre dann wirklich Konzept und zu sagen, wir sammeln die Skateboards, denn wir wollen ja den Kindern bringen und dann kommen natürlich die anständigen Deutschen und sagen toll, habe ich auch noch was für die Kinder in der Welt getan. Und dann müsste eigentlich das Künstler-Kollektiv hingehen, wenn die Skateboards zusammen sind, dann die alle aufstapeln und abbrennen und sagen, nee, ihr braucht euch gar nicht einbilden, dass ihr jetzt irgendwas getan habt. Wir lösen das in der Sphäre der Kunst auf und gucken, wir müssen uns jetzt mit unserer Ohnmacht mal konfrontieren. Das wäre interessant.
Da hätte man wieder das Argument bringen können, wenn wir sie hier vor Ort verbrennen, haben wir die Umwelt weniger geschädigt, als sie im Flugzeug dahin zu transportieren.
Wir hören weiter, denn Brock ist vor allem unglücklich darüber, dass so viele Kollektive eingeladen sind.
Alle diese Leute haben noch nicht kapiert, was überhaupt die Kunst für einen Wert darstellt, die Wissenschaft für einen Wert darstellt. Es geht doch am Kern um Folgendes, dass Banker, Kirchen, Militärs, Parlamente etc. Autorität haben, Kraft ihrer Durchsetzungsfähigkeit, das ist doch wohl allen klar. Damit haben alle Kulturen aller Zeiten gerechnet und gelebt. Erster Westen entdeckt vor 600 Jahren, dass es auch eine überzeugende Kraft von Individuen gibt, hinter denen gar nicht steht. Und die Sensation des europäischen Entdeckermuts der Kunst und Wissenschaft war anzuerkennen, dass es nicht nur kulturelle Legitimation durch Kollektivbeschlüsse gibt, sondern Autorität durch die Autorschaft, das heißt durch die Fähigkeit eines einzelnen Menschen, hinter denen keine Macht steht. Welterkenntnis zu eröffnen und zu zeigen, beispielhaft zu zeigen, wie ein einzelner Mensch, ein Individuum, sich in der Welt gegenüber dem Überdruck des nicht individuellen, also des bloß Kollektiven, der Machtkomplexe von Kapital bis Kirche behaupten kann. Und das wird jetzt beerdigt und unsere Zeugen und Paten sind eben Erdogan, Xi und Putin. Wir sprechen also mit der Documenta genau der Weltlage. Das ist natürlich eine große Leistung.
Jetzt habe ich es verstanden, was er meinte. Sehr gut. Ich habe mich auch lange gefragt, wenn man so die Kataloge durchblickt, welche Bücher entstehen eigentlich gerade. Wir blättern ja immer durch, weil wir so Salonliteratur suchen. Dann ist natürlich nicht unbedeutend, wer hat es denn geschrieben. Denn, was weiß ich, irgendwann ist es doch mal so ein Black Rock Whistleblower oder so, der die Innerreihen kennt und was schreibt oder irgendeinem Politikgarten anliegen. Und wir wissen, wenn der was schreibt, der hat ja auch Macht. Vielleicht setzt er davon was um oder so lesen wir dann Schiritzbuch über Olaf Scholz oder was auch immer. Oder wir lesen Sendl, weil Scholz den gelesen hat und so. Und jetzt schreibe ich über Demografie. Und ich bin aber einfach nur so ein Publizist. Und Demografie, klar wäre es auch gut, wenn wir uns alle noch mal, keine Ahnung, das letzte Blühenbuch zum Thema So und So oder hier vom, wie heißt er, das alte Brüderpaar, Vogel, richtig. Und dann wird noch mal über Grund und Boden und so weiter geschrieben. All solche Sachen, wo man weiß, das lesen auch Leute. Und dann stellt sich ja wirklich die Frage, warum sollte jemand ein Buch über Demografie lesen und warum von mir? Und der einzige Weg, den ich habe, ist inhaltlich besonders originell und was die Formulierungen irgendwie ansprechen zu schreiben. Das ist das Einzige. Also ich habe nur diese ästhetischen Kategorien, die er gerade als, da steckt niemand dahinter oder so.
Und argumentative.
Genau, inhaltlich einfach so.
Genau, du musst durch den Inhalt, durch das Argument überzeugen. Kannst nicht überzeugen, damit du sagst, ich bin selbst 120 Jahre alt und deswegen habe ich so viel Ahnung von Alten oder irgendwas.
Es steckt keine Autorität dahinter.
Aber das ist die eigentliche. Also das ist die moderne Form der Autorität, ist genau die und dann können wir das überprüfen. Dann können wir vielleicht noch ein zweites Buch über Demografie lesen und sagen, vielleicht haben beide ein bisschen recht oder einer mehr oder weniger und das ist aber dann wieder der Aushandlungsprozess, der dann gesellschaftlich in Gang gesetzt wird. Aber du kannst nicht sagen, ich, weil ich Stefan heiße oder weil ich in Frankfurt wohne oder weil die Kirche mich beauftragt hat, habe ich recht.
Genau und um den Schutz geht es ihnen.
Ja genau.
So und diesen Schutz gibt es nicht in den Ländern, die er ansprach. Ja und jetzt ist er auch in Deutschland sichtbar verloren gegangen und dazu gratuliert er uns bitter und das ist natürlich sehr bitter.
Ja und er zeigt jetzt noch mal diese Unterscheidung auf Kultur gleich Kunst. Man macht die ja einfach so immer mal wieder, dass man sagt ja ich interessiere mich für Kultur und damit meine ich dann Theater, Ballett oder sonst was. Aber er legt noch mal Wert darauf, dass wir diese Unterscheidung trotzdem machen müssen, geistig.
Von Kunstkollektiven haben sie noch nie was gehalten, das haben wir gerade auch gemerkt. Ich glaube sie gehen noch weiter und sagen das ist sogar das Ende der Kunst?
Das ist in der Tat absehbar und das ist absichtlich so gemacht worden. Es hieß lange Zeit die Leute sind nur bildungslos, die sind nur kenntenslos, sind nur dumm. Und deswegen sagen sie Kunst und Kultur, Kunst und Kultur, Kunst und Kultur, das ist Synonym, gleichbedeutend. Kunst gleich Kultur und Kultur gleich Kunst. Es ist ein wildes Durcheinander von Leuten, die nicht gerade sehr lange nachgedacht haben. Nein, inzwischen stellt sich heraus, dass das wirklich strategisch ist. Das ist gewollt, das ist Absicht. Und das ist die Refaschistisierung, das ist die Retotalisierung und Fundamentalisierung aller Autoritäten. Man hat die Nase voll von der Vielfalt der Anforderungen, die Kenntnisse, geschichtliche Kenntnis verlangen etc. Das will man nicht und deswegen kehrt man zurück zum Schafstahlgeblöcke der kulturellen Identität.
Sehr scharf formuliert, ich würde aber sagen, wir müssen nochmal überprüfen, ob das in diesem Rahmen, also beim Antisemitismus, ja ist es jetzt so passiert, ob das auch bei anderen Themen so passiert, dass wir Kunst rausräumen, weil sie unter...
Na ja, wir sehen es zum Beispiel an einem Antrag, also wir sehen es an einem Amazon Playbook, wir sehen es zum Beispiel an Anstrengungen in der Off-Szene. Da weiß ich, das weiß ich Leute kennen, die Theater machen, die plötzlich Identitäten angeben müssen, wer repräsentiert ist, wer teilnimmt. Wir sehen das daran, dass fast nur noch reden über solche Fragen gehalten werden. Und da, also das... Ich würde es jetzt auch nicht, noch nicht das Ende der Kunst ausrufen, wie Bazon Brock das macht. Er macht das natürlich in überspitzter Weise. Aber ich glaube, dass diese Tendenz ganz klar dahin geht. Und das Argument dann auch genauso wenig zählt, wie zu sagen, ja, aber das ist doch Kunst, die darf das doch. Sondern dann muss man dann ständig jetzt mit sich, sich mit Identitäten herumschlagen. Und für Brock ist natürlich jetzt die Frage, wie ist dann die Documenta als Ganzes einzuschätzen? Und ich glaube, da hat er dann schon, auch wenn das dann bitter gemeint ist, recht.
Nein, schlechteste nicht. Die ist die beste, weil sie die Situation, die im Augenblick der Weltlage am besten abbildet. Sie ist die gefährlichste, sie ist die folgenreichste, sie ist damit auch die zu beachtendste. Jetzt kann man nicht mehr davon absehen, prononciert Stellung zu beziehen. Jeder ist jetzt aufgefordert, man muss sich jetzt entscheiden. Gehört man zu den Kulturalisten, die alles vernichten, was überhaupt je Autorität durch Autoren und Wissenschaftler gewesen ist, also von schwachen kleinen Individuen, gehen die mit diesen Individuen, Schreibern, Künstlern um, wie alle Diktaturen ins KZ, ins Loch abgestraft oder hier gemeinsam abhängen. Das ist die große Maxime dieser Ausstellung. Gemeinsam abhängen, gemeinsam Zeit verblödeln und sich großfühlen. Das ist alles. Das ist die wirklich bedeutendste Documenta, die es hier gegeben hat.
So Stefan, du gehst dahin und du darfst natürlich jetzt nicht abhängen, sondern ich will jetzt wissen, nachher wie ist die Kunst. Aber vielleicht sollte ich dann doch hingehen, um es als Phänomen wahrzunehmen, so wie ich mir Til Schweiger Filme angucke. Da sage ich auch, dass es wichtig ist, um die deutsche Leitkultur zu verstehen. So muss ich vielleicht jetzt die Documenta mir ansehen, um die Weltlage zu erkennen. Also vielleicht doch ab nach Kassel.
Ich gebe zu, ich gebe mich geschlagen, denn ich wäre genauso ein Abhänger im doppelten Sinne, der dahin geht, um abzuhängen mit anderen Leuten. Und mir wäre egal, was sie da eine Woche vorher abgehangen haben. Damit ich es nicht sehe und mein zartes Gemüt nicht betrübt wird von irgendwelchen Eindrücken, von denen ich glücklicherweise dann durch die neuen Autoritäten geschützt wurde. Das ist natürlich, ja, Bazon Brock hat wie immer recht.
Nein, er hat, man muss, also es geht ja jetzt nicht darum, dass, also er kritisiert ja nicht, dass da was abgehängt wurde, sondern was er wirklich kritisiert ist, dass wir in dieser kulturalistischen Logik über alles sprechen. Und das finde ich wirklich ganz merkwürdig, dass das auch bei Leuten auftaucht jetzt, die das früher nicht gemacht haben. Also das finde ich auch ist eine Entwicklung, dass man das bei einigen Leuten, die man gerne gelesen hat, plötzlich merkt, dass die das auch einfach jetzt so nehmen, so als sei das so eine Konvention jetzt geworden, in dieser Weise darüber zu sprechen. Und dass man sich geradezu verdächtig macht, wenn man noch die Kunst hochhält. Nun ja, vielleicht muss man sich da auch ein bisschen was trauen, wie ein 86-jähriger Bazon Brock.
Ja, Kunst und Kultur so zu unterscheiden, ist auf jeden Fall hilfreich. Das gibt uns es denn. Klar, solche Kunst braucht natürlich kulturell. Und damit ist schon politisch gemeint. Ein Ausrichter, ein Veranstalter, jemand muss das organisieren und so weiter. Gut, jetzt habe ich ja eben gesagt, welche Mittel habe ich schon, um Leute zu überzeugen, Bücher von mir zu lesen. Oder wenn du übers Theater schreibst. Und das eigentliche innerliche Argument ist natürlich, naja, wenn du das Buch nicht liest, weißt du nicht, was in deinem Leben los ist. Von welchen Ideologien du auf welche Weise ausgetrickst wirst, von Leuten, die selber nicht wissen, dass sie gerade mit einer Ideologie rumtricksen zum Beispiel. Oder auch klar, du leidest unter hohen Wohnkosten, bist unzufrieden, hangest dich von einer Problemlösung zur nächsten. Könnte man das nicht mal so im Panorama betrachten, dass man Handlungsmöglichkeiten wieder zurückgewinnt. Das wäre so Thema meines Buches. Und da ist natürlich dieser Monat Juni jetzt besonders interessant gewesen, weil wir eine von Frank-Walter Steinmeier aufgerufene Pflichtjahr-Diskussion haben. Ich weiß nicht genau, wo die Autorenschaft liegt. Richard David Precht behauptet ja in seinem Podcast mit Langs, dass er das auch aufgeworfen hat und Carsten Linnemann, der ja gerade im Grundsatzprogramm der CDU, über die wir uns ja noch sehr lustig machen werden, arbeitet und dort auch das Thema Pflichtjahr vorkam.
Aber es ist dann wahrscheinlich so, dass Precht Linnemann berät, oder? Weil Precht auch schon Linnemann gelobt hat mehrmals, wo man dann denkt, gut, was ist da jetzt?
Ich will mal den Zynismus zurückfahren. Ja, Precht berät Linnemann, aber, und das ist der Unterschied.
Ist das tatsächlich so oder ist das jetzt eine Mutmaßung nur?
Also Richard David Precht war sehr stolz darüber zu erklären, dass er mit Linnemann in Kontakt steht, der ja gerade das Grundsatzprogramm schreibt. Und dass er durchaus die Idee aufgegriffen hat, nachdem Precht ihm unterrichtete, was das für eine gute Idee ist.
Precht schon gezeigt hat, dass er keine Ahnung von Geldpolitik hat.
Auch, genau. Ich will mal alles ausklammern. In die Klammer gehört jetzt nur, Frank-Walter Steinmeier hat es für die jungen, jüngeren vorgeschlagen. Richard-David Precht hat den Vorschlag, es zweimal zu veranstalten, das Pflichtjahr einmal beim Einstieg in die Arbeitswelt und einmal beim Ausstieg aus der Arbeitswelt. Dieses zweite Pflichtjahr finde ich natürlich besonders super wichtig für unsere Rentnerrepublik, in der sehr viele alte Menschen am ersten Tag nach ihrer Berufslaufbahn nicht genau wissen, warum sie morgens eigentlich aufstehen und da eine Anleitung brauchen. Und ich auch denke, wir könnten sie da durchaus verpflichten, Tagesordnungspunkte wahrzunehmen, auch wenn es für sie innerlich eine Überraschung ist. Es wird meistens gut gehen. Sie werden sich gut fühlen. Und am besten lernen sie die Alternative, nichts zu tun, orientierungslos zu sein, gar nicht erst kennen.
Das glaube ich auch. Ich glaube, dass viele dann auf die Idee kämen, man könnte, man könnte, also es ist ja so. Für junge Leute ist es relativ leicht, sich irgendwo neu zu orientieren. Man geht irgendwo hin, lernt jemand kennen. Wenn man 65 ist und vielleicht alleine lebt oder vielleicht auch nicht die ganze Zeit nur froh ist, dass man verheiratet ist, dann hat man ja noch mal so mit 65 viel Zeit. Aber es ist ganz schwer, irgendwo reinzukommen. Man kann in Kulturvereine gehen. Ja, da ist eine Möglichkeit, aber das ist alles nicht mehr so offen und man geht auch nicht einfach in die Bar und quatscht Leute an oder so. Das ist eher nicht so. Man merkt aber dann zum Beispiel bei Einkäufen, wenn man mal mit Senioren ins Gespräch kommt, sind die sofort ganz dabei, weil sie froh sind, dass das jetzt gerade geschieht. Wenn diese Hürde genommen würde, wenn man einfach sagt, ihr müsst euch da, weiß ich nicht, zehn Stunden die Woche engagieren, ihr könnt euch diese 25 Vereine aussuchen, ob die jetzt Kuchen backen, Kinder betreuen, vorlesen oder Flüchtlingen helfen oder Stadtpark machen, ist ja mal egal, dass man dadurch natürlich sagt, so könnte auch das Leben jetzt weitergehen, das kann ich ganz gut mit meiner Zeit vereinbaren, kann mich auch immer noch um Enkel oder so kümmern oder habe da auch noch mal die Möglichkeit, neue Leute kennenzulernen, denn es ist ja keineswegs so, dass Liebe und all das, was dranhängt, vorbei ist, wenn man 65 ist.
Genau. Ganz wichtig ist gerade in dem Hören, in der zweiten Pflichtjahr Idee, dass es wirklich eine Pflicht ist, weil man häufiger es mit alten Menschen zu tun haben, die selber nicht ganz durchblicken, wie sehr sie sich nicht eingestehen, dass sie es eigentlich als Pflicht brauchen, damit sie noch drei Wochen lang immer rumjammern können, jetzt muss ich wieder in den Kindergarten gehen und diese Kinder und so. Ab der vierten Woche macht ihnen das dann Spaß. Dann switcht das innerlich so Inception-mäßig um und dann, ja eigentlich mache ich das gerne, es muss jetzt keine Pflicht mehr sein, so es würde mir fehlen, wenn ich es nicht mehr mache, so irgendwie.
Man kennt das ja von Verwandten, wenn die irgendwelche wöchentlich wiederkehrenden Aufgaben haben, irgendwas, vielleicht dann auch Kinder betreuen oder so, ach ja und so und dann, und dann braucht er nur dann mal den Vorschlag zu machen, ja hast du dann mal daran gedacht, das ist ja ein Babysitter oder so, dann das wäre ja auch eine Möglichkeit, ah ne, ne, es geht auch so und dann zeigt sich schon, natürlich wollen sie das überhaupt nicht, vielleicht muss man noch dazu sagen, wo hat Steinmeier das jetzt gesagt? Er hat das in einem Organ gesagt, wo man genau diese alten Leute erreichen könnte und die könnten da lesen, die sitzen nämlich, die haben so viel Zeit, dass die sich die Bild am Sonntag kaufen, da muss man ja nun wirklich schon fast zweifelt sein, ja und das Internet nicht kennen und so weiter. Die hätte man jetzt ansprechen können, hier, ihr, ihr, ihr lest doch gerade diese Zeitung, ihr könntet auch was Vernünftiges machen.
Und deswegen machen wir den Punkt, an diesem ersten wichtigen Punkt, das von Frank-Walter Steinmeier aufgeworfene Pflichtjahr-Diskussionstheater, klammert dieses zweite Pflichtjahr am Ende des Berufsleben aus. Es ging nur noch um das Pflichtjahr für die Jüngeren in der Diskussion. Und das ist das erste große Problem, was wir hier markieren. Das zweite große Problem gehen wir jetzt mal durch mit Kurzmeldung aus den Fernsehnachrichten, die ich extra aufgespart habe für diesen Podcast, um diesen roten Faden hier zu spinnen. Zum einen am 1. Juni im Heute-Journal.
Ärzte haben vor dramatischen Engpässen bei der medizinischen Versorgung von Kindern und Jugendlichen in Deutschland gewarnt. Aufgrund erheblichen Personalmangels können auf vielen Kinderintensivstationen ein Drittel, teils sogar die Hälfte der Betten nicht belegt werden, erklärt Mediziner der Funke Mediengruppe. Wegen Infektionswellen im Herbst könne sich die Lage noch verschärfen.
So, wohl dem, der keine Kinderklinik braucht. Aber wenn man sie braucht und dann heißt es, eigentlich könnten wir, aber wir haben zu wenig Personal, niemand hat sich gekümmert. Die Hälfte bis ein Drittel oder ein Drittel bis zur Hälfte steht einfach still. Also wir müssen selbst schwer, schwerwiegende Eingriffe, die sofort erfolgen müssen, können wir einfach nicht machen, weil Kapazität.
Da fragt man sich gleich, wir haben jetzt wieder einen Gesundheitsminister, der sagt, wir müssen aufpassen, dass wir im Herbst nicht überlastete Krankenhäuser haben. Und man muss ihm einfach sagen, wir haben gerade überlastete Krankenhäuser. Nur hat das mit Corona nix zu tun.
Genau. Also Kinderkliniken arbeiten in Deutschland, wenn es regional schlecht läuft, nur auf halber Kapazität. 100% Kapazität ist politisch ermessen an dem Bedarf, den es eigentlich gibt. Also wir haben eine echte Problemlage. Wir reden hier über die Menschen, die wir dann, wenn sie im schlimmsten Fall angewiesen waren, auf solche Sachen, die dann erwachsen werden, denen man dann sagt, aber jetzt stell dich mal die Gesellschaft zur Verfügung. Verpflichtend. Die Gesellschaft hat dir zwar nichts gegeben und noch Unterlass in Hilfeleistung usw. aber usw.
Im Übrigen ist das Problem mit Therapieplätzen ja auch schon nicht mehr groß mit Jahr thematisiert. Ich habe jetzt mit einem Bekannten gesprochen, der jetzt ganz glücklich war, also sehr jung ist er, 19 oder 20. Der hat jetzt nach über sechs Monaten anrufen und tun und machen, also man ist ja auch ziemlich auf sich allein, er hat einen Therapieplatz gefunden und er sagt, er hätte jetzt schon unheimliches Glück gehabt.
Ja genau, also das ist, da ist sowieso, hat ja Boris Palmer damals auch schon gesagt, Triage angesagt. Da werden, wenn überhaupt nur noch die suizidalen Fälle, also wenn du hingehst und sagst, ich wollte mich gerade umbringen, oder ist es so der Selbstmordversuch schon nicht geglückt dann, dass der dann noch aufgenommen wird. Naja, das ist also am 1. Juni vermeldet worden, am 23.
Die Corona-Pandemie hat bei vielen Schülerinnen und Schülern nicht nur psychische und körperliche Spuren hinterlassen. Laut dem neuen nationalen Bildungsbericht deuten erste Studien in Grundschulen auf Lernrückstände von bis zu einem halben Jahr hin. Außerdem drohe in Kitas, Schulen und Hochschulen ein langfristiger Fachkräftemangel. Dies war eine der drängendsten Fragen der nächsten Jahre.
So, eine der drängendsten Fragen der nächsten Jahre wird ja verpackt in eine Kurzmeldung. Es gibt keine Moderation zu, kein Expertengespräch, kein Bericht.
Aber jetzt gucken wir lieber mal, ob Söder irgendwas über März gesagt wird.
Genau, betrifft ja nur die, die, wenn sie dann mit ihrem Lernrückstand aus der Schule kommen, erst mal verpflichtet werden und so weiter. So, eine weitere Kurzmeldung am 13.
Juni. Nach einer Umfrage des Paritätischen Gesamtverbandes haben viele Kitas in Deutschland weiterhin mit Personalmangel zu kämpfen. Etwa die Hälfte der Beschäftigten von Einrichtungen und deren Trägern gab an, dass die Kapazität ihrer Kita nicht voll genutzt werden kann, weil Fachkräfte fehlen. Aus der Sicht von 67 Prozent der Befragten gibt es zu wenige Kita-Plätze auf kommunaler Ebene. Und 60 Prozent der Befragten Erzieherinnen und Erzieher sagten, sie können den Bedürfnissen der Kinder nicht gerecht werden, weil Personal fehlt.
Nichts funktioniert, es sind die drängendsten Probleme, die Deutschland hat. Wird zitiert und gleichzeitig wird das alles gar nicht thematisiert, aber stundenlang mit allen möglichen Leuten über das Pflichtteil diskutiert. Unter anderem mit Christel Bienstein, die ist Verbandspräsidentin für alle Pflegeberufe. Also es gibt einen Sammelverband für alle Pflegeberufe, also sowohl Kinder, Alten und so weiter. Sie ist sozusagen selber Hochschullehrerin und so kennt sich da richtig aus. Und sie kennt natürlich noch, sie weiß, wie die Diskussion geführt wird. Es gibt doch das soziale Ja und Damals bei den Männern ging es zur Bundeswehr, die Frauen ging dahin, war das nicht irgendwie gut und so. Ja, wir haben historische Erfahrungen damit, junge Menschen so semi verpflichtend irgendwie beispielsweise in den Pflegeberuf zu bringen. Nur haben wir jetzt 2022 hier ein ernsthaftes Problem. Das Argument, was sie jetzt macht, aus der Praxis heraus, mit Panoramablick auf das ganze Problem, habe ich nur das eine Mal hier bei ihr gehört, danach nie wieder in der Diskussion. Es ist das letzte Zitat, das ich in meinem Buch noch mit aufgenommen habe. Ich habe die Fahnen gekriegt, habe gesagt, das muss noch rein, habe ich noch reingeschrieben. Wir hören uns das hier mal an.
Wir haben damals bei den Zivildienstleisten hatten wir andere personelle Situationen und da konnten diese jungen Menschen gut begleitet werden. Wir haben dann auch sehr viele von ihnen im Grunde für die Pflegeausbildung gewinnen können. Und wir haben jetzt Sorge, wenn die Begleitung nicht gut geleistet werden kann, dass das ein Negativerlebnis für diese jungen Menschen ist und sogar sich gegen die pflegerische Ausbildung wendet und das auch natürlich in ihren Freundenkreisen weitergetragen wird.
Die machen Anti-Werbung.
Es wäre Anti-Werbung. Wenn man die Abiturienten in Deutschland fragt, landen die Pflegeberufe mit zwei Prozent, ja, kann ich mir vorstellen für mich, also nicht will ich machen, sondern könnte ich mir vorstellen, sowieso schon auf dem allerletzten Platz. Wenn jemand mit dieser Einstellung den Saustall, den wir Pflegenden in Deutschland jetzt kennenlernt, wo man unbegleitet, weil schon das Personal um diejenigen, die dann da mitarbeiten wollen, nicht anleiten zu können, nicht vorhanden ist, wäre das kontraproduktiv. Sie hat Angst davor, dass junge Menschen da plötzlich auftauchen, sehen, wie es wirklich ist und dann ihren Freunden erzählen, was der Sachstand beim Thema Pflegeberuf ist, dass dann niemand mehr kommt.
Das ist im Übrigen das, was wir nachher noch ansprechen würden. Ich habe mal zwei Pfleger, die wir zu Wort kommen lassen und dann werden wir mal hören, wie viele da auch sagen, nee, mache ich nicht mehr.
Und ein Argument, das ja noch gar nicht, ich habe es nirgendwo gehört, ist, was hatten wir hier schon mal kurz thematisiert und erreicht auch die Rechnung, wenn 2023 1, 1 Millionen Menschen in Rente gehen und 700.000 18-Jährige von unten nachwachsen und der ganze BDI und so weiter jetzt schon händendringend, wer baut denn jetzt demnächst unsere Autos und so. Und dann kommt die Politik und sagt, diese 700.000 Menschen spannen wir jetzt completo einmal für uns ein und nehmen sie aus dem, also ihr hattet die im Erwerbspersonenpotenzial erwartet. Muss man noch ein bisschen warten.
Wir haben ja das Abitur mal verkürzt, damit man früher an die Leute rankommt.
Genau, wenn man jetzt einen ganzen Jahrgang rausnimmt und ein Defizit von einer Million in einem Jahr Maximum sozusagen herstellt, das wäre einfach volkswirtschaftlich nicht zu tragen in Deutschland. Das geht überhaupt gar nicht. Und dieses Argument fand nun so gar nicht statt. Selbst wenn man nur 200.000, 300.000 Leute daraus nimmt, ist es einfach brutal. So, jetzt haben wir die Glocken angefangen.
Man wundert sich aber auch, Steinmeier hat ja durchaus mit Politikern zu tun. Da könnte doch mal jemand, der es weiß, anrufen und sagen, Frank, ich kann dir das ja mal schnell sagen, das wäre eine Katastrophe, wenn wir das machen.
Also den Verbänden schlottern die Knie davor, dass die jetzt irgendwie abgezweigt werden, um so ein Pflichtjahr irgendwo zu machen. Es gibt so große Bemühungen, den Leuten irgendwie auszureden, mach keinen Gap, komm direkt in die Berufe, studiere nur Bachelor, Master, brauchst du nicht und so weiter. Und da jetzt, was die Politik da gerade veranstaltet, ist so kontra zu dem ganzen Ansehen, dass die Unternehmen und Verbände so haben. Es ist wirklich abenteuerlich, aber es schlägt sich nirgendwo nieder. Und jetzt hören wir das Interview, das mit Jessica Rosenthal, der Juso-Vorsitzenden im Deutschlandfunk-Interview-Programm geführt wurde. Es ist haarsträubend, aber wir steigen mal locker ein.
Am Telefon nun die Juso-Vorsitzende Jessica Rosenthal für die SPD im Bundestag. Guten Morgen.
Guten Morgen.
So, die Stimmung ist gut. Guten Morgen, guten Morgen.
Es muss darum gehen, dass ehrenamtliches Engagement insgesamt attraktiver wird ja auch für junge Menschen, aber eigentlich ja auch für alle.
Bleiben wir in Israel noch für einen Moment? Auch dort, Sie wissen es, gab es Corona, gab es die Pandemie, gab es einen harten Lockdown. Und dennoch stellt niemand dort den Kibbutzgedanken. Also das Engagement für das Kollektiv, für die Gesellschaft, über die unbedingte Wahrung der eigenen individuellen Freiheit, das Sie jetzt sehr betonen.
So, sie kommt also die ganze Zeit darauf zu sprechen.
Ehrenamt muss man stärken, aber nicht verpflichtend.
Genau, nicht verpflichtend. Und warum nicht für alle? Das ist doch eine deutschlandweite Bevölkerungsaufgabe. Jeder, der Kapazitäten hat und helfen möchte, kann doch einfach machen, wieso muss das der 18- 19-Jährige sein, der gerade so aufbrechen will in sein eigenes Leben? Und total unvermittelt, weil er gelesen hatte in der Vorbereitung, ach, die Jessica Rosenthal hat doch mal biografischen Abstecher nach Israel gemacht. Und da gibt es ja dieses komische Prinzip. Und da helfen ja auch alle dem Kollektiv und so weiter, wie man das halt so übialisiert dann in so ein Gespräch reinholt. Und bringt das hier einfach an, nur um ihr sozusagen ihre verbalisierten Argumente rauszunehmen und mit so einem biografischen, eingedichteten Argument irgendwie zu kommen. Gilt denn dieses Prinzip da nichts?
Ja, aber er sagt ja auch gar nicht, was eigentlich mit der Kibbutz-Idee verbunden ist. Nämlich Vergemeinschaftung von Eigentum. Das ist ja nicht einfach nur, wir opfern unsere Jugend für irgendwas auf, sondern das meint wirklich ein gemeinschaftliches Leben. Und meint vor allem ein Leben, in dem die Eigentumsrechte mal ganz hart angetastet werden. Und da wird tatsächlich Eigentum vergemeinschaftet. Und das ist ja im Prinzip eine, also die Kibbutz-Idee ist ja sehr nah an sozialistischen Ideen. Und wird ja auch immer wieder von Linken aufgegriffen. Also ob so eine Form des Zusammenlebens sein kann, wird auch dann ein wichtiges Thema, wenn man sagt, wie organisiert man Familie, wenn das nicht mehr nur Mama, Papa, Kind ist, sondern wenn da sich andere Konstellationen ergeben. Da gibt es dann in der nicht-orthodoxen Kibbutz-Idee natürlich hochinteressante Ansätze. Und da müsste man sofort eigentlich kontern und sagen, ja, also das ist wirklich eine gute Idee von Steinmeier. Wir müssten dann vielleicht erst einmal alle Wohnungen vergemeinschaften, damit wir ja dann keine Miete mehr zahlen müssen. Und dann können wir aber auch gemeinsam dafür sorgen, dass Leute gepflegt werden. Das wäre die richtige Antwort, das wäre die Kibbutz-Idee.
Also die Geschichte Israels, gerade der Gründungsmoment, ist natürlich religiös geprägt. Das ist für uns hier in Deutschland sehr wichtig. Aber das ist auch die eigentlich ganz strenge Auslegung bis hin zu kommunistischen Ideen und so weiter, die da über Jahrzehnte ja auch mitgezogen wurden. Naja, er hat das so versucht. Jetzt kommt sie mit, ja dann kann ich ja mal eigene Erfahrungen reinbringen. Ich habe ja auch ein soziales Jahr in Deutschland gemacht.
Wenn es dann darum geht, dass mehr junge Menschen Freiliegendienst machen, dann glaube ich, haben wir da ganz andere Hebel und Instrumente. Im Moment ist es nämlich so, dass das vor allem diejenigen machen können, die sich das leisten können, weil es einfach sehr, sehr schlecht vergütet ist. Man erst mal gucken muss, wie kriegt man es überhaupt mit der Wohnung hin. Ich habe das selber auch gemacht und weiß, dass das nicht einfach ist und hätte das ohne die Unterstützung meiner Eltern auch nicht machen können.
So, sie bringt jetzt den Punkt rein. Ich habe ein soziales Jahr gemacht, freiwillig, aber ohne Bürgschaft meiner Eltern für die Miete an dem Ort, wo ich mich jetzt für die Gesellschaft einbringe, war da nichts zu machen. Das ist natürlich die Erfahrung, die man hier einfach mal anbringen muss.
Jetzt einfach mit dem Pflichtjahr um die Ecke zu kommen, weil das super einfach wäre und dann ja auch auf die Kosten von jungen Menschen passiert. Das finde ich wirklich falsch und gerade jetzt in dieser Zeit auch mal mehr.
Nun gibt es aber auch Menschen, egal welche Altersgruppe, die das große Ich auf der Stirn tragen und nur ihr eigenes Wohlbefinden im Kopf haben. Würde hier eine soziale Pflichtzeit auch diesem Teil der Gesellschaft, und den gibt es ja, vielleicht weiterhelfen, den eigenen Egoismus in Frage zu stellen. Auch darauf zielt ja Frank-Walter Steinmeier ab.
Das ist ein egoistischer Gedanke, den der hat, nur nicht für die Jungen.
Also er hier stellt jetzt einfach in den Raum, es gibt ja in vielen Generationen Menschen, die das große Ich auf der Stirn tragen. Völlig unreflektiert haben wir ja eine Babyboomer-Generation, die hier im Schnitt einfach pro Haushalt 600.000 Euro auf sich vereinigt. So, und wenn man dann deren Kinder sich anschaut, sind es nur 70.000 Euro. Da ist irgendwie eine Lücke dazwischen. Das kann man sagen, ja gut, die sind ja auch älter, die hatten ja mehr Zeit, das Ding aufzubauen. Nur dann schaut man sich die Lohnentwicklung an und sagt, nee, das schaffen die nie. Also wer heute da startet, müsste irgendwie... Also es gibt auch Jüngere, die vermögend sind. Nur das Medianvermögen und die Spitzen 10% sind halt mit Faktor 14 auseinander. Und das Gehaltsgefüge ist aber so eng, dass man das nie aufholt. Also man kommt nie in diesen Reichtumsrange rein, den Babyboomer da gerade haben und geben die irgendwas ab, senken die irgendwie ihre Mieten, wenn die Vermieter sind und so? Nee, gar nicht.
Dass ich nicht so in den Mittelpunkt stelle. Ja, das ist so. Dann könnte ich auch sagen, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, stellt doch nicht immer euer Ich so in den Mittelpunkt. Ich könnte gut, Haushälterin, Chauffeure, alles könnte ich gut brauchen, Gärtner, kommt doch, arbeitet bei mir gratis. Denn das ist ja auch ein Dienst an der Gemeinschaft.
50 Sklaven arbeiten für uns. Warum nicht direkt vor unserer Haustür? Warum nur in Afrika? Warum haben wir das nicht auf dem Dienstleistungssektor? Warum nur bei der Güterproduktion?
Einfach mal das Ich überwinden.
Es ist unglaublich. Sie versucht jetzt über den nächsten Einschlag. Wie viel engagieren Sie eigentlich schon?
Wenn 63 Prozent von jungen Menschen sich engagieren, dann ist es ja der Regelteil, dass junge Menschen ehrenamtlich aktiv sind.
Aber keine Lust haben, schön und gut, Frau Rosenthal. Aber muss man in den Köpfen der jungen Menschen nicht verankern, dass man in einer Demokratie nicht nur Rechte hat, nicht nur individuelle Freiheiten hat, sondern eben auch Pflichten? Wir haben John F. Kennedy zu Beginn dieser Sendestunde gehört. Ist diese Weisheit für Sie tatsächlich aus der Zeit gefallen?
Es ist auch keine Weisheit. Es war eine große Dummheit von John F. Kennedy. Und das ist einfach nur, damit die herrschende Klasse weiter ihren Besitz stabilisieren kann, hat John F. Kennedy das gesagt und hat damit natürlich viele junge Menschen in den Krieg und in den Tod geschickt. Also das ist einfach richtig falsch, dieser Satz. Und man muss ja auch zur Kenntnis nehmen, dass wir in einem Kapitalismus leben, der natürlich auf Eigennutz aufgebaut ist. Also wir können ja dann wieder gerne nochmal die Kibbutz-Idee heranführen an das Ganze. Aber einfach so zu tun, als seien das, ja, das ist die jungen Leute denken nur an sich. Ich kenne tatsächlich auch nur Leute, die an sich denken.
Ja, und sie hatte auch gerade vorgestellt, ja, mehr als 60 Prozent engagieren sich hier schon, wo ich mir so ein bisschen denke, ja, wann denn die Schule geht, bis 16 Uhr, und dann musst du noch, was weiß ich und so weiter zu erledigen. Ja, es ist einfach abenteuerlich. Dann kommt da so mit dieser John F. Kennedy um die Ecke. Was hier noch fehlt, sind Stereotype, die man auch so ein bisschen, wie soll man sagen, etwas zu locker ins Gespräch einfällt.
Wir machen jetzt eine Pflicht, ja, ist auf diese Debatte keine Antwort. Sie scheint einfach zu sein, aber es ist keine Antwort, die dieses Problem wirklich behält. Das ist ein ganz anderes, was viel breiter ist und was auch z.B. in Schule und an anderen gesellschaftlichen Orten, die Stärkung von Vereinen und so weiter, im freiwilligen Bereich, im zivilgesellschaftlichen Bereich gestärkt werden muss und zwar breit.
40%, also 63% engagieren sich, sagen Sie, engagieren sich nicht. Sie sagen, 60% engagieren sich, also fast die Hälfte engagiert sich nicht. Und der Bundespräsident fordert ja auch, dass man durch ein Pflichtjahr gezwungen wird, seine eigene Blase zu verlassen, um dann neue Erfahrungen zu machen. Frau Rosenthal, ein Jan Malte in einem islamischen Kulturverein oder ein Achmed bei der freiwilligen Feuerwehr auf dem Karriereplatz. In einem katholischen Land, in Bayern, ist das nicht richtig, damit man seine eigene Blase verlässt und neue Erfahrungen macht und das hält dann die Gesellschaft zusammen?
Ja, Zwangsum-Siedlung ist natürlich auch eine schöne Idee und zeigt aber auch wieder diesen Boomer-Talk, anders kann man das ja nicht bezeichnen. Jungen Leute, auch die Jan Malte heißen, haben längst mit Achmit zu tun. Richtig, ganz genau. Also wo sollen die sich denn herumtreiben? Also in welchem Q-Cuff sollen die dann noch leben, wo die Achmit nicht begegnen?
Also das ist ja ganz erstaunlich, das kriegt ja jeder mit in der Schule. Treffen alle zusammen. Schon allein, weil in der Grundschule ist das Einzugsgebiet wie es ist. Da kannst du dich eh nicht dagegen wehren. In der weiterführenden Schule, klar, findet eine gemäßigte Separierung statt.
Ja, könnte man auch überdenken, aber dann hätte man auch noch mal mehr Vermittlung.
Ja, also jetzt bei meiner Tochter, das sind 1400 Schüler. So, da sind einfach alle vertreten. Aber klar, es ist immer noch, spätestens dann mit den Abiturjahrgängen und so weiter, hat man die ökonomische Herkunft, die sich da vererbt. Im Studium lernt man keine Realschüler mehr kennen. So, der normale Student von heute hat so viel zu tun und der ganze Kram und der Schulabgänger.
Der Azubi hat auch mit den Studenten eher wenig.
Genau, da differenzieren sich die Milieus und es wird nie wieder aufgehoben. So, wir haben also dieses Problem, dass Jan Malte nicht beim Islamverband mal vorstellig wird und da versucht mitzuhelfen in der Gemeinde. Das ist nicht das Problem der unter 30-Jährigen, sondern der über 40-Jährigen und zwar durch die Bank.
Alle.
Und dann mit solchen Ideen hier einfach ihr komplett, also wirklich an ihr vorbei zu reden. Sie versuchte die ganzen Punkte zu machen. Sie engagieren sich eh schon, wir sollten uns alle engagieren, der Gedanke ist richtig, aber warum nur die Jungen und so. Eigentlich hätte sie ihn persönlich ansprechen sollen.
Aber man muss da wirklich so dran und was machen sie?
Ja, was genau die Professoren heute in Deutschland, also Professorenstellen werden ja sowieso nach komischen Prinzipien vergeben, aber man muss in seinem Lebenslauf mittlerweile soziale Projekte drin haben und nichts fällt diesen angehenden Akademikern, also schon Akademikern, die dann ihre Dissertation fertig haben, die Abilitation geplant und dann, äh, welcher Verein, hm, keine Ahnung, und dann wird ihnen das so alle leiden, genau, es ist so völlig Banane.
Dann werden so komische Konstrukte da geschaffen, irgendwas, Verein für französische Übersetzer oder so.
Ja, genau, die haben gar keine Sorgen, ihre Publikationsliste und so weiter, die Biografie ist voll. Und dann kommt diese Frage soziales Engagement.
Ich hab das auch so miterlebt, dass dann über, ja, in eine Gewerkschaft gehen, was kommt denn da auf mich zu?
Ja, genau, es ist einfach durch und durch. Na ja, die letzten 15 Sekunden spiegeln es eigentlich ganz wunderbar. Aber sie fragt nochmal nach der Altersfrage und er guckt nochmal auf seinen Zettel, was er sich vorher aufgeschrieben hatte.
Ich finde auch die Verengung auf junge Menschen total falsch. Ich weiß gar nicht, wo die herkommt, ehrlich gesagt. Aber dann bin ich da total für, diese ganzen Fragen zu stärken. Aber nicht mit dem Pflicht, der, weil es keine Antwort darauf ist.
Was ist denn falsch daran? Ich verstehe es nicht, jemanden zu zwingen, den eigenen Horizont zu erweitern.
Genau, ich könnte vielleicht mit dem Zwang zusammenhängen. Das ist wahrscheinlich aber auch derselbe Mensch, der sonst keine Einschränkungen duldet. Weil man sagt, das können wir jetzt hier unsere Freiheit nicht uns rauben lassen.
Also einfach eine Debatte zu führen, in dem man sagt, ich habe ein Interview mit einer jungen politischen Frau und dann mache ich einfach nur Gegenargumente, die ich mir vor ausgedacht habe und höre gar nicht zu bei diesem Gespräch, um was es da geht, zeigt dir wirklich, wie sehr die Generationen aneinander vorbei reden. Also ich fand das wirklich auch sehr, er hat es halt mal so explizit einfach gemacht, dieses Kaltschneuzige, das komplett Ignorieren, was ja eigentlich Sachstand ist, was ihm vorgetragen wird an Wünschen und Vorstellungen der jungen Leute und das nochmal gespiegelt mit diesem, hat er ein Interview geführt zum Thema Kinderkliniken, zum Thema Lehrermangel, zum Thema Kita-Qualität und so weiter? Nein, hat er natürlich nicht, sondern nur sowas wird dann da einfach durchgepaugt in so einem Interview.
Hat er aber irgendwann mal Glück und hat bestimmt noch einen schönen alten Vertrag. In Amerika gibt es ja Erfreuliches zu berichten, die Gewerkschaften werden stärker. Ein wichtiger Protagonist ist Chris Smalls, der ja bei Amazon entlassen wurde. Und weil er eine Gewerkschaft gründen wollte, hat sich dann da zurückgeklagt und hat es geschafft, dann die erste Amazon-Gewerkschaft zu gründen. Weiteres geschieht da gerade und es ist beeindruckend zu sehen. Wir müssen jetzt Abstraktionen selber leisten. Also wir hören jetzt, wir bekommen sie zum Teil dann auch geliefert, aber wir hören jetzt immer nur Stimmen von Leuten, die wirklich in einem Arbeitskampf sind. Wir hören jetzt nicht die Analyse, die müssen wir jetzt leisten. Wir müssen aber jetzt erst mal festhalten, es gibt so etwas wie eine Arbeiterlosigkeit offenbar. Also es gibt zu wenig Leute in den westlichen Ländern, in den USA ist das auch. Es ist noch unklar, ob das wirklich ganz so ist. Also es gibt ja auch Leute wie Philippa Siegel Klöckner, die sagen, ja, aber wenn diese Arbeiterlosigkeit da sei, also wenn eine hohe Nachfrage nach Arbeit ist, aber das Angebot nicht das, dann müssten ja eigentlich auch die Löhne steigen. Das tun sie ja in Deutschland interessanterweise momentan nicht.
Aber da muss man auch schon sagen, es ist eben eine konzertierte Aktion des Kanzleramts auf Ansinnen der Industrieverbände, um die Gewerkschaften so ein bisschen schon mal im Vorfeld, bevor die Tarifrunden ankommen, um den schon mal zu verklickern. Die wehren sich jetzt auch dagegen. Der DGB hat ja eine neue Chefin, die da sehr engagiert reingeht und von der Lohnpreisspirale auch nicht viel hält, wie zum Beispiel auch Marcel Fratscher nicht. Das wird ein ganz interessanter Kampf hier in Deutschland. Diese sieben Prozent, die jetzt gerade auftauchen, auf der einen Seite Inflation, auf der anderen Seite...
Ja, das wollten wir vielleicht noch gerade deutlich machen, Lohnpreisspirale meint, dass man also eine Inflation dadurch immer weiter entfacht, indem die Preise steigen. Dann sagt man, wir müssen die Löhne daran anpassen und dann werden aber die Preise wieder erhöht, weil die Löhne ja erhöht wurden und so weiter. Und dann kommt man da nicht mehr raus. Es gab sowas tatsächlich auch in den 70er Jahren. Aber es ist jedenfalls so, dass wir es heute mit einem ganz anderen Zustand zu tun haben. Also wenn wir jetzt auf Großbritannien blicken, damals waren die Gewerkschaften immens stark und dann hat Setscher über Jahre das dann zerschlagen und Tony Blair hat dann noch den Rest der übrig war kaputt gemacht. Und das ist also eine ganz andere Voraussetzung, unter denen jetzt diese Arbeitskämpfe stattfinden. Auch in Amerika, da war dann die Reagan-Regierung auch hier, Niedriglohnsektor und so weiter. Das heißt, die Gewerkschaften sind geschwächt. Das heißt, selbst wenn man sagt, es gab so etwas wie eine Lohnpreisspirale, dann können wir nicht sagen, ach, jetzt wiederholen die da die 70er Jahre. Nein, die Gewerkschaften sind in einer ganz schwachen Position und die Arbeiter an sich sind in einer sehr schwachen Position. Das ist eben nicht vergleichbar. Und was jetzt getan wird, ist zu sagen, ihr könnt jetzt keine Lohnerhöhungen fordern, denn wir haben ja diese Inflation, was eigentlich heißt, man sagt den Leuten, ja, also wir haben natürlich jetzt so seit 2008 ging es ja für uns nur aufwärts. Wir haben richtig gut profitiert, wir hatten Wirtschaftswachstum, wir hatten billiges Geld, wir sind immer reicher geworden. Jetzt ist das für uns vorbei, diese Party erst einmal. Ach so, jetzt wollt ihr auch mal was haben. Nee, also jetzt ist gerade aber ein ganz schlechter Zeitpunkt. Und man hat ja in den letzten zwölf Jahren, 14 Jahren auch nicht Lohnerhöhungen und so weiter gemacht. Und jetzt hat man wieder ein anderes Argument gefunden, warum man es nicht tun will.
Also diese Lohnpreis-Spirale ist eigentlich, ich bin gespannt, ihr werdet das bestimmt auch in Wohlstand für alle noch mal thematisieren. Denn das ist ein bisschen wie mit dem Wirtschaftswunder. Wer hat es verursacht? Ist es wirklich der Erhard gewesen? Oder ist das so retrospektive Sense-Making, Geschichtsschreibung, die ihm das so unterjubelt, weil er gerade und so weiter.
Denn wir hatten ja auch eine Ölkrise in den 70er Jahren, die auch inflationäres dann verursacht hat. Da hat der Lohnpreis-Spirale nichts mit zu tun.
Genau, diese Erzählung von Helmut Schmidt, der meinte, dass mit dem autofreien Sonntag haben wir damals als Symbol gemacht, damit die Leute verstehen, dass es Auswirkungen der Weltpolitik hat. Eigentlich hatten wir gar nicht so wenig Öl und so weiter. Bei der Lohnpreis-Spirale gibt es zwei Sachen, die glaube ich ganz wichtig sind. Einmal sachlich und dann auch einmal wieder zeitlich. Löhne sind auch Preise, nur aus der anderen Richtung betrachtet. Das ist eigentlich der wichtigste Preis, nämlich der Preis auf Arbeit. Also von Löhnen und Preisen in einer Spirale zu sprechen, ist schwierig, denn es ist eine Preis-Preis-Spirale. Die Frage ist nur, sind diejenigen, die die Güter anbieten, teuer, indem sie Produkte teuer haben oder teuer machen? Das ist auch immer so eine Frage. Sind die wirklich so teuer oder bereichert sich da gerade jemand? Also ganze Übergewinn-Diskussion. Und auf der anderen Seite, die Lohnpreis-Spirale, so wie sie thematisiert wird, soll ja vermieden werden, damit nicht durch mehr Geld auf Lohnempfängerseite eine Nachfrage entsteht, die dann nicht bedient werden kann, die die Preise wieder anhebt. Was ja bedeutet, aha, es gibt also einen Zusammenhang zwischen, es muss auch konsumiert werden. Es geht nicht nur um das Anbieten von, sondern ja, der Gegenpol ist das Konsumieren. Wenn man das aber eingesteht, indem man eine konzertierte Aktion gegen eine Lohnpreis Spirale macht, muss man auch mit einrechnen, dann gilt auch das Argument, wenn wir die Preise auf Arbeit nicht erhöhen, also die Löhne niedrig bleiben, können die faktisch weniger konsumieren, was ja auch wieder die Wirtschaft dimmt, kontraproduktiv ist in diesem Sinne. Und dadurch ist diese Lohnpreis Spiralen Diskussion super knifflig, weil irgendwo sind Defizite aufgelaufen und die müssen dann abgearbeitet werden und es ist trotzdem ein Kreislauf. Die Frage ist dann nur, leiden zuerst die Unternehmen darunter, dass da wieder Preisanpassungen stattfinden müssen und deswegen Konsum einbricht oder ist es sozusagen derjenige, der von seinem erarbeiteten Geld auch was kaufen will und dann aber nichts kriegt, weil er eben durch Inflationsdruck weniger kaufen kann und so. Und Spirale ist dann glaube ich das Wichtige, nämlich dass das irgendwie zirkulär ist und dann in so eine Richtung führt, also Spirale nach unten, so dieser Strudel. Eigentlich müsste man von Preis-Preis-Strudel sprechen, statt von der Lohnpreis-Spirale. Und ich bin sehr gespannt, also als Olaf Scholz, wir hören das nachher auch beim Industrietag, da diese konzertierte Aktion angekündigt hat, was das ja nun wirklich heißt, wir vertrauen hier den marktwirtschaftlichen Prinzipien nicht mehr, sondern wir müssen zurück an einen Tisch und dann muss die gute Gesellschaft, der die Verantwortung haben, mal irgendeine Entscheidung treffen in der Hoffnung, dass wir dann eine Marktwirtschaft wieder zum Laufen kriegen, das sind schon echt knifflige Momente für alle Beteiligten, in der niemand so richtig Macht hat, sondern alle nur so particuläre Interessen erstmal haben, aber man nicht genau weiß, kann man jetzt hier noch irgendwas gewinnen in dem Spielchen oder so, kann man jemanden übervorteilen?
Wir sollten ja nicht vergessen, dass wir während Corona durch Kurzarbeitergeld, wir hatten ja damals auch diese Daimler Aktionärskonferenz uns angehört, Wir haben dort ein System geschaffen, bei dem der Staat einsprang, damit die Unternehmen weiterhin große Profite machen konnten. Und das wurde von unten nach oben verteilt. Die Arbeiter haben ein bisschen weniger bekommen. Die kamen dann das sogenannte Kurzarbeitergeld. Da wurde immer gesagt, wir retten damit die Arbeitsplätze. Das stimmte auch zum einen. Aber zum anderen hat man damit natürlich die Lohnkosten, also den Preis der Arbeit, ganz niedrig gehalten für die Unternehmer, weil der Staat eingesprungen ist. Und jetzt ist das nicht mehr so. Jetzt sehen die plötzlich, wir müssen jetzt wieder wie früher wirtschaften. Und dann kommt noch diese Tendenz hinzu, dass plötzlich Gewerkschaften merken, wir könnten ja auch mal den Mond aufmachen. Und da, muss ich ganz ganz sagen, sollten sich die Arbeiter keineswegs jetzt einreden lassen. Das ist jetzt aber unverantwortlich, dass du gerade mehr Lohn haben willst. Die anderen haben die Taschen voll gemacht. Ganz unverantwortlich auch während der Corona-Krise.
Genau, also wir gehen jetzt die amerikanische Diskussion durch. Ich will nur kurz teasern, worüber wir nachher noch sprechen. Beim Industrietag waren natürlich alle Bundesminister von Rang und Namen und der Kanzler da, auch Lindner und Habeck. Während Lindner dort seine Ideologie vorträgt, irgendwie im Gleichschritt mit der Industrie, steht Habeck eben auf der Bühne und sagt, ich verkürze es mal auf den relevanten Teil, wir sind jetzt in einem Punkt an der historischen Entwicklung unserer volkswirtschaftlichen Übung, die wir ja gemeinsam unternehmen, sie und ich, bei der wir uns nicht verarschen dürfen. So oft wie die gesagt, und zwar in seinen philosophisch blumigen literarischen Worten. Also da war einiges los.
Ja, nun warum ist es in Amerika so, dass die Löhne steigen? Es gab ja diese Idee von beiden, der sich dann auch spät angeschlossen hat, das war ja eigentlich was aus dem Sanderslager, dass man einen viel höheren Mindestlohn braucht. Ich glaube, das waren dann sogar 15 Dollar, die damals gefordert wurden und dann wurde das nicht durchgesetzt. Und dann sagte man, ah, seht ihr, jetzt kann man schon fast sagen, es erübrigt sich so langsam, weil einfach die Löhne extrem steigen in den USA.
Amazon hat das ja antizipiert, die haben ja die 15 Euro überall.
In vielen Sektoren. Amazon ist darauf angewiesen, dass sie weiter ausliefern können müssen, deswegen gute Konditionen auch anbieten. Und eine These, warum das jetzt gerade noch mal so eine Dynamik hat, die will ich mal aufgreifen, die Adam Toos gesagt hat. Und zwar hat er gemeint, wir haben das in Europa nicht und vor allem in Deutschland haben wir das momentan noch nicht, weil diese Leute durch Kurzarbeitergeld ja einfach in ihren Jobs gehalten wurden. Und bei den Amerikanern war es ja so, dass die einfach entlassen haben. Und zwar Millionen Menschen entlassen haben, als der erste Lockdown kam. Wenn man entlassen ist, dann orientiert man sich vielleicht um und all das. Aber ganz wichtig ist, man verhandelt ja den Lohn wieder neu. Das heißt, man guckt, man vergleicht und man kann in anderer Weise dem Arbeitgeber zu verstehen geben, ich will jetzt mehr haben, als wenn man im Job ist. Und er geht davon aus, dass das ein Grund dafür ist, warum da so eine Lohndynamik überhaupt entstanden ist. Denn erst einmal leuchtet das ja gar nicht so ein, weil die Gewerkschaften ja viel schwächer in den USA sind. Aber dadurch, dass die Karten da neu gemischt wurden, weil man die erstmal rausgeworfen hat, hat sich das verändert.
Ja, also der Arbeitsmarkteinbruch, da ging es ja damals um 30 Millionen Menschen oder so. Die hatten ja wöchentlich Rekordarbeitslosenmeldungen, was ja am Ende sich wirklich auf 10 Prozent der Leute, die da gearbeitet haben, sind irgendwie wirklich rausgefallen. Und in dem Moment, wo die sich wieder neu bewerben und feststellen, ich hätte jetzt zwei oder drei Gelegenheiten zu arbeiten, schon da beginnt ja dann so eine Lohnspirale nach oben irgendwie. Wenn dann so ein Unternehmen feststellt, ne, also wir haben ja echt gar keine Bewerber, die gehen alle woanders hin. Aber so langsam drängt es bei uns, wir brauchen jetzt mal jemanden. Man hat ja auch Opportunitätskosten in dem Moment, wo man eine Stelle nicht besetzt hat. So ein DAX-Konzern in Deutschland, das sind ja schon seit Jahren sechsstellige Beträge, die für Recruiting einer Stelle einkalkuliert werden. Das kann man sich mal gar nicht vorstellen. Das so eineinhalb Jahre Gehälter schon allein nur für die Besetzung einer Stelle draufgehen.
Das Recruiting ist ein wahnsinnig boomendes Geschäft. Also das ist jetzt gerade der Wachstumsmarkt überhaupt. Und Biden hat es ja selbst in so einer Rede gesagt, Pay them more. Da hat er dann tatsächlich so ausgerufen. Nun habe ich eben schon gesagt, wir sind nicht in den 60er Jahren, wir haben nicht die starken Gewerkschaften, aber wir haben natürlich diese Traditionen der 60er Jahre, wo Gewerkschaften sich überall doch sehr stark zeigten, auch in den USA. Und eine wichtige Protagonistin der Gewerkschaftsbewegung in den USA ist Dolores Huerta. Sie ist über 90 und es ist sehr schön zu sehen, dass sie jetzt auch Events macht. Da trifft sie sich mit Chris Smalls, der die Amazon-Gewerkschaft gekundet hat. Und sie kommt hier mal zu Wort.
Du hast den modernen Arbeitungsmovementen gestartet. Von Amazon, Starbucks, den Lehrern, die in ihrem Macht stehen.
Besonders die Leute, die mit ihren Händen arbeiten, die oft in die essentialen Arbeiter verabschieden.
Und ich bin glücklich, dass Amazon-Arbeiter und andere Arbeiter das gleiche tun.
Gewerkschaften sind die Grundlage für die Demokratie. So sieht sie das und das erfreut sie jetzt mit Smalls da zu sitzen. Und jetzt muss man sich überlegen, wie kann man eigentlich heute Gewerkschaftsarbeit machen? Und natürlich gibt es ja ganz viele Berufsfelder, die sind nicht mehr mit einfacher Gewerkschaftsarbeit zu erreichen. Also wo Leute in Fabriken natürlich gehen oder in Amazon-Lager, da kann man relativ gut noch Menschen miteinander vernetzen. Nun sind ja Unternehmen stark auch dazu übergegangen, solche Subunternehmen anzustellen. Amazon ist da auch ein bestes Beispiel. Es gibt jetzt so einen neuen Panorama 3 Beitrag von Sebastian Friedrich und Philipp Henig, der sich mit diesen Subunternehmen auseinandergesetzt hat, die also die Pakete herumfahren, die aber nicht bei Amazon angestellt sind, sondern bei einem anderen Unternehmen, die enormen Druck bekommen, die auch die Löhne, die vertraglich festgeschrieben sind, dann nicht erhalten. Aber die haben natürlich kaum eine Möglichkeit, sich richtig zu organisieren. Da versuchen jetzt gerade die deutschen Gewerkschaften auch irgendwie, also wer die versucht, da die in einer Weise zu erreichen, aber es ist natürlich sehr schwierig. Chris Morse hat es da einfacher. Er beschreibt hier mal die Strategie, die er angewandt hat, damit er überhaupt erfolgreich sein kann.
Also sag uns mal, wie deine Taktiken, deine kreativen Taktiken, und warum haben sie funktioniert?
Die Art, die wir organisieren, ist, dass wir die Menschen zusammenbringen.
Und Amazon tut das nicht.
Sie haben ein System, das durch Metrix geht.
Also wir hatten ja diesen einen Text gelesen, wo die Rekrutierungsstrategie von Amazon da vorgestellt wurde, als die hunderttausende innerhalb eines Jahres so schnell gewachsen sind, wie niemals ein Unternehmen zuvor. Und da war ja einfach, heute ist hier, wer arbeiten will, kommt. Und dann saßen die alle schon in einem Wartezimmer zusammen. Und das will man ja eigentlich vermeiden. Die alte Industrie-Idee war ja, gibt jedem ein Haus, aber nur eins, wo nur ein Mann und eine Frau reinpasst, damit die sich bloß nicht nach Feierabend noch organisieren und so weiter. Und die sind ja wirklich als Gemeinschaft, ganze Communities einfach als Gemeinschaft bei Amazon aufgenommen wurden. Und wenn er jetzt sagt, na ja, wir kennen halt unsere Kollegen.
Ja, wir backen Brot, wir essen zusammen.
Wir fahren zusammen zur Arbeit, wir leben hier, da ist das Lager. Das ist, wir steigen da zu uns ins Auto ein und fahren halt dahin. Ja, ja, das ist halt Amazon wirklich gefährlich geworden.
Und Amazon hat ein perfekt funktionierendes System entwickelt. Es geht ganz schnell, wenn man da Pakete bestellt und es ist wunderbar optimiert. Aber das ist natürlich wie bei der frühen Industrialisierung, wie wir oder bei der Hochindustrialisierung, wie wir sie in Modern Times bei Charlie Chaplin sehen können, natürlich ein System der Entfremdung, das so aussieht, dass kein anderes soziales Angebot gemacht wird. Also es ist dann nicht wie der Google Campus, wo man sagt, hier sind die Sitzbälle und hier kann man was trinken und da kann man sich wohlfühlen und da gibt es auch eine Massage, sondern hier ist Entfremdung und da ist es natürlich sehr viel leichter zu organisieren. Also in gewisser Weise ist ja diese neoliberale Subjektivierung, die in modernen Unternehmen stattfindet, ganz schwierig da noch zu sagen, ja wir müssen uns mal organisieren, weil man sich ja schon so sehr mit dem Unternehmen identifiziert, dass man das gar nicht mehr so einfach kann. Hier fällt es den Leuten natürlich sehr leicht, sich in der Community wohlzufühlen, sich da zu identifizieren.
Also es gibt halt so eine virtuelle Schicksalsgemeinschaft, während Amazon alles dafür tut, dass sie nicht gleichzeitig Pause haben, dass jeder seine eigene Arbeitszeitende hat und nicht plötzlich alle gemeinsam aus dem Lager raus. Aber ja, eigentlich bräuchte man dazu noch mal einen Film, der das wirklich zeigt, so um eins zu eins, wie ist das abgelaufen?
Genau. Und ich würde sagen, Chris Maltz hat auch großes Talent dafür. Man wollte jetzt gar nicht mehr von ihm abspielen, man muss sich mal so Auftritte wirklich ansehen, was das für Events inzwischen sind, wenn er auftritt und was das für Emotionen auch los ist. Das ist schon ganz erstaunlich, wie gut er das macht. Und er sieht ja wirklich aus wie ein Hip-Hopper.
Und redet ja auch so. Redet auch so.
Und ist aber jemand, der dann auch Chutzpah hat, wenn er auf Politiker trifft. Es gibt so einen Clip von einer Anhörung aus dem Mai, da war er im Kongress. Und dann ist dieser Lindsey Graham von den Republikanern, der dann sagt, ja, it's very dangerous, weil er dann meint, dass er jetzt einen Extremismus hier reinbringen würde, in die amerikanische Gesellschaft. Und dann sagt er einfach, das ist jetzt hier auch kein Ding zwischen Republikanern und Demokraten. It's a worker thing. Und dann sagt er, und ich würde an deiner Stelle mal gut zuhören, denn das sind auch Leute, die dich zum Teil gewählt haben, die wir jetzt hier unterschüttet sind.
Das ist einfach sehr gut. Er sollte das publizistische Bühnenprogramm ja auch das Buch selber schreiben, was dann als Drehbuchvorlage genommen wird und so weiter.
Wir springen zu einem anderen Redetalent nach Großbritannien, zu Mick Lynch. Das ist da der Gewerkschafter der Bahn. Und wir werden wissen, dass es im Transportwesen da auch drunter und drüber geht. Nicht nur bei den LKWs, sondern auch sonst bewegt sich da im öffentlichen Nahverkehr und so weiter nicht mehr allzu viel.
Falls ihr euch fragt, wer ist Mick Lynch, es lohnt sich wirklich. Und vielleicht ist er euch auch schon untergekommen, weil irgendwelche Freunde euch die Clips geschickt haben und so weiter. Ja, genau das ist der Typ.
Ganz genau. Und ich habe jetzt bewusst nicht ein Fernsehinterview rausgezogen, denn er kann auch ganz seriös und ruhig Sachlagen erklären. Ich dachte, es ist vielleicht mal ganz gut, diesen Auftritt mitzubekommen. Er ist jetzt da relativ spontan angereist. Es gibt jetzt auch so wilde Streiks, zum Teil, die einfach sagen, wir strecken jetzt mal gerade hier. Also nicht mit großer Anmeldung und drei Tagen, sondern er kommt dann einfach da hin und hält dann auch noch schnell spontan so eine 5-6 Minuten Rede und da hören wir jetzt mal rein.
Ja, das, was er hier macht, ist eine der wichtigsten Sachen für alle. Dass man immer ein gesellschaftliches Anliegen mit reinbringt, das über das eigene Ansinn hinausgeht. Denn man darf ja eins nicht ins Management des Unternehmens eingreifen. Also irgendwie, was weiß ich, der Wiselski darf nicht dem Management irgendwie Vorgaben machen oder nur eine Idee oder auch nur, die haben doch im Vorstand das und das diskutiert, die Alternative wäre besser gewesen oder so. Das darf man nicht, sondern man muss immer nur die Anliegen derjenigen, die man vertritt, der Mitarbeiter, die also dem Management ausgeliefert sind. Aber man darf und man muss, bei der E-Metall weiß ich, da legen die auch Wert drauf in der Ausbildung ihrer Mitarbeiter da. Man muss diesen gesellschaftlichen Charakter mit sich führen. Und das macht er so wunderbar.
Sagt gleich, sich selbst zu organisieren, das ist die Stärke, die wir haben.
Über das Eisabahnertum hinaus, sondern das ist hier ein großes allgemeines soziales Anliegen ist, dass sich an diesem einen Punkt, wo er Hoheit darüber hat, manifestiert, aber dass es sozusagen darüber hinausgeht.
Und nur so lässt sich auch dauerhafte Gewerkschaftsarbeit leisten, denn das ist ja auch ein großes Problem. Was, wenn Forderungen erfüllt werden? Das ist ja in gewisser Weise so eine psychoanalytische Struktur. Lacan sagt, gibt mir nicht, was ich begehre, denn dann ist das Begehren verschwunden. Und übertragen auf einen politischen Protest bedeutet das, wenn ich diese drei Prozent mehr Lohn bekomme, sage ich dann, ach ja, dann brauche ich aber auch jetzt nicht mehr gewerkschaftlich engagieren. Dann wird im nächsten freien Augenblick das Unternehmen wieder zugreifen und sagen, ach, wir streichen da gerade was, dass man das weiter am Laufen hält, die Arbeiten und dass sie nicht endet mit der Füllung einer Forderung. Das funktioniert nur, wenn man über diese konkrete Sache hinaus denkt.
Genau, das ist, manche Gewerkschaften in Deutschland haben das ein bisschen aus den Augen verloren und die vertreten nur noch den Rest Gewerkschaftsmitglieder, den sie haben und nicht darüber hinaus. Aber man muss immer auch an die künftigen Mitarbeiter, die man ja für sich anwerben möchte und dass es grundsätzlich allen besser geht. Also ich würde sagen immer die künftigen Gewerkschaftsmitglieder muss man mit reinholen und das macht man so ganz gut.
Dazu kommen wir gleich noch, das ist gut, dass du es schon ansprichst. Wie ist es denn jetzt? Inflation und Lohnerhöhung, geht das denn zusammen?
Und was sagen sie uns in diesen Interviews? Die Antwort ist eine Wiederverkaufung der Wöcher in diesem Land.
Das ist wichtig, darauf hinzuweisen, es wird weiterhin sehr viel Geld verdient.
Umverteilung. Gerade, und das kann man ja ewig ausschlachten. Was nützt es irgendwem volkswirtschaftlich, wenn die Renditen irgendwo abgeschafft werden, um dann irgendwo auf der Welt, irgendwo im Kunstmarkt zu versanden? Das ist natürlich auch kommunale Landschaftspflege, wenn Leute vor Ort einfach mal Geld haben, um da den Dienstleistungsbereich und wie auch immer ein bisschen nutzen zu können. Da musst du als Marxist natürlich sagen, ja klar, wer sonst, wenn nicht der menschliche Beitrag in dem Arbeitsgefüge führt dem Mehrwert herbei. Allerdings, Amazon gesteht ja auch diese 15 Euro Mindestlohn zu, weil sie wissen, das ist ein Auslaufmodell. Also umso höher wir den Preis für menschliche Arbeit machen, umso engagierter sind die ganzen Mittelmanager bei Amazon erpicht darauf, diesen hohen Kostenfaktor rauszuräumen und die letzte Handbewegung, für die man die Menschen noch braucht, durch Roboter zu ersetzen. Und Amazon ist so ein Unternehmen, das diese Theorie dann wirklich auf die Probe stellt, wenn man es schafft, fast bis vor die Haustür, ohne menschliche Arbeit vorzukommen. Adidas und so, die haben ja auch schon diese dunklen Fabriken, wo einfach nur noch Maschinen die Schuhe zusammenkleben und so weiter. Klar, der Mehrwert steckt dann immer noch in der Innovation der Roboter, die das dann halt bewerkstelligen und so weiter.
Aber wir haben ja dieses Buch von Benanef gelesen und wir wissen, dass diese ganzen Automatisierungsfantasien sich sehr schnell in Luft auflösen. Das ist ja auch so eine Richard-David-Precht-These, die er jetzt seit zehn Jahren vertritt. Und ich gucke mich immer um und denke, wo denn? Und wir klagen jetzt alle darüber, dass es kein Personal gibt, dass irgendwas nicht versendet werden kann, dass irgendwas nicht produziert werden kann. Und ich habe den Eindruck, ja, Amazon wird das sehr weit treiben. Aber selbst wenn die Löhne kräftig steigen, müsste das ja eine technische Entwicklung sein, die so brillant und rasant voranschreitet, dass das dann billiger wird. Und wenn man sich mal ansieht, was Technik kostet, und die muss ja auch mal wieder zusammengebaut werden und all das.
und Energieeffekte sind schon groß. Dann bin ich sehr gespannt. Also ich würde es eher volkswirtschaftlich sehen im Sinne von überall in der westlichen Welt sinken jetzt die Erwerbspersonenpotenziale. Das heißt, wir müssen eh anders verteilen. Es gibt sehr viele Berufe, für die haben wir einfach keine Menschen mehr.
Und du meinst, Migration wird nicht zugelassen. Und deswegen ist die einzige Möglichkeit, das dann über diese Weise zu machen, dass man sagt, gut, dann muss das alles rechronisch laufen.
In Deutschland, also wenn ich jetzt meine Rechnung da aufmache, dann ist das ja immer so dieses 700.000 von unten, 1, 1, 1, 2 Millionen oben, da ist eine Lücke dazwischen. Wenn wir jetzt eine wirklich spektakuläre Megamigration haben, dann heißt das beispielsweise fürs Jahr 2029, dass von unten nicht nur 730.000 18-Jährige, sondern 800.000 18-Jährige, aber es tauchen nicht plötzlich 1.000.000 18-Jährige bei uns auf. Deutschland ist auch ein Auswanderungsland. Wenn Detlef Scheele von der Bundesagentur für Arbeit davon spricht, dass wir 400.000 Zuwanderer pro Jahr brauchen, dann ist das schon die Netto-Summe. Die heißt in Brutto 1.000.000 Zuwanderer, weil 600.000 pro Jahr auch Deutschland verlassen. So, und das sind einfach Migrationsströme in Dimensionen, also wirklich mehrere, also mehr als 1.000.000, wenn nicht mehrere Millionen Zuwanderer pro Jahr. Das ist politisch nicht zu thematisieren gerade, das ist schwer zu organisieren, das ist einfach super kompliziert. Also selbst wenn wir jetzt davon reden, es gibt 100.000.000 Flüchtlinge dieses Jahr auf der Welt, ist Deutschland so ein attraktives Ort? Hat man hier schon Verwandtschaft? Haben wir eine Einborderungskultur? Haben wir eine Sprache, die sich leicht lernen lässt? Welche Erfahrungen werden zurückgemeldet von Leuten, die hier angekommen sind? Da haben es Länder wie England, Kanada und so weiter, trotz Brexit, trotz großer Entfernung, einfacher.
Gut, klammern wir mal ganz kurz Amazon aus, aber dann können wir ja jedenfalls feststellen, dass der Dienstleistungssektor wichtiger werden wird, der ganze Betreuungssektor, aber auch uns, was an Freizeit den Leuten zur Verfügung steht, wird ja auch gerne dann mit Personal bestritten, in der Form, dass man in Cafés sitzt oder was auch immer tut. Und das wird ja nicht ersetzbar sein, bzw. selbst wenn man es ersetzen könnte, will man das nicht. Also natürlich kann ich einen Selbstbedienungsladen machen, wo ich am Ende mich nur noch mit einem Fingerabdruck oder so verifizieren muss. Aber so möchte ja niemand in ein Café gehen. Sondern im Café möchte man ja begrüßt werden und vielleicht noch ein nettes Kompliment bekommen oder so etwas.
Dafür werden die Leute auch immer Geld bezahlen, dass man da bedient wird.
Genau, da glaube ich, muss man auch ganz klar sagen, da ist eine gute Verhandlungsposition jetzt eigentlich, um entsprechende Löhne einzufordern.
Also Richard David Brecht, klar, der schlägt da immer richtig so im Vorschlaghammer drauf. Aber bei VW arbeiten derzeit 600.000 Leute in zehn Jahren. Wenn das alles auf Ebo-Humilität umgestellt ist, schon allein, weil es in zehn Jahren einfach verboten ist, noch einen Verbrennermotor herzustellen. Also herzustellen, sondern man darf ihn ja nicht verkaufen. Das heißt dann, da sind einfach 200.000 Leute weniger beschäftigt, mit dieser Aufgabe, diese Mobilität fortzuführen. So, die können natürlich volkswirtschaftlich anders verplant werden. Also die werden niemals Bewerbungsschreiben an VW schreiben, obwohl die Autoindustrie immer noch der beliebteste Arbeitgeber, weil angeblich der sicherste ist. So, die können sich dann woanders bewerben. Das heißt, das Richard-David-Precht-Argument wird eventuell stimmen, aber wir werden es trotzdem nicht so merken, weil wir eben keine Nachwuchsschwemme haben, sondern dann einfach feststellen, jeder kommt unter. Die Arbeit ist uns ja gar nicht ausgegangen. Aber wir werden in zehn Jahren auch feststellen, statt 43 Millionen arbeiten halt nur noch 36 Millionen Menschen in Deutschland.
Aber weil nicht so viele mehr da sind. Aber nicht dieses Precht-Argument, wir brauchen mal dringend ein Grundeinkommen, weil die Leute alle arbeitslos werden.
Genau, das Grundeinkommen ist ein Argument.
Also eine Massenarbeitslosigkeit. Ich weiß gar nicht, was ferner momentan liegt als eine Massenarbeitslosigkeit.
Ganz genau. Also ich würde sagen, Richard David Precht hat so ein bisschen recht, dass es eine Umstrukturierung gibt im ganz großen Maßstab, die aber nicht bedeutet, dass wir jetzt ein Grundeinkommen brauchen, volkswirtschaftlich gerechnet, weil relevante Segmente da irgendwie rausfallen, sondern es ist dieses Graduelle und in zehn Jahren wird es für die Leute, was du willst, du willst ein Auto herstellen, bist du bekloppt und so, weil dann auch die ganzen Programme...
Ja, das ist so, wie man irgendwann nicht mehr eine Ausbildung zu näheren macht in Deutschland, aber das ist dann...
Ja, ich warte ja immer noch, dass Olaf Scholz jetzt einfach mal beginnt. Es war ein ganz wichtiges Anliegen von ihm und steht auch im SPD-Programm wirklich tief in der DNA drin, die Entakademisierung und die Aufwertung der Ausbildungsberufe, Handwerken und so weiter. Ich sehe das Programm dazu irgendwie noch nicht. Vielleicht hat er noch keine Zeit oder so, aber da bin ich mal gespannt, dass da und die haben das, die wollen das auch wirklich mit zum Stimmungswandel, die Aufwertung der Handwerker, eigentlich ergibt sich gerade fast von alleine, weil jeder einem den privaten Tipp gibt, mach lieber eine Ausbildung selbst mit Abitur, mach lieber eine ordentliche, solide Berufsausbildung, wo du einfach Aufträge bekommst und dann Monat für Monat des Abarbeitest, bevor du hier akademisch dich irgendwie verbeißt in drei Jahren irgendeinem Studium und danach vielleicht noch Promotion. Genau, ja, diese ganzen, also es verändert sich da eh schon, aber ich warte eigentlich noch auf die große politische Begleitung, die das mal so ein bisschen, das duale System noch mal, die Berufsschulen, die fallen ja nun wirklich komplett auseinander in Deutschland, dass man da noch mal Förderdinger, aber na, mal sehen.
Wir hören jetzt Mike McLinch zum Thema Outsourcing. Das ist, was du gerade angesprochen hast. Das ist das Problem der Gewerkschaften in Deutschland häufig, dass die ihre Leute vertreten und der, der in der Gewerkschaft ist, guckt rüber an der Werkbank und sagt, ach, das ist ja gar kein Genosse von ihr. Der ist ja von irgendeiner Zeitarbeitsfirma, der ist schon outgesourct. Also habe ich mit dem nichts zu tun. Und also muss da auch keine Solidarisierung stattfinden. Und das macht er. Ich habe das dann auch in mehreren Reden von ihm gehört. Immer ganz, ganz explizit und dann auch noch mal zu zeigen, wer sind die Arbeiter und wer ist denn von diesen ganzen schrecklichen Reformen und Gesetzen besonders betroffen? Das macht auch noch mal deutlich.
Genau, dieses Outsourcing. Also als ich vom RWB jetzt die Woche angefragt wurde, da kurzes Interviews geben zum Thema Altersarmut und Demografie. Wie hängt das eigentlich miteinander zusammen? Hat das jemand in der Redaktion, als es in der Planung war, mal mitbekommen und hat mich gleich angeschrieben als Vertreter der Freien, die dort arbeiten und meinte, ja, also zum Thema Altersarmut kann die Hälfte der Leute, die hier beim Programm beitragen, was sagen aus eigener Schicksalhaftigkeit, nämlich die ganzen Freien, die das Programm da tragen. Ich habe dann nicht reagiert, weil da sitze ich dann auch zu sehr zwischen den Stühlen. Ich kann natürlich nur mit dem Redakteur, der mir Fragen stellt, die dann ihm beantworten und ihm danken für die Gelegenheit, das da beizutragen. Aber das ist natürlich ein mega Thema, dieses Outsourcing, dass man mittlerweile selbst bei Porsche oder so arbeiten, die Leute, die bei Porsche arbeiten, am Fließband und der Kollege daneben, der genau die gleiche Arbeit macht, verdient nur die Hälfte davon. So, der wurde einfach outgesourct.
Ja, das öffentliche, öffentlich-rechtliche System hat das ja perfektioniert, was die Freien anbelangt. Was Leute, die eingeladen werden, also ich bekomme manchmal Anfragen, wo ich denke, ja wieso sollte ich jetzt zwei Tage für ohne Honorar irgendwas machen, für den öffentlich-rechtlichen? Warum? Also warum sollte ich nur, dass ich meiner Mutter sagen kann, heute Abend bin ich im Fernsehen?
Ja, und wir haben das besondere Problem in England, da gibt es halt diese Zero-hour-Contracts, Null-Stunden-Arbeitsverträge. Du musst immer in Bereitschaft sein, aber es kann sein, dass die dich einfach nicht anfragen. Du darfst aber auch nicht für die Konkurrenz arbeiten. Und du musst dann darauf vertrauen, dass die das intern schon irgendwie so regeln, dass jeder durch den Monat kommt über die Runden, aber die versprechen es dir halt nicht. Sobald da irgendwas passiert, wie mit Corona oder so, oder sei es nur intern, dass die so einen betrieblichen Schaden einfach erleiden, dann sind da einfach alle von jetzt auf gleich quasi gekündigt. Aber es wird ihnen nicht mal mitgeteilt, sondern sie werden einfach nicht mehr zum Dienst bestellt und damit füllen sie ihren Stundenzettel nicht und haben keinen Gehalt. So, und dieses Outsourcing, das kennen wir so in Deutschland gar nicht. Das ist in England, da hat es wirklich um sich gegriffen.
Ich empfehle da sehr die letzten Filme von Ken Loach, der sich genau dieser Thematik da annimmt. Was fordert Lynch? Eigentlich eine ganz schöne Formulierung und eine schöne Provokation in England, zu sagen, wir brauchen Bill of Rights for Workers. Er nimmt aber auch die Medien in die Kritik. Das ist etwas, was wir hier auch medial erleben können, wenn irgendwo gestreikt wird, dann heißt es immer, ja, aber die armen Leute, die dann nicht zur Arbeit kommen. Statt dann mal einen anderen Fokus zu setzen und zu überlegen, müsste man jetzt nicht auch sagen, die sollten auch noch mit streiken. Es wird immer so getan, als würde man alle Menschen um ihr Lebensglück bringen, wenn jetzt gerade irgendwo gestreikt wird.
Ja, ich verstehe dieses Prinzip sowieso nicht. Also ich verstehe das Prinzip Personalisierung im politischen Journalismus, in der Medienproduktion, wo auch immer. Wir wollen einfach Personen sehen. Dass wir aber die Straßenbahn, die nicht fährt, reduzieren auf, nee, da gibt es kein Unternehmen drum herum. Das ist auch keine technische Maschine. Das hängt einfach nur daran, ob diese Person morgens zur Arbeit erscheint oder nicht. Das ganze andere Gefüge wird komplett ausgeblendet. So ein ICE zum Beispiel, Lockführerstreik, dass ein ICE fährt, ja klar, der braucht einen Lockführer, der vorne drin sitzt, aber der Zug muss von 100 Leuten begleitet werden, die sich um alles Mögliche kümmern, um die Sicherheit, um die Personalorganisation und so weiter, um die Technik, die da dabei ist, um die Abrechnung, dass man dann auch immer schön kassiert und bezahlt, wenn man in einen Bahnhof eingefahren ist, weil die Deutsche Bahn immer noch so eine interne Leistungsabrechnung macht, wo jeder eins in den Haltepunkt abgerechnet wird, weil das eine ist ja der Betrieb des Bahnhofs und das andere ist ja der Zug, also müssen die miteinander noch Rechnung schreiben und so. Und wenn wir sehen, ein Zug fährt nicht, sagen wir, der Lockführer ist schuld. Und blende da alles andere aus. Obwohl man selber aus der Arbeitswelt, ich bin schuld, hä? Ich bin noch hier in einem riesigen Gefüge, ja. Also jeder kennt das aus seiner eigenen Arbeitswelt, dass man nur ein Teil des Ganzen ist. Aber sobald man die anderen beobachtet, ist es der Straßenbahnfahrer, die Bedienung, der Lockführer und so, die Kita-Erzieherin, die streikt und deswegen, und das finde ich auch krass, dass sich diese Wut, es funktioniert gerade nicht, nicht auf die Eigentümer abwälzen lässt, sondern immer der konkret sichtbare Mitarbeitende da irgendwie im Feuer steht. Und da finde ich, sollte man auch mal ein paar mediale Strategien irgendwie durchgehen, um diese Schuldfrage mal, die ja dann natürlich im Raum stehen, wenn die Infrastruktur nicht mehr funktioniert, dass man das mal irgendwie anders thematisiert.
Das habe ich mich jetzt auch schon häufiger bei meinen vielen Ärgernissen über die Bahn gefragt, müsste man eigentlich so eine Stelle haben, wo man wirklich mal böse werden kann? Denn man kann ja nirgends böse werden. Das regt einen ja noch viel mehr auf. Also ich bin ja reflektiert genug, um zu wissen, dass ich jetzt den Schaffner nicht anbrüllen kann dafür, dass es wieder nicht bei der Bahn funktioniert hat. Das kann ich ja nicht machen. Ich muss einfach sagen, ja leider verspätet. Können Sie mal gucken, ob da noch ein Ersatz dann fährt. Das ist die einzige Möglichkeit, die ich habe. Sonst kann ich ja nichts tun.
Genau. Du hast jetzt kein Smartphone mit dir, aber der Schaffner hat nur genau die Information, die jedem Nutzer der Bahn in der App angezeigt werden. Der hat darüber hinaus nichts. Der kann auch nicht einfach irgendeinen anderen Zug anrufen oder so, selbst das ist nur so, ich kann es versuchen, keine Ahnung. So wie man selber bei der Bahn anrufen könnte.
Man müsste dann Volker Wissing haben, der müsste sich dann jeden Abend drei Stunden zur Verfügung stehen, dass man ihn beschimpfen kann. So was kann man machen. Das wäre vielleicht eine Idee. Gut, jetzt gehen wir aber auch nach Deutschland. Denn auch hier wird gestreikt und zwar in der Pflege. Wird medial wenig repräsentiert. Das ist natürlich auch Teil des Problems, dass das medial nicht repräsentiert wird. Ich würde auch tatsächlich den Streikenden dort empfehlen, nochmal über Social Media aufzudecken. Denn es ist zum Teil katastrophal. Ich habe einige Pressekonferenzen mir angesehen. Ja, es ist ja schön, dass es überhaupt mal irgendwo sichtbar ist. Aber es ist zum Teil 1998. Und ich weiß nicht, kann man da nicht mal sich ganz kurz vernetzen mit drei Podcastern und sonst was und mal überlegen, was brauchen wir. Und es ist ja am Ende dann nur eine Webcam, die funktioniert und ein Mikro, in das man wirklich reinsprechen kann. Also das ist so, ich glaube, das würde sehr viel Effekte haben. Klar, die Amerikaner können das besser. Das ist beeindruckend, wenn du die Shows da siehst. Das schaffen wir im ZDF um 20.15 Uhr nicht, wie die ein Gewerkschaftsauftritt dann vielleicht mitunter hängen. So professionell muss es auch nicht sein, man muss auch nicht überprofessionalisieren. Aber wenn selbst für mich der will, das Informationsmaterial mitunter schwierig zu beschaffen ist, dann wird es schwierig.
Ja, aber ich will es auch nochmal betonen. Also letzten Monat waren die Wahlen in Nordrhein-Westfalen. Wir haben das hier ein bisschen thematisiert. Die Wahlen dort sind wichtig. Da leben 18 Millionen Menschen. Das ist fast ein Viertel von Deutschland. Das ist eine der größten und bedeutsamsten Wirtschaftsregionen Europas. So und in den drei Wochen vor dieser Wahl wurden alle Unikliniken Nordrhein-Westfalens bestreikt. Alle. Und danach immer noch. Und es war niemals auch nur irgendwo Thema. Ich habe alle Nachrichten dazu geguckt. Das ist einfach nirgendwo Thema. Und da muss man sich Gedanken darüber machen, wie schafft man das? Wie schafft man diese Aufmerksamkeit? Denn eine Uniklinik, ich weiß, hier in Frankfurt, das ist einfach wirklich ein Gebilde eigener Dimensionalität. So, das ist einfach riesig, gigantisch. Das sind Milliardenbudgets und so weiter. Wenn die ausfallen, wenn die nicht funktionieren, funktioniert nichts mehr. So. Und die funktionierten da nicht in dieser Wahl. Und trotzdem hat man es nicht hinbekommen, auch nur ein journalistisches Interesse darauf zu lenken, dass keine Uniklinik in Nordrhein-Westfalen funktionierte.
Und die Jury liegt natürlich auch bei den Journalisten. Das sind nämlich dieselben Leute, die du weißt, wenn fünf Corona-Fälle mehr sind, sagen, und jetzt müssen wir aber aufpassen, dass die intensiv beten und so weiter. Das ist ja genau das. Und dass man, also man muss, glaube ich, einfach provozieren. Also ich glaube, man muss dann wirklich mit provokanten Aktionen und mit einer entsprechenden Repräsentanz in den sozialen Medien das einfach so groß machen, dass die nicht mehr daran vorbei können. Das ist die einzige Chance, die man hat. Aber man kann nicht glauben, dass die sich dem annehmen werden aus Goodwill oder so. Da ist Hopfen und Malz bei den Meistern verloren.
Streikprojekte brauchen eine öffentliche Dimension und an der muss man auch mitarbeiten.
Ja, weil das ist ja Wahnsinn, wie intensiv diese Streiks sind. Also das ist ja erstaunlich, wenn irgendwo so paar Rechte rumspringen. Die machen mal ihren Spaziergang und sofort sind 100 Kamerateams da. Und hier wird ja richtig sich ins Zeug gelegt. Und dann ist es umso schlimmer, wenn es da nicht repräsentiert ist. Gut, wir hören jetzt ein Interview, das in der Deutschen Welle gegeben wurde, mit einer Pflegerin und einem Pfleger. Und jetzt spricht als erstes eine Intensivpflegerin. Und wir achten da mal auf ein Wort, das da fällt. Das ist uns auch aus Pandemie-Zeiten wohl bekannt.
Frau Schubacher, fangen wir doch mal mit Ihnen an. Was ist denn der Hauptgrund des Streiks bei Ihnen?
Ich bin schon 30 Jahre Krankenschwester und 20 Jahre Intensivschwester. Ich habe im Laufe der letzten Jahre gesehen, dass die Arbeitsbelastung einfach immer höher wird. Und ich teilweise in jedem Dienst schon triagieren muss, zu welchen Patienten ich als Erstes gehe. Ob ich Schmerzen als Erstes behandele oder Stuhlgang und Sigrete wegmache oder doch lieber Kreislaufprobleme und Beatmungsprobleme, die natürlich ganz oben auch verlässt zu stehen, zuerst behandeln.
Jetzt noch nicht in dem Sinne, wem lasse ich sterben oder nicht. Aber natürlich mit dem Endeffekt natürlich, dass da Leute unnötig leiden müssen, weil nicht genügend Personal da ist. Und hier haben wir Triage. Die Triage, die so nicht stattgefunden hat bei Corona aufgrund von Maßnahmen und und und so weiter. Hier wird es einfach mal so gesagt, nö, das ist mein Alltag.
Ja, reagieren ist für sie ein Grundbegriff in ihrem Alltag.
Ja, so jetzt kommt der Pfleger zu Bord und bringt auch den Aspekt der Demografie mit rein.
Herr Lüder, wie sehen Sie denn die Stimmung unter den Pflegekräften?
Die Patienten werden immer älter, sie werden immer aufwendiger, aber wir haben das gleiche Problem. Im Prinzip stellen, bleiben teilweise, halten ist ja unbesetzt, weil wir niemanden finden. Die Leute reduzieren auch bei uns die Stunden, die Azubis hören teilweise in der Ausbildung ausbrechen die ab. Dann haben wir jetzt viele Kolleginnen, die in Rente gehen, diese ganze Bruma-Generation geht jetzt demnächst in Rente, aber es kommen einfach viel zu wenige nach. Ja, bei einem viel höheren Aufwand, den wir halt einfach auch wir haben, weil auch wir haben Geräte, wir haben Diagnostik. Es wird nicht weniger, nur die Menschen werden weniger, die betäuen.
Ja, irgendwann haben wir nur noch Honorarärzte in Deutschland, die einfach fünf Tage die Woche sich da irgendwo hinschicken lassen für doppeltes Gehalt. Nirgendwo so verankert werden, dass sie irgendwie Verantwortung übernehmen, sondern morgen bin ich halt in Münster oder so.
Die müssen ein Memo abgeben am Ende, was sie getan haben.
Also die wirklich freitags die Klinik verlassen und denen das Schicksal der Patienten dort egal sein kann, weil sie einfach am Montag woanders arbeiten. Das wird eine Luxussituation für die Ärzte und das wird einfach ein Grusel für die Patienten. Also es ist einfach ganz schlimm.
Ja, denn das machen die natürlich immer klar bei all den Interviews, die man hört. Sie haben eigentlich keine Zeit, um sich mit den Nöten der Patienten-Auslandsetzung, geschweige denn mal, mit Angehörigen auch zu sprechen. Auch das könnte ja Teil einer Pflegeleistung sein, aber nein, das ist alles nicht gegeben.
Das ist tatsächlich in den letzten Jahren immer schlimmer geworden durch, wie gesagt, die zunehmende Mobilität der Patienten, also Mehrfacherkrankungen der Patienten, das Alter der Patienten spielt eine Rolle, es wird immer mehr operiert, was auch natürlich super ist, sind die ganzen technischen Erneuerungen, die gekommen sind in den letzten 20 Jahren. Das ist auch gut, das muss auch so sein, aber es muss auch Menschen geben, die diese Technik bedienen und die gut ausgebildet sind. Und das geht halt auch unter diese ganze Praxisanleitung, die Einarbeitung neuer Kollegen, die wirklich heulend in der Ecke sitzen, weil sie völlig überfordert sind, weil sie keine gute Einarbeitung hatten und die den Job wieder an den Nagel hängen, obwohl sie vielleicht gute Pfleger oder Pflegerinnen geworden wären. Das macht einen so traurig und man nimmt das dann natürlich auch irgendwann mit nach Hause.
Das ist das Argument, was wir eben schon gehört haben, wenn die jetzt mit ihrem Dienstpflichtjahr kommen, wenn die das debatre sehen, dann sagen die all ihren Freunden, tu es nicht, komm niemals in die Pflege.
Also ich habe eine sehr bittere und wütende Mail bekommen, weil ich beim letzten Mal im Salon Teaser davon sprach, dass gesunde Ernährung nachweislich besser gegen Corona hilft, als eine AstraZeneca Impfung. Ausdrücklich gesagt eine, denn es gibt ja nicht ohne Grund einen doppelten und dreifachen Impfschema und so weiter und so fort. Und angeblich verstehe ich aber dem ganzen Thema nichts und ich sollte die Studien nochmal nachreichen und so weiter und so fort. Und ich komme nicht umhin, auch hier wieder, es ist solche Sachen wie Corona, gut, das hatte jetzt ein eindeutiges Beuteschema, das sich zufällig passte, aber auch der Klimawandel und auch der demografische Wandel. Man kommt besser durch sein eigenes Leben, wenn man nicht drei- vierfach morbide, da irgendwie mit Übergewicht und Blutdruck und noch so weiter. Und am Ende ist der Beinbruch, wegen dem man da ist, sozusagen die Bagatelle im ganzen Gefüge. Sondern das ist kein neoliberales Gelaber oder so was, ein bisschen auf sich zu achten. Weil am Ende, klar, ist es von mir aus neoliberal, so ein Gedanke da drin, aber am Ende ist man so ein System ausgeliefert, dass einem da nicht helfen kann.
Ich würde mich zumindest nicht darauf verlassen, in allem was man da hört, denke ich, um Gottes Willen.
Durchschnittskontakt zwischen Arzt und Patient in Deutschland dauert sieben Minuten Gespräch. Das wird niemals mehr mehr werden, sondern allenfalls kann man die Qualität dieser sieben Minuten erhöhen, indem man schon mal mit seinem ausgedrückten PDF, das die Apple Watch hergestellt hat, zum Arzt geht, wo ja schon mal das EKG der letzten drei Tage, auch wenn nur so ein halbgares, nur auf der Apple-Uhr-Watch gemacht wurde und so. Klar, das ist dann nur ein Elektronenstrom und nicht acht, wie in der Klinik, aber es ist schon mal ein bisschen was, womit der Arzt was anfangen kann. So, und man kommt da nicht wieder raus aus diesem sehr bedrückenden, die Gesellschaft kann einem dann nicht so helfen, wie man da Hilfe braucht. Und es wird sehr viel Lebensqualität einfach bringen, wenn man zu einem Arzt geht und dem einfach ein ganz spezifisches Problem nennt und nicht als Wundertüte da auftaucht und der Arzt plötzlich feststellt, sie haben eigentlich gerade sieben Probleme auf einmal. Und da steckt so ein gewisser alten republikanischer Imperativ drinne. Achte auf dich. Und das ist keine leoliberale irgendwas, auch wenn es so wäre, es bringt dir trotzdem was ein bisschen auf dich zu achten.
Schwarzwald Klinikzeiten sind jedenfalls vorbei.
Absolut, das ist legendär.
Was auch ganz gut ist, dass hier darauf verwiesen wird. Wir haben diese Technik, aber wir haben eigentlich nicht mehr genügend Leute, die sie bedienen können. Und was wir hier auch noch mal merken, die Komplexität des Pflegeberufs, weil das ja auch oft so dargestellt wird, ja die pflegen halt was ist, pflegen, ein bisschen waschen, ein bisschen aufdecken, zudecken und das war's. Nee, das ist sehr, sehr komplex und ist eine nicht nur anstrengend, körperlich anstrengende Arbeit, sondern natürlich auch geistig herausfordernde Arbeit, die da zu leisten ist. Plus mit all den Zwischenfällen, denen man laufend ausgesetzt ist. Und da ist natürlich erstmal deutlich zu machen, dass das auch gar nicht ersetzt werden kann durch eine Dienstpflicht. Also was ist das für ein Irrglaube? Man kann natürlich jetzt jemanden da hinsetzen, der liest vor. Oder man kann auch einfache Tätigkeiten jemanden schnell anlernen. Aber der eigentliche Pflegeberuf, weil das schwang jetzt immer so mit in der Diskussion auch, als könne man den mal schnell ersetzen. Dann nutzt man mal einen 18-jährigen, dem sagt man hier, da, pass nur auf, dass die Maschine am Laufen bleibt oder was. Also das kann ja gar nicht sein.
Wasch mal diese Frau bitte.
Ja, aber pass auf, dass keine Schläuche abgehen oder was. Also das ist eine komplexe Tätigkeit und das ist auch gar nicht so zu ersetzen. Was wollen eigentlich jetzt diese Intensivpfleger und die anderen Pfleger mit ihren Streiks?
Das sind ja eigentlich feste Betreuungsschlüsse. Bei uns sind es jetzt zum Beispiel, ich möchte nur drei Patienten betreuen, weil ich glaube, also ich weiß, drei Patienten schaffe ich. Momentan sind sieben plus x, wenn man Patienten hat, die man zu zweit betreuen muss. Und bei dreien weiß man einfach, man kann so arbeiten, wie man ausgebildet ist. Für die auch menschenwürdig mit denen einfach arbeiten, dass man nicht wegrennt, sondern dass man einfach eine Behandlung einfach mal auch beendet und zwar wirklich beendet. Und dann auch Zeit hat, für die ihre Ängste, für die ihre Nötigkeit. Die kriegen ja bei uns, wir sind ja im Krankenhaus, eine Maximalversorgung. Die kriegen bei uns ja Diagnosen, dass das Leben zu Ende ist. Oder sie rutschen in die Phase, dass sie sterben. Und das ist momentan so, wir müssen die Leute zum Teil einfach alleine sterben lassen, weil wir nicht können.
Ja, ich habe letztens erst wieder einen Erfahrungsbericht aus einer Hermetologie oder so gehört, wo die Patientin dann so meinte, ja, das war echt ein tolles Gespräch mit dem Arzt, der hat sich auch viel Zeit genommen und so. Und dann bei dem Wiederholungstermin stellt sie sich dann raus, ja, das war der einzige Termin des Tages, wo der Arzt mal nicht eine Todesnachricht schon mal vorbereiten musste oder sowas. Wo nicht schon, das Krebs ist leider so im krassen Stadium und so, einfach mal sagen konnte, mit Ihnen ist alles in Ordnung. Es macht mir auch Spaß, Ihnen das gerade mal zu sagen, wir können uns jetzt gemeinsam darüber freuen. Also solche Sachen, das kommt ja da immer noch dazu, diese psychische Belastung für alle, also sowohl für die Patienten, als auch für die Mitarbeitenden.
Auch das wieder eine herausfordernde Tätigkeit, die man nicht mal so eben gerade 18-Jährigen überlassen kann, macht man da noch so ein bisschen Sterbebegleitung oder so, das ist einfach gar nicht schaffbar. Und ja, da werden viele einsame Tode gestorben. Wie könnte man den Pflegeberuf attraktiver machen und was hätte das zur Folge?
Wie kann man denn den Beruf attraktiver machen?
Ganz, ganz viele Pflegepersonen, die unheimlich viel reduziert haben zum Beispiel. Und da gibt es auch diverse Studien drüber, wie viel wieder aufstocken würden und wieder zurückkommen würden in ihren Beruf. Plus die, die in externe Berufe gegangen sind, die auch wieder zurückkommen würden, wenn sie wüssten, okay, ich hole mir da nicht wieder einen Bannenschein vor, weil ich die ganze Zeit alleine lagern muss. Und ich hole mir kein Burnout, weil ich auch mal frei habe und mal abschalten kann. Bei uns in der Klinik wurde erst neulich eine Studie gemacht unter den Werkemitgliedern. Das wären 58 Prozent der Teilzeitkräfte, die mit besseren Arbeitsbedingungen, die wir in diesem Entlastungstarif fordern, wieder zurückkommen würden. Und für die Jugendlichen und Auszubildenden, die diesen Job machen, wäre das natürlich auch ein Ansporn.
Also Arbeitsbedingungen, wir haben jetzt bei den Gewerkschaftern gehört aus Großbritannien oder auch Amerika, da geht es sehr stark um Lohnerhöhungen. Hier geht es jetzt tatsächlich darum, der Pflegeberuf soll attraktiver sein. Und das ist jetzt nicht eine Frage der Bezahlung, sagt dann auch der Kollege.
Auch bei uns ist die Lohnsteigerung in den letzten Jahren sehr langsam erfolgt. Aber das machen wir erst beim nächsten Mal. Wir wollen jetzt erst mal wirklich nur die Entlastung, weil es geht auf vielen wirklich gar nicht ums Geld. Es gibt auch viele Bereiche, die werden auch vollkommen okay bezahlt. Nur man kann es körperlich nicht mehr. Man kann es einfach körperlich nicht mehr leisten.
Und das sagt ein junger Mann, der wahrscheinlich noch super stark ist und so. Ich meine, diese Qualität oder die Arbeitsbedingungen, man könnte auch darauf achten, dass diese Art der Arbeit auch wieder Teamarbeit ist. Das ist ja im Kindergarten auch ganz wichtig, dass man dann nicht morgens den Frühdienst alleine mit den Kindern macht, sondern immer zu zweit. So ein Vier-Augen-Prinzip bringt schon viel mehr als eins plus eins. Da stecken wirklich so ein paar Potenziale drin, aber naja. Gut, wo ist all das? Sogar kein Thema, erstaunlicherweise beim BDI. Der Industrietag, wir hören das gleich vom Russwurm, die Hütte brennt. Also die wissen gerade alle nicht mehr, wo ein, wo aus. Sie haben nicht ein Wort über die Demografie genannt. Klar, immer mal so Fachkräftemangel, aber ohne Konzept, ohne Kontext. Einfach nur so, weil es kein Modewort ist. War ganz erstaunlich, dass sie mit wie vielen krassen, konkreten Problemen sie gerade zu tun haben und deswegen das Große nicht sehen. Erinnerte mich so ein bisschen an, ja eigentlich wollten wir ja mal einen Ärztetag machen, wo die Ärzte über Klimawandel und Hitze und so weiter sprechen, aber das ging dann nicht, weil Corona und so. Dass man einfach ein Katastrophenthema hat, das ein apokalyptisches Thema so richtig verdrängt.
Naja, wir gehen den Industrietag einfach durch, wie er stattfand am zweiten Tag, als dann auch ganze Bundesregierung war im Grunde da. Rang und Namen und überhaupt. Und wir beginnen mal bei Sarah Brun, Bundesregierung, beauftragt für soziale Innovationen. Sie kommen nicht umhin, in diesen Podiumsdiskussionen das Bullshit-Bingo so richtig durchzupauken.
Also ein wichtiges Thema ist, dass wir da auch moderne Finanzierungsformen für finden. Eben zu sagen, ist es denn nur die Venture Capital 10x-Denke? Ist es nur die Profitabilitätsdenke? Schaffen wir es auch sozialen Mehrwert quantifizierbar und investierbar zu machen? Kann man diese Welten zusammenbringen, finanzieller plus sozialer Return? Ich glaube, das sind einfach Themen, die mich gerade umtreiben und uns in der Regierung umtreiben. Wie können wir Kapital bereitstellen, aber eben auch das Kapital aus dem Sektor mobilisieren, um am Ende den gesellschaftlichen Outcome zu fördern und Technologieführer zu sein, Thought-Leader zu sein, auch für das Thema gesellschaftlichen Wandel und eine zukunftsfähige Wirtschaft.
So, jetzt haben wir uns das ganz grauenhaft 45 Sekunden angehört.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, ich habe aber den Eindruck, sie ist beeinflusst durch Frank Thiel. Da geht es doch hier auch um Ten X. Also da ist sie ganz auf Linie. Toll, dass man so auch Karriere machen kann. Mit reinem Unsinn.
Es ist in diesem Falle wirklich ein bisschen blöd, denn sie ist noch super jung, aber auch super engagiert. Ihre Biografie lässt sich nachlesen auf der Seite. Sie ist im Grunde an der richtigen Stelle mit der richtigen Idee.
Was ist sie denn?
Sie ist, ja, ihre Funktion ist beauftragt für soziale Innovation und sie versucht…
Also sie hat sich irgendwo mal als Speakerin mit Bullshit-Bingo hervorgetan und dann wurde sie da hin besetzt.
Ich sag mal so, sie ist eine junge, engagierte Frau, deren Biografie, soweit sie sich auf der Ministeriumssite nachlesen lässt, schon zeigt, ja, wirtschaftlicher Erfolg stand für sie nie im Mittelpunkt. Und es ist gar nicht so verkehrt, dass jemand mit so einem Anliegen nicht in Unternehmen, aber für die Bundesregierung mit Unternehmen so arbeitet.
Ach so, ich dachte, das war jetzt so eine Start-up-Figur.
Ne, ne, ne, ne, eben nicht. Aber wir sehen sie eben hier beim Industrietag, wo sie weiß, ich muss hier scheiß Bullshit-Bingo machen. Hier ist leider ein Publikum, dem ich Thought-Leader sagen muss und Innovationen.
Also das ist eine sehr, sehr gutmütige Interpretation, aber gut bleiben wir dabei.
Es ist sehr gutmütig von mir. Ich würde sie da ungern sozusagen diffamieren, was es angeht, aber es ist halt, es zeigt gut, was das für eine Veranstaltung ist, nämlich, dass man da durch die Tür tritt und dann weiß man, jetzt ist diese Veranstaltung und alle im Kopf auf Bullshit-Obenstritt switchen einfach. Naja, aber Bullshit-Bingo haben alle so ein bisschen.
Sie müssen diese Kommunikation führen. Und ich glaube, das ist auch ein Punkt, den wir vielleicht in Deutschland so ein bisschen aussach gelassen haben. Für mich ist Innovation immer eine Führungsaufgabe. Also man kann Innovation nicht managen, man muss Innovation führen. Und wenn Innovation komplexer wird, weil es in einem komplexeren System stattfindet, dann müssen sie Menschen haben, die andere Menschen an den Tisch bekommen. Und gerade wenn sie in die sozioökologischen Themen gehen, wenn sie aus dem klassischen Industrie-Sektor rausgehen, dann ist es wichtig, dass sie über Menschen kommunizieren und nicht über Innovationsprozesse oder Regularien.
Und wir hören noch einen Bullshit-Bingo auch in der Moderation.
Supercomputing, Quantencomputing, Cybersicherheit, das ist ja im Grunde alles im Kern, vor allen Dingen Digitalisierung. Und die ist ganz wichtig und miteinander verbunden mit dem Thema, das uns jetzt beschäftigen wird, nämlich das große Wort Nachhaltigkeit. Da erleben wir ja gerade eine interessante Gleichzeitigkeit. Auf der einen Seite sind viele Unternehmen gerade gezwungen, ihre Investitionen in den Bereich zurückzustellen, weil sie mit völlig neuen steigenden Kosten rechnen müssen. Andererseits ist vielen Nachhaltigkeit, es vielen verantwortungsvolles Unternehmertum so wichtig wie noch nie. Also ein Feld mit ganz vielen Risiken, mit ganz vielen Chancen.
So, da waren alle noch beim Frühstück. Und auf der Bühne wurde so ein, komm, Nachhaltigkeitsinnovationen.
Aber es kommt doch in jedem Unternehmenspodcast, ich höre ja auch viel so Marketing, E-Commerce-Podcasts, und es kommt immer an die Nachhaltigkeit. Und das kann ein Outlet-Center sein, das sagt, ja wir waren ja schon immer nachhaltig, bis hin zum Chef von Rolls-Royce, der sagt, ja wir sind natürlich nachhaltig mit unseren Produkten. Und ich würde sagen, wenn man jetzt wirklich mal Konsumkritik üben will und auch selbst Konsumverzicht üben will, dann sollte man einfach sagen, ab sofort kaufe ich nur noch Produkte, die nicht nachhaltig sind. Und dann wird man ein großes Problem haben. Mal gucken, ob man überhaupt noch was in den Einkaufswagen legen kann.
Das Problem bei diesem BDI-Tag hier ist, die haben im Grunde jetzt anderthalb Stunden lang die Bühne bereitet für den ersten Redner Friedrich Merz. Denn Friedrich Merz kommt hier einfach mit dieser Attitüte, wie Gregor Gysi beim Linkenparteitag auftritt. Ey, Gendersternchen, habt ihr sie noch alle und so? Und konnte nämlich alles einfach mal schön vom Tisch räumen.
Wir stehen vor großen geopolitischen und strategischen Aufgaben und Herausforderungen, diese Zeit von 1990 bis 2022 war nicht das Ende der Geschichte, wie Francis Fukuyama es einmal formuliert hat, sondern es war eine kurze Zwischenphase der Geschichte und spätestens seit diesem Datum, dem 24. Februar 2022, wissen wir, dass wir jetzt in eine neue Phase der Geschichte eingetreten sind.
Man kauft es ihm auch gar nicht ab, also er versucht jetzt so ein bisschen den Großintellektuellen zu spielen, irgendwo mit Fukuyama, Habama, Sonsota, das ist das eigentliche Bullshit-Bingo.
Hier ging es erst richtig los, mit Friedrich Merz, irgendwas von er, der Fukuyama, der gesagt und so. Wir sind natürlich hier aufgeklärt, wir haben es ja alles gelesen, in der Ansicht nochmal, verweise auf den Salauer.
So in dieser Angestrengtheit merkt man gut, das ist eigentlich gar nicht sein Modus, in dem er üblicherweise denkt. So müsste ich mich anstrengen, wenn ich jetzt Fußball moderieren sollte, aber er sagt jetzt hier, ich bin ja Politiker, ich bin Staatsmann eigentlich, eigentlich bin ich schon Bundeskanzler und liebe Wirtschaftsleute, ich erzähle euch jetzt mal die Weltgeschichte. Ich mache hier Momsen und Weber und alles zusammen.
Er leidet darunter, in welcher Rolle er ist und fühlt sich aber in der eigentlich Bundeskanzlerrolle. So, naja, es ist jedenfalls eben noch von Nachhaltigkeit gesprochen hier, jetzt kommt er.
Wir stehen hier möglicherweise vor den größten Herausforderungen, die wir nach dem Zweiten Weltkrieg zu bestehen hatten, für die Industrie, aber auch für die privaten Haushalte, für das ganze Land. Meine Damen und Herren, die Energieversorgungssicherheit ist sozusagen das Rückgrat der deutschen Volkswirtschaft und deswegen möchte ich dafür plädieren, dass wir spätestens ab jetzt sämtliche Scheuklappen ablegen, keinerlei Vorbehalte mehr äußern, sondern sämtliche Ressourcen nutzen, die uns zur Verfügung stehen.
So, wird er auch noch mal irgendetwas sagen jetzt?
Ja, er sagt dann gleich noch mal Atomkraftwerke und so, aber der Modus, in dem er hier auftritt, mit dem er versucht, dort Unterstützung zu mobilisieren für sein großes biografisches Anliegen, dann noch mal Kanzler zu werden, ist ja echt so dieses, ich habe auch keine Lösung, aber glauben Sie mir, niemand nimmt ihr Problem ernster als ich. Und ich kann es so gut formulieren und mein rhetorisches Talent, oder was auch immer mir nachgesagt wird, spiele ich jetzt hier mal aus. Und das finde ich eigentlich krass, dass er glaubt und dass es vielleicht auch so ist, dass das funktioniert. Dass allein eine Problembeschreibung, ein Alarmismus hier irgend wem weiterhilft. Einfach nur so Schicksalsgemeinschaft wie in so einer Trauerarbeit.
Da sitzen ja nur Leute, die das Handelsblatt abonniert haben, die FAZ abonniert haben. Die haben ja genau das jetzt schon 50, 80, 100 Mal gehört seit dem Ukraine-Krieg. Und jetzt kommt er und wiederholt das einfach noch mal und möglicherweise sagen ja, der hat das noch mal gut auf den Punkt gebracht.
Ja und während die Leute unten Handelsblatt und FAZ lesen und er sie deswegen besonders gut abholen kann, zeigt er, was er so liest.
Ich lese jedenfalls mit großer Aufmerksamkeit und großem Interesse die Berichte des Weltklimarats und des IPCC, die in Deutschland ja gern, aber meistens unvollständig zitiert werden. Gern insoweit, als dass sie unsere Ziele unterstreichen, CO2-Neutralität durch den Rückbau fossiler Energieträger und durch den Ausbau regenerativer Energien zu erreichen. Weniger Aufmerksamkeit in der deutschen Öffentlichkeit finden die Hinweise auf die Kernenergie?
Die Kernenergie, ja, wir Deutsche haben noch drei Atomkraftwerke und die bringen auch irgendwie 5 Gigawatt oder so geschenkt. Neue zu bauen, werden dann auch 2056 oder so fertig. Das ist so sachlich, also sachlich ist das so jenseits von allem, hier die Kernenergie noch mal in die Scheuklappen reinzuholen. Das ist einfach total blöde, das wissen eigentlich auch alle. Trotzdem wird hier noch mal dieses Theater von ihm aufgemacht. Und er liest die IPCC-Berichte vollständig, anders als alle anderen.
Er geht in die Fußnoten rein.
Er liest alle Anmerkungen und Ergänzungen, die auch nicht dann von allen mitgetragen wurden. Das ist einfach ein ganz toller. Und auf dem großen Spielfeld der Handlungsmöglichkeiten sucht er sich jetzt noch mal genau die kleine Ecke, wo er ein paar Purietten dreht und du sagst, ah, da überzeugt er mich besonders.
So, und dann will ich einen Gedanken zum Schluss sagen. Wenn wir den Mindset hinbekommen, dass wir als CO2-Neutralität, Umweltschutz, Klimaschutz, diese Themen nicht als eine Belastung empfinden und als eine Aufgabe des regulierenden Gesetzgebers, sondern dass wir sie als eine Chance empfinden, damit Geld zu verdienen. Ganz profan, wenn wir sie als eine Chance verstehen, damit mit innovativen Unternehmen nicht nur in Deutschland und Europa, sondern auf der Welt Geld zu verdienen, dann haben wir, glaube ich, den richtigen Spurwechsel in diesen Fragen so gemacht, dass wir das auch wirklich schaffen können.
Ja, Mindset hat mich dann sofort angesprochen. Und was hier nochmal deutlich wird, er will wieder den schwachen Start haben. Und da muss ich ja sagen, was redet er da? Selbst wenn man das so annimmt, wie er das möchte mit dem schwachen Start, dann braucht man ja gar nicht ihn da sitzen haben. Weil dann könnte man ja einfach sagen, ihr seid doch innovativ, ist doch egal. Also was brauchen die dann überhaupt den Politiker da?
Seine Aufgabe ist ja als Antipolitiker, den Staat noch aus dem Weg zu räumen. Die letzte Anzammlung des Staatsmanns, den Staat aus dem Weg zu räumen. Was ich so interessant finde, ist, wie er hier dieses Argument verkauft, wir müssen das als Wachstumsstrategie denken, die ökologische Wende. Das ist eins zu eins der Tenor von Ursula von der Leyen Januar 2020 gewesen. Er hätte einfach nur sagen müssen, richtig Ursula, wir sind Parteien in Familie, du bist eine von uns, du machst es, das ist die Idee. Aber nein, so und jetzt zweieinhalb Jahre später, so das sollten wir mal machen. Profitgedanken rein, so was. Ich frag mich dann auch, was denken die da jetzt in der EU-Kommission? Nur noch Spiel, nur noch Simulation und Spiel hier, jenseits von jeder Realität. Na ja, Lutz Dietrichs von der BNP Bank, CEO natürlich, zeigt ja nochmal, es geht um ganz schön viel Geld.
Wir müssen uns nochmal vor Augen führen, was wir in den nächsten Jahren vor uns haben. Wir reden immer an Investitionsprogrammen, seriöse Schätzungen gehen von 6 Trillionen Euro, also 6.000 Milliarden bis 2045 und da ist vollkommen klar, dass das nicht einer alleine stemmen kann.
Ja, einer alleine soll das auch nicht stemmen. Aber die Aussage ist, also der...
Brauchen wir das private Geld?
Er ist ja Banker und da muss man natürlich sehen, dass man weiter im Kreditgeschäft bleibt und das funktioniert natürlich nur, wenn die Privatbanken weiterhin das Geld schöpfen für diese große Innovation.
Wenn der Staat das macht, sind die alle raus.
Und da kann man auch mal ein bisschen Spack im Sacko dastehen.
Also die Gefahr für diese auch, wenn der Staat das organisiert, sucht der nur Handwerker, die tatsächlich die Solarplatten aufbauen und die Solarplatten herstellen und niemanden sonst. Das wäre natürlich blöd für alle beteiligt.
Man sollte jetzt zurecht mal auf den Staat wieder verweisen mit Bayern. Du hast das Beispiel heute schon gebracht. Die organisieren am Flughafen in München die Sicherheit, die ist gewährleistet durch die staatliche GmbH, vollkommen in deren Besitz. Und da läuft es. Da heben die Flieger pünktlich ab. Und da könnte man ja auch sagen, dann wollen wir mal gucken, wo sind dann am schnellsten die Solarzellen auf dem Dach?
Bayern will sich ja als Solardachland sowieso beweisen, damit sie die Windräder, das ist ja für die auch ein innerer Antrieb, sozusagen ganz schnell Solarplatten bauen, damit in drei, vier Jahren Söder dann sagen kann, wir brauchen keine Windräder. Wir haben so viel Solarkraft mehr als ganz Deutschland. Da bereitet er sich ja drauf vor.
Ich bin gespannt, ob die dann auch da eine weiße Weste haben wollen, weil wir jetzt von Menschenrechtsverletzungen erfahren haben, bei der Herstellung von Solarpanels. Die werden jede zweite, glaube ich, sogar in China hergestellt. Und vieles kommt aus den Regionen, wo die Uiguren eingesperrt sind. Und mal sehen, also wenn man das dann auch noch abwickeln will, dann wird es langsam schwierig.
Genau, das ist nämlich die nächste Dimension, das Soziale, nicht nur das für die Umwelt.
Selbstverständlich können fairer Handel und Investitionen Positives in anderen Ländern und Gesellschaften bewirken. Und dafür haben wir wirklich gute Beispiele. Aber dass sich dadurch politische und gesellschaftliche Ordnungen ändern, das ist eben kein Automatismus. In autokratischen Regimen geschieht genau so viel Wandel, wie die Autokraten zulassen. Und die lassen sich oft nicht von Handel beeinflussen.
Das finde ich, wir haben ja von der Bundesregierung selbst, wir haben es ja selbst im Podcast gehört, für uns arbeiten auf der Welt 50 Sklaven. So, wenn wir jetzt unser Wirtschaftsmodell exportieren, was exportieren wir dann eigentlich? Naja, dass auch die Chinesen ein Recht haben auf 50 Sklaven. So, was haben wir also im Wandel durch Handel im Angebot? Gar nichts, keinen moralischen Vorrang oder sowas.
Genau.
Ja, und dann wundert er sich, die nehmen das gar nicht so dankbar auf irgendwie, dass wir die ganze Welt versklagen.
Das eine hängt ja auch mit dem anderen überhaupt nicht zusammen. Also das heißt ja nicht nur, weil ich irgendwo hin was verkaufe, dass die sagen, ja wir sind jetzt auch für liberale LGBT-Rechte. Das kann ja nicht zusammenhängen, sondern man könnte es ja höchstens an etwas knüpfen. Und was er hier macht, ist eigentlich ganz geschickt. Er weiß natürlich, dass dieses Wandel durch Handel nicht funktioniert hat. Das zeigt sich in China und Russland. Er verquickt das aber jetzt mit den Lieferketten und sagt, ja also das ist ja alles gut, wenn wir da die Welt verbessern. Aber da wird sich eigentlich nichts verbessern. Und da würde ich sagen, doch, wenn man diese hohen Standards einsetzt und sagt, man bindet die Wirtschaft daran zurück, dass gewisse Menschenrechte eingehalten werden oder dass grundsätzlich die Menschenrechte eingehalten werden, dann verändert sich in dem Land einfach etwas, wenn es etwas verdienen will. Und da hat man eine direkte Einwirkung. Man kann nicht sagen, wir sagen, bitte wählt Putin ab oder so. Das kann man nicht sagen. Aber man kann sagen, wir werden ab sofort nur noch mit Ländern kooperieren, wo zum Beispiel Homosexualität nicht mit der Todesstrafe geahnt wird.
Ja, auch das lieber unbekannt. Also hier zuhören, der Autor kommt bitte ins Merkel Buch. Wir haben ja über das Lieferketten-Sorgfalz-Gesetz gesprochen. Das ist das eigentliche Hebel für Wandel durch Handel, wie du es beschrieben hast.
Und da hat nämlich Großbrum immer alles getan, damit das zusammen mit Peter Altmaier nicht passiert.
Genau, also wenn einer das Argument auf der Bühne so nicht machen darf, dann er. Und das ist einfach gut. Jetzt verkoppeln wir mal zwei Clips, zum einen diesen hier.
Drittens ist klassischer Wettbewerb unsere Formel für den Erfolg in der Welt. Innovationsvorsprung, Technologieführerschaft und Wettbewerbsstärke. Damit müssen die demokratisch verfassten Industrieländer rund um den Globus den Systemwettbewerb ein attraktives Angebot entgegenstellen. Das war unsere Schlussfolgerung aus dem Treffen der B7 gestern. Aber Achtung, dabei ist der Schiedsrichter immer der Kunde. Der entscheidet, welches Angebot attraktiv und wettbewerbsfähig ist. Egal, ob er Konsument ist oder der Abnehmer von Investitionsgütern oder die Regierung eines Landes, wenn es um Infrastrukturleistungen geht.
So, der Schiedsrichter. Aber Achtung, der Schiedsrichter ist der Kunde.
Und ich finde, Olaf Scholz, der da eingeblendet wird, schmunzelt ein bisschen. Herzverstanden.
Also die Idee der Deutschland AG war immer Angebotsorientierung. Das sagt der März bis heute. So, es geht darum, Unternehmen zu fördern, damit die ein tolles Angebot machen. Und der Kunde muss dann eben was halt rauskommt. Und wenn das Verbrennungsmotor sind oder Dächer, die aufgrund ihrer Bauart eigentlich viel zu teuer sind und gar nicht gebraucht werden um eine Familie und ein eigenes Wohnen, das ist halt auf dem Markt und das wird dann bitte gekauft.
Das ist ein großer Irrtum über den Kapitalismus. Der Kapitalismus befriedigt Bedürfnisse, aber das ist nicht seine primäre Aufgabe. Es ist die sekundäre Aufgabe und die braucht es auch, damit wir was konsumieren. Man kauft nicht was, was man wirklich gar nicht verwenden kann. Also ein Computer, der nicht läuft, den würde man nicht kaufen. Aber alles andere, was du jetzt gerade ansprichst, dass man ein teures Dach bauen muss, weil es keine Alternative gibt und man könnte jetzt viele Beispiele dieser Art nennen, das ist der Kern des Kapitalismus, der primär ein Profit erwirtschaften will für die Leute, die Russwurm da vertritt. Und das ist genau das, was mit angebotsorientiert gemeint ist. Wir schaffen ein Angebot, von dem wir am besten profitieren. Das können wir über Kartelle herstellen. Das können wir auch über andere Vereinbarungen herstellen.
Also vor allem Verdrängung von Konkurrenzprodukten.
Verdrängung von günstigen und sinnvollen möglicherweise Konkurrenzprodukten. Und da er jetzt hier diesen Wettbewerb noch mal so ganz stark macht, wir hatten ja vor einem Jahr schon mal den BDI-Tag, da hatte ich Clips mitgebracht und da hat er ja wirklich so eine flammende Rede gehalten. Glauben wir denn überhaupt noch an die soziale Marktwirtschaft? Ist für uns Wettbewerb noch wichtig? Also da hatte er schon das Gespenst des Sozialismus ausgemalt mit Blick auf, was ist, wenn die Grünen an der Macht sind? Und jetzt hatte er natürlich Robert Habeck da und hat aber auch jetzt festgestellt, gut, Sozialismus ist doch noch nicht ganz eingeführt.
Ja, also das sind Ideologie-Schleuder-Veranstaltungen, ohne Ende, verlogen, ohne Ende. Und jetzt hat er gesagt, der Kunde ist der Schiedsrichter. Wir wissen, der Kunde ist ja nicht der Schiedsrichter, sondern der ist einfach den Marken, den Angeboten ausgeliefert, wie es halt so ist. Ansonsten könnte man ja echt sagen, wieso fressen sich die Leute so ungesund? Warum gibt es kein 1, 5 Liter Auto, mit dem man durch die Stadt fährt, weil man nie auf einer Autobahn will damit oder so. Wo ist dieses alles, das tolle Zeug? Naja, und dann, und er hat ja nicht nur der Kunde als Käufer, sondern auch den Wähler, den Nutzer von Infrastruktur und so weiter genannt, also die ganzen Publikumsrollen, würde man sagen, die er jetzt hier gleich wieder komplett aus dem Spiel nimmt.
Der künstlerische Klimaschutz basiert auf einem technologieoffenen Innovationsumfeld. Die jüngsten Positionierungen des Europäischen Parlaments halten wir geradeaus für falsch und kontraproduktiv. Und Herr Bundeskanzler, entsprechend groß sind unsere Erwartungen an die Bundesregierung und an das Treffen des Europäischen Rates in der nächsten Woche.
2035 ist der Schluss mit Verbrennungsmotoren. Hat ja eigentlich der Schiedsrichter Kunde entschieden. Und dann kommt er und lobbyiert auf offener Bühne für alle einsehbar und sagt, das akzeptieren wir nicht. Wir nehmen heute noch auf dich Einfluss, lieber Bundeskanzler, damit du im Europäischen Rat oder im Ministerrat, also entweder macht es die Umweltministerin, oder du dann selbst als Staats- und Regierungschef der EU-Gremien diesen Europaparlamentsbeschluss bitte nicht wirksam werden lässt. So, das ist natürlich... Also ich fand's ein bisschen crazy, das überhaupt so auf der Bühne zu machen.
Man unterminiert den demokratischen Willen und macht das... droht das nochmal offiziell an, also dass das intern läuft, ahnen wir natürlich.
Also dieser Lobbyismus läuft ja eigentlich so, dass der Europäische Rat, wenn er sich trifft, man weiß gar nicht genau wann, man weiß nicht wer, wer macht da die Arbeitsgremien vorarbeiten und so weiter. Es gibt keine Pressekonferenzen danach. Alles ist total kleines Team. Niemand weiß über irgendwas Bescheid. Und da setzen die sich dann immer durch. Aber das hier so auf offener Bühne zu sagen, dass man eine demokratisch gefasste Entscheidung des Europaparlament einfach für falsch hält und deswegen den Lobbyarm, den man hat, der dann in die anderen Gremien da reinwirkt, nutzen möchte, um das zu torpedieren, finde ich einfach, das ist... Also hier zeigt sich, das ist...
Das ist sehr schamlos.
Das ist antidemokratisch und einfach bescheuert. Naja, er kommt jedenfalls noch mal auf seinen Schiedsrichter dann zu sprechen.
Und noch mal, der Schiedsrichter dafür ist der Kunde. Was es nicht braucht, was es überhaupt nicht braucht, ist mehr Bürokratie.
Ja, natürlich, Bürokratieabbau. Nur wenn man selbst von der Bürokratie profitiert, das tun ja ganz viele Industrien. Man hat nämlich dann bürokratische Monstren geschaffen, die es den disruptiven Start-ups dann sehr schwer machen, da reinzukommen. Die machen nämlich einfach Marktschließungen durch. Bürokratie, die haben dann ihre teuren Firmenanwälte, die können sich die kleinen Unternehmer nicht leisten. Und dann ist die Bürokratie natürlich dein Freund.
So, dann steht Olaf Scholz auf der Bühne. Wir hören uns nur diesen einen Clip an. Die konzertierte Aktion erinnert uns an deinen Themenblock gerade.
Wichtig ist, dass die externen Shocks zu keiner dauerhaften Inflationsspirale führen. Genau daran muss uns jetzt gelegen sein, und zwar allen Verantwortlichen gemeinsam. Deshalb habe ich Gewerkschaften, Wirtschaft und Politik zur konzertierten Aktion ins Bundeskanzleramt eingeladen.
Das ist im Grunde der heiße Stuhl für die Gewerkschaften.
Genau, nur der heiße Stuhl für die Gewerkschaften. Das musst du noch mal ganz deutlich sagen.
Denn die Preise auf Erzeugerseite sind ja schon hoch. Jetzt geht es darum, die anderen Preise in der Arbeitsbearbeitung zu machen.
Man hätte ja ein Mittel. Man könnte ja sagen, die verminderte Mehrwertsteuer, die auf die wichtigen Dinge, die wir brauchen, es ja gibt, die könnte man ganz tilgen, würde die bei Null belassen und dann würde man damit die Preise tatsächlich senken.
Ja, da gibt es auch ganz viele Wege. Da würde ich sogar sagen, jetzt soll man einfach alles in so eine quasi Steuererklärung reinschreiben. Man zeigt so ein Beispiel Kassenzettel, der angelaufen ist, steht ja alles drauf, was man gekauft hat, und dann lässt man sich eine Mehrwertsteuer zurückerstatten, so wie man sich auch eine Cum-Ex-Steuer zurückerstatten lässt. Warum nicht? Also da gibt es ja viele Ideen.
Das ging sehr einfach.
Um auch zu vermeiden, dass der Supermarkt einfach den Gewinn mitnimmt, wenn dann plötzlich Preisanpassungen dann doch nicht da sind.
Findet am 4. Konzertierte Aktion, der Begriff steht für die Einsicht, dass sich schwierige Probleme im Miteinander besser lösen lassen als im Gegeneinander. Das ist ein gutes Markenzeichen unseres Landes. Als gesellschaftlichen Tisch der Vernunft, bezeichnete Karl Schiller die erste konzertierte Aktion. Und an genau diesen gesellschaftlichen Tisch der Vernunft werden wir uns deshalb jetzt auch wieder setzen.
Bei Mark Schieritz haben wir ja gelesen, dass er mal Marxist war. Und dann muss doch wenigstens so viel geblieben sein, dass man weiß, da gibt es kein Miteinander, sondern es gibt widerstreitende Interessen.
Also ein Tisch der Vernunft ist einfach Karneval. Das so zu nennen, das ist einfach völlig abseitig. Aber gut.
Ich finde, wir brauchen nur noch einen Bürgerrat dafür.
Richtig, einen Bürgerrat, der noch so flankierend gute Tipps gibt, woran man gerade leidet, wenn die Butter zu teuer ist. Scholz, ansonsten nur floskeln.
Wir bewegen uns im unkartiertem Gelände. Aber wir haben einen klaren Kompass. Vor allem aber, wir sind nicht allein unterwegs. International stehen wir enger denn je zusammen mit unseren Partnern und Freunden in der EU, in der NATO und den G7. National ziehen wir an einem Strang, Staat, Wirtschaft und Gesellschaft.
Nun, ich glaube nicht, dass Amerika sich sehr dafür schert, wenn wir hier eine Rezession produzieren, dann sagen die, ja gut, macht ihr mal da. Wir haben ja unsere Energie und exportieren die euch und mal gucken, welchen Preis ihr bereit seid, dafür zu zahlen. Aber wichtig ist, dass ihr jetzt nichts mehr aus Russland importiert. Das ist überhaupt da auf dieser wirtschaftlichen Ebene natürlich keine Partnerschaft. Die NATO ist ein Zweckbündnis. Ein Zweckbündnis, das sich auch bewährt hat. Aber es ist keineswegs so, dass die Bündnisländer in irgendeiner Weise wirtschaftlich, freundschaftlich zusammenarbeiten, sondern es sind Konkurrenten untereinander. Es sind wie konkurrierende Unternehmen.
Derzeit muss man echt aufpassen, dass nicht zwischen Griechenland und der Türkei ein Krieg ausbricht wegen irgendwelchen Vormachtstellungen auf den Inseln im Mittelmeer und so.
Ja, das wird ja auch ganz ausgeblendet, ich finde, dass ja auch jetzt mit den Beitritt von Schweden, wenn man da wieder sieht, was Schweden für Zugeständnisse der Türkei machen muss. Ich meine, die Kurden werden ja wieder übergangen. Also die sind wieder die Gearschten eigentlich.
Es ist einfach alles absurd. Und solche Tage, man könnte sich natürlich eine wissenschaftliche Expertise, die nun wirklich mal im Code der Wahrheit, also aus der Wissenschaft kommt, aber nein, bei der Frage Rezension, ja oder nein, fragt man den deutschen Bankchef. So, also das ist einfach, das ist wie so eine Hollywood-Spielfilm-Produktion, die man hier einfach nur, hauptsache supergeile Typen auf der Bühne.
Herr Seebing, wir freuen uns sehr, dass Sie da sind, weil im Moment schwirren eine Menge...
Wir freuen uns sehr, dass Sie da sind mit Ihrer Expertise als Chef der Deutschen Bank, weil niemand sonst könnte uns jetzt diese Frage beantworten.
Was erwarten Sie als Perspektive?
Zumindest so, dass wir in den nächsten zwölf oder 18 Monaten eine Wahrscheinlichkeit einer Rezession haben, die deutlich höher ist, als wir es uns vor dem Krieg ausgemalt haben. Das ist nicht unbedingt die Folge des Krieges, sondern insbesondere die Folge der Bekämpfung dieser Inflation.
Toll, das sind Analysen, das müsste man gleich nochmal in den Wirtschaftspodcast einladen.
Da sitzt man da acht Stunden und hört sich diesen Blödsinn an. Kleines Intermezzo, man hat festgestellt, es ist ja auch noch Krieg, jetzt haben wir schon über Nachhaltigkeit gesprochen, jetzt müssen wir noch kurz über den Krieg sprechen. Man macht das natürlich im Duktus einer Industrietagung. Uns ist jetzt völlig egal, wer da spricht usw. Wir hören uns das einfach nur kurz an.
Und hier ist Russland im Vormarsch. Russland kann bis zu 50-60.000 Granaten pro Tag verschießen. Die Ukraine hat nur ungefähr 5-6.000 Granaten. Und eben deshalb diese Bitten von Präsident Zelensky, dass wir doch Haubitzen, Raketenwerfer und andere Artilleriegeschütze so schnell wie möglich in die Ukraine schicken.
So, jetzt sind alle auch darüber informiert. Gehen wir noch was zu verkaufen? Wollen wir jetzt auch 50.000 liefern? Dann fragt man den Reihmetallchef irgendwie, keine Ahnung, er sagt ja und dann entscheidet das Plenum, wird gemacht. Auftritt Christian Lindner.
In der Tat, wir leben in Zeiten, in denen sich viel verändert, in denen wir Zeugen einer echten Disruption geworden sind durch den schrecklichen Angriff Russlands auf die Ukraine. Das verändert viel. Vor allen Dingen weckt es uns auch aus einer falschen Normalität, in der wir es uns lange bequem gemacht haben. Wir haben nach dem Fall des Eisernen Vorhangs gut gelebt von der Friedensdividende.
Ich kann das langsam nicht mehr hören. Ich finde es auch eine Frechheit und diese Idee von, wir haben uns bisher auf eine Friedensdividende ausgeruht. Das ist aber eine falsche Normalität gewesen. Für einen FDP-Liberalen gilt der Mensch, das ist das Menschenwolf. Aber das würde ich doch ungern als die tragende Ideologie weder in meinem Leben noch in anderer akzeptieren. Dass alle nur noch mit Misstrauen und Missgunsten sich immer auf den Krieg einstellen. Vorsicht, du lebst im Frieden. Das könnte eine falsche Normalität sein.
Wir hatten ja hier die Stimmen zum Krieg, wenn dann im Stern Mickey Bison sagt, jetzt ist mal wieder Zeit, ernst zu sein und nicht mehr Spaßkultur und alles. Das geht ja genau in diese FDP Richtung. Und ich frage mich auch immer, bei wem ist eigentlich diese Friedensdividende, wenn es sie dann geben sollte, angekommen? Bei den Löhnen ist das nicht so gut zu erkennen jedenfalls.
Die Produktivität ist ja um 40 Prozent gestiegen in den letzten 30 Jahren und die Löhne um 8 Prozent. Da kann man sich durchaus fragen, wo ist denn eigentlich diese kleine Lücke da hängen geblieben?
Kann man die jetzt vielleicht nachträglich mal einfordern, dass jetzt alle anderen sagen, ich hätte noch, bevor all gut ist jetzt bald zu Ende, aber jetzt hätte ich noch gern diese Friedensdividende.
Es gibt nichts mehr einzufordern, es tut sich eine Steilwand vor uns auf.
Im letzten Jahr habe ich 4 Milliarden Euro Kapitaldienst im Haushaltsabschluss gehabt. Im nächsten Jahr muss ich mit 30 Milliarden Euro kalkulieren. Nicht nur wegen der aktuell gestiegenen Zinsen, sondern weil meine Vorgänger auch inflationsgesicherte Staatsanleihen begeben haben. Da haben wir früher Geld mit verdient, jetzt zahlen wir Milliarden dafür. Auch Disarjo und Arjo-Effekte fallen weg, will sie nicht mit Details behelligen, aber 30 Milliarden Euro Kapitaldienst im nächsten Jahr. Das ist eine Steilwand, die sich vor uns auftut.
Nun hat er gerade noch mal das wirklich zugegeben. Wir hätten da auch noch richtig Geld verdienen können. Jetzt nicht. Und er rechnet jetzt aber im Modus der schwäbischen Hausfrau. Ich hab jetzt noch mal in den Spotmoney geguckt, so viel ist noch da.
Adjaditisimo, aber will ich auch nicht mit Details behelligen. Nicht, dass jetzt irgendwer auf die Idee kommt, dass manche hinterfragen, wie es jetzt auf der Bühne gesagt wird. Übergewinne. Die Übergewinnensdiskussion haben wir ja gerade bei Ölkonzernen, bei denen Christian Lindner schon sagt, wir haben ja gar keine Ölkonzerne in Deutschland, da sind ja nur Filialen und so weiter und so fort. Und er bringt ja noch mal so ein zweites Argument, wo ich mir irgendwie denke, und das soll jetzt für Ölkonzerne auch gelten?
Und diese Übergewinne, diese guten Renditen, sind ja ein Anreiz dafür, genau an den Punkten zu investieren. Also dürfen wir das nicht zerstören. Mehr noch, wer am Stammtisch entscheidet, was ein Übergewinn ist, der gibt das deutsche Steuerrecht der Willkürpreis und dazu darf es nicht kommen.
Wenn wir den Ölkonzernen ihre Übergewinne nicht zugestehen, dann machen die keine Innovation mehr. Und da frage ich, selbst wenn, wohin ist die Innovationen getrieben?
Die machen natürlich eine Innovation, um ihre Profite zu verbessern.
Das ist die Innovation. Der Übergewinn ist eigentlich die Innovation.
Das ist eigentlich ja.
Also es geht hier wirklich drunter und drüber.
Es ist eben nicht alles gleichzeitig zu jeder Zeit möglich oder in anderen Worten geländegängig gesagt. Wir müssen nach fast einem Jahrzehnt der expansiven Finanzpolitik wieder eines lernen.
So und jetzt kommt der große Satz. Wir müssen jetzt alle nicht nur lernen, sondern umlernen. Wir sind also alle Maurice Höfken verseucht und so weiter. Christian Lindner sagt uns jetzt die Wahrheit.
Erst muss der Wohlstand von Ihnen erwirtschaftet werden, bevor ihn danach die Politik verteilen kann. Wenn wir das beherzigen, bekommen wir auch die Haushalte unter Kontrolle.
Ja, und es ist genau andersherum. Der Staat gibt das Geld, nimmt Steuern, damit die Währung akzeptiert wird. Und der Staat schafft Vermögen, indem er z.B. Unternehmen beauftragt, zu sagen, mach doch mal da einen Schwimmbad hin.
Es ist einfach grotesk. Ich finde, man kann auf der Bühne mal einen Fehler machen, eine Ungenauigkeit. Aber die Realität um 180 Grad zu verkehren und dann diesen Satz, den man daraus bildet, noch mit so einer Ankündigung zu versehen, um ihn dann auszusprechen, finde ich, das geht einfach nicht. Das ist so eine Veranstaltung da nicht würdig.
Und das muss eigentlich skandalisiert werden. Und das muss wirklich in einer Weise skandalisiert werden, wo wir jetzt immer so von Fake News reden, von wissenschaftlichen Kriterien. Dass man sagt, nee, das ist nicht so. Das ist genauso, wie wenn jemand sagt, nein, die Ehe für alle, die sorgt für schwule Kinder oder so was. Dann muss man sagen, nein, das ist einfach Unsinn, was du da erzählst. Und genauso muss man auch hier sagen, nee, das ist Fake News. Genauso wie Leute sagen, die Impfung wirkt nicht, würde man auch sofort sich dagegen stellen und sagen, ist Unsinn. Genauso muss man hier auch sagen, nee, so funktioniert das System aber gar nicht.
Wo du das so sagst, ich suche auch Beispiele, aber mir fällt nichts Groteskes ein. Aber es wäre so, du nimmst so eine Wanderungseinladung an, legst dich dann unten an den Berg und beschwerst dich darüber, dass du nicht automatisch hochrollst. Wie soll da hochgehen? Ich dachte, wir rollen jetzt hier hoch einfach. Wie wollen sie denn hochrollen? Ich lege mich hierhin und rolle hoch. Sie müssen hier hoch wandern. Ich will aber nicht, auf der Ebene inhaltlich ist es irgendwie, sich das so anzuhören von dem Lindner.
Nun, lass uns aber noch mal einen Punkt besprechen. Jetzt wissen wir ja, dass das eigentlich wirtschaftlich sinnvoll wäre für die Volkswirtschaft, wenn man anders agieren würde als Lindner. Lindner agiert aber auch wirtschaftlich sinnvoll für eine gewisse Klientel. Also es ist ja keineswegs so, dass man, wenn man jetzt das mal beherzigt, was Larry Fink mal formuliert hat in einem seiner Briefe, dass damit wirklich, dass das der einzige Weg ist, um Geld zu verdienen. Also die Idee von Larry Fink ist ja zu sagen, oder auch von Bill Gates, wir müssen jetzt sehen, dass wir eine grüne Transformation hinbekommen. Wir müssen CO2-neutral werden, denn wir wollen ja auch in der Zukunft Profite machen. Und das können wir ja nicht, wenn die Erde kaputt ist. Dann haben wir ja alles vernichtet. Und das kann man ja dann auch sehen bei so Überflutungen wie an der Ahr. Plötzlich sind da hunderte, tausende Häuser futsch und dann ist Vermögen vernichtet worden. Auf der ganz globalen Ebene stimmt das und ich glaube, dass es auch für BlackRock stimmt, weil BlackRock überall investiert ist. Und dadurch ist das für die natürlich in irgendeiner Weise entscheidend, auch wenn ich jetzt Larry Fink da nicht zu hoch hängen will, als der Oskar-Liots-Figur, aber so Karatzehen.
Genau, überall mit acht Prozent ungefähr drin. Hauptsache, der Markt funktioniert. Mit welchen Teilnehmern ist denen am Ende egal, weil sie einfach bei allen Teilnehmern drin sind.
So, und jetzt will ich mal einen Transfer machen. Man kann ja sagen, es hat richtig schlimme wirtschaftliche Konsequenzen, auch dass wir so viele Schulmassaker haben in den USA mit diesem liberalen Waffenrecht. Das produziert so unendlich viel Leid. Das ist auch sehr teuer, was dann da an Folgekosten entsteht, psychologische Betreuung und all das. Und dann könnte man auch hier das Argument machen, eigentlich so ein Larry-Fink-Argument, schon aus wirtschaftlicher Logik heraus sollte man es nicht tun. So, und jetzt kommt aber mein Gegenargument. Und das hörte ich in dem Podcast Once and Tues mit einem Tues, den ich sehr empfehlen kann. Da ging es auch um diese wirtschaftliche Komponente. Und naja, es gibt aber einen ganz, ganz großen Wirtschaftszweig, der extrem daran verdient, dass alles so bleibt, wie es ist, und dass die Waffengesetze so liberal sind. Das ist nämlich der Sektor, der die Schule sicherer macht. Und da werden Milliarden ausgegeben. Die Schulen, muss man sich vorstellen, sind heruntergewirtschaftet ohne Ende. Und Millionen werden aber drauf geworfen, damit man eine sichere Schule hat, damit man Türen hat, die nur in eine Richtung zu öffnen sind und, und, und. Diese ganzen Dinge. Man kann sich vorstellen, bis man so eine Schule wirklich sicher hat, in Anführungszeichen. Und da ist so eine große Industrie entstanden, dass man also mit der Katastrophe unkaupig gut Geld verdienen kann. Und jetzt denke ich hier an unsere Hitze. Wochen oder Monate werden es ja fast. An all diese Dinge denke ich an die Klimaanlagenindustrie, an all das. Da gibt es auch ganz große Zweige, die mit so einem, ich möchte mal sagen, Katastrophenkapitalismus wahnsinnig gut Geld verdienen können. Und für die macht Lindner da Politik.
Also, dass das Gemeinwohl eine ideelle Vorstellung ist, aber das particuläre Interesse sich durchsetzen muss beim Interessensausgleich. Lindner ist so ein Typ, der die particularen Interessen intensiv verdreht. Und zwar die einen besonders intensiv und die anderen eben gar nicht. Das sind dann die, die hinten runterfallen. Auf ganz dramatische Weise sehen wir das ja in Amerika, wo Joe Manchin aus West Virginia, nur um einfach die Kohleindustrie in seinem kleinen Bundesstaat nicht zu gefährden, das ganze Innovationsprojekt von Joe Biden in Höhe von 6 Trillionen Dollar einfach nicht mit der notwendigen 51-50 Mehrheit durch den Senat kommen lässt, sondern es einfach scheitert. Selten stand ein particulares Interesse so sehr einem Gemeinwohl Ansinnen gegenüber und so ist das auch bei Lindner. Das ist einfach ein Verräter, das ist ein Antipolitiker, der einfach Interessenpolitik vertritt und da für andere wirklich dann vor der Klinge springen lässt. Und am nächsten Clip wird es besonders deutlich, wir hatten schon sein Eingeständnis, ja wir haben das mit der Schuldenpolitik, im Grunde haben wir die Chancen verpasst. Wir hätten hier und so ordentlich absahnen können als Staat und gleichzeitig über öffentliche Gelder, ja dann hätten nicht die privaten Investoren die Renditen eingefahren und so weiter und so fort. Und jetzt hören wir hier Lindner, wie er über die deutsche Autoindustrie und die Subventionen spricht und welches Eingeständnis da drin steckt.
Verehrte Anwesende, meine Damen und Herren, die Automobilindustrie ist eine unserer Schlüsselindustrie in Deutschland. Ich bin überzeugt davon, Deutschland wird der Leitmarkt sein für die Elektromobilität. Ich bin auch überzeugt im Übrigen von den Fahrzeugen, die in Deutschland produziert werden, die exzellent sind und die eigentlich gar keine Kaufprämie mehr brauchen. Die steuerliche Förderung als Dienstwagen reicht eigentlich absolut aus. Da muss noch eine Subvention gezahlt werden. Im Übrigen sind die Autos gegenwärtig ja so beliebt. Wir haben so viele Knappheiten, dass sie gar nicht lieferbar sind.
Wir müssten eigentlich gar keine Subventionen zahlen, aber irgendwie haben wir da noch so viele drin. Diese ganzen 60 Milliarden, die da ausgerechnet worden sind, muss nicht weg, aber nötig ist auch nicht. Sie sind toll genug. Das ist so eine Art von Lob, wo man sich echt denkt, auf offener Bühne.
Naja, und so gleich erleben wir, wie die chinesischen Autohersteller jetzt doch offenbar sehr an Fahrt aufnehmen. Die waren zum Beispiel jetzt auch in München bei SIXT bei diesem Unternehmen zu Gast und haben da mal diese Modelle vorgestellt an E-Mobilität, was es da so gibt. Und plötzlich merkt man ja auch, wenn es so Flotten gibt und E-Mobilität gibt und all diese Dinge, dann gibt es ja nicht mehr diese Markenbindung, wie bei dem Privatmann, der sich jetzt das eine Auto kaufen kann, ich will aber einen BMW in der Garage haben. Und dann kann sich plötzlich so ein größeres Unternehmen vielleicht, das Autos vermietet, vorstellen, mit NIO zusammenzuarbeiten. Und dann sieht das plötzlich für die deutschen Autos nicht mehr so schön aus.
Ja, da müsste man ja eigentlich mal politisch ein bisschen was regeln, sodass die Innovationsfreude und der Drang zum Elektroauto und so weiter, alle Ideen, neue Ideen mal sich durchsetzen können.
Also steht Christian Lindner auf der Bühne und sagt, wenn es aber irgendwann ein Verbot der Neuzulassung des Verbrennungsmotors gibt, dann wird er auch nicht weiterentwickelt werden, zumindest nicht in Europa und Deutschland. Und deshalb halte ich diese Entscheidung, den Verbrennungsmotor zu verbieten, de facto für falsch. Und ich habe deshalb, daraus folgt etwas, ich habe deshalb entschieden, dass ich in der Bundesregierung, dass wir in der Bundesregierung dieser europäischen Rechtsetzung nicht zustimmen werden in dieser Woche. Deutschland wird also nicht den flotten Grenzwerten mit dem de facto Verbrennungsverbot zustimmen können, weil wir uns eines erhalten müssen, die Offenheit für technologischen Fortschritt.
So, also Russwurm hat es ja vorhin aufgeworfen, er hat den Ball jetzt aufgenommen. Die haben auf offener Bühne hier einfach diesen antidemokratischen Weg einmal eingeschlagen.
Ich glaube allerdings, dass man sich fast diese Debatte um den Verbrenner sparen kann, denn der Verbrenner wird sich von selbst erledigen. Es wird kein Markt mehr da sein. Die Sache ist die, alle Automobilunternehmen der Welt versuchen, möglichst schnell umzustellen. Möglichst schnell meint, natürlich nehmen die noch die Profite mit, die man mit dem Verbrenner erzielen kann. Wenn aber erst einmal ein gewisses Stadium erreicht ist, mit der E-Mobilität, es dann auch viel einfacher wird, wird es natürlich auch so sein, dass was zurückgebaut wird, nämlich Tankstellen. Und dann hat man irgendwann ein großes Problem, überhaupt mit diesem Auto noch sinnvoll durch die Gegend zu fahren. Und da kann man fest von ausgehen, dass da noch ein paar Innovationssprünge auch kommen werden, die das so schnell machen. Und gerade so mit chinesischen Autos oder es gibt noch andere Länder, die plötzlich in die Autoproduktion gehen. Google, Apple wird auch für Autos sehr wichtig werden und die werden sich da auch nicht mehr mit dem Verbrenner groß rumschlagen wollen. Das heißt, das ist hier nochmal Politik für Herrn Russwurm und seine Altersgenossen.
Ja, vor allem war sie.
Aber ich glaube, das können die sich schon jetzt da abschminken. Da kann der machen, was er will. Also die könnten das Gesetz durchbringen oder nicht. Da wird sich nicht viel tun. Der Verbrenner wird dann eh 2035 so gut wie verschwunden sein.
Genau, also in drei, zehn Jahren noch mal ein Verbrenner kaufen. Man muss allerdings jetzt auch sagen, Lindner hat gut gebrüllt hier auf der Bühne. Die Bundesregierung hat dann am Ende zugestimmt. Also es gibt das 2035-Verbot. Man hat dann noch so eine kleine Floskel zu E-Fuel oder so, um Verbrenner, das verbrennt man ja auch, irgendwie da noch rein zu bringen. Also in der Hinsicht, das ist schon hier auch sehr viel Theater einfach auf der Bühne gewesen. Wir haben ausführlich über die Taxonomie gesprochen, über Erscheitern und so weiter. Christian Lindner sitzt hier, nach jedem Talk gibt es noch, also nach jeder Rede gibt es noch so ein kleines, so eine Talkrunde, da saß er dann da drin. Und die Art und Weise, wie er hier über die Taxonomie redet, finde ich, dafür, dass das auch mit die Wachstumsstrategie ist, die Merz eben noch so abgefeiert hat als seine Idee, ist das wirklich gruselig. Die reagieren da drauf, die wollen nur zu uns kommen, wenn wir attraktiv sind.
Ja, ich würde ja auch einen Satz zu diesem Komplex Taxonomie verlieren wollen, als Oppositions-
Und er greift sich dafür noch extra das Wort, er wurde nicht mal explizit gefragt nach Taxonomie, sondern es lag ihm wirklich im Herzen so, dass er das hier noch auf der Bühne anbringen will.
Politiker, habe ich immer gesagt, Taxonomie ist planwirtschaftlich bürokratisch. Habe ich als Oppositionspolitiker gesagt, jetzt bin ich Bundesfinanzminister und ich sehe es etwas anders. Als Oppositionspolitiker sagte ich, bürokratisch und planwirtschaftlich, als Finanzminister muss ich sagen, ich war naiv, es ist viel schlimmer. Es ist viel schlimmer. Ich hatte jetzt ja das Privileg, bei der Taxonomie mit der Kommission mitsprechen zu dürfen, die war nicht alleine federführend natürlich, das waren andere, mitsprechen zu dürfen über Taxonomie im Bereich Energie, Kernenergie und Gas. Von wegen bürokratisch und planwirtschaftlich, ein politisches Schlachtfeld.
Ja natürlich, man wird es dazu verwandelt. Jetzt gehen wir mal ohne Scheuklappen hier rein und machen noch irgendwas mit Atomkraft und so weiter. Klar, wenn sowas dann alles da eingeklammert wird in einen Katalog.
Diese Anti-Europäen-Verhaltung ist ja ganz erstaunlich. Das ist ja fast so wie die Anfangstage der AfD, wo die dann immer so gegen Europa geschossen haben.
Ja und du hast jetzt eben schon die Moderatorin gehört, die ihn auch noch so ein bisschen anfeuert, weil sie einfach aus ihrer Rolle verhält und da so mitlacht. Jetzt hören wir ihn, also Linda redet sich jetzt um Kopf und Kragen und wird dann noch so ein bisschen mit angefeuert von der Moderatorin. Also wir sehen ja ganz viel professionelles Scheitern und aus der Rolle fallen in diesem Clip.
Also ich bin Politikwissenschaftler. Wie soll ich über solche physikalischen Fragen entscheiden können? Dann habe ich gedacht, Mensch, der Robert Habeck, dass der das alles kann, aber dann vielmehr auf, der ist ja auch kein Physiker, sondern der ist ja Schriftsteller. Wie kann der das? So und deshalb nach vorne gerichtet die Forderung. Das, was wir jetzt bei Energie gemacht haben, das kriegt man nicht mehr weg. Will man vielleicht auch nicht, also streichen sie das aus dem Protokoll, das ist da, habe ich gesagt. Aber es darf sich dasselbe jetzt nicht noch wiederholen bei einer sozialen Taxonomie, wo wir das alles noch einmal bekommen, planwirtschaftlich, bürokratisch und ich sage mal in Anführungsstrichen politikanfällig.
So, dieses letzte Wort.
Politik anfällig.
Politik anfällig von einem Politiker, ne?
Ja.
Wir müssen die Dinge so machen, dass sie nicht politikanfällig werden, weil dann würde jemand Politik dazu machen.
Und dann würde am Ende noch der Wähler was zu entscheiden haben.
Genau. Und das ist, wie soll man sagen, also ich finde keine Worte dafür. Auch diese Idee von die Taxonomie, also der Kriterienkatalog für Green Finance, wo wir einfach mal Sachen rausnehmen, die das Klima schädigen und da sagen, wird ein bisschen zurückgefahren, weil Anreize fehlen. Es ist ja noch nicht mal richtig Politik, sondern fehlen erst mal nur wirtschaftliche Anreize. Und er bringt ja einfach so eine soziale Taxonomie. Also jetzt bloß nicht noch Sozialpolitik machen. Habt ihr sie noch alle und so? Müssen wir uns echt davor wappnen, dass hier irgendwer Politik macht. Das ist einfach wirklich pure Antipolitik. Das kann man nicht anders. Das ist eigentlich das Beispiel, das Paradebeispiel für Antipolitik.
Zwei Dinge noch dazu. Einmal möchte ich noch mal verweisen auf das Buch, das wir immer mal wieder angesprochen haben von Grégoire Chamayoux, die Gesellschaft der Unregierbaren. Da wird noch mal sehr gut gezeigt, inwieweit dieser Neoliberalismus, den Lindner hier vertritt, natürlich antidemokratisch ist und dass man immer sagt, wir müssen sehen, dass die Gesellschaft, dass die Bürger möglichst wenig Chance haben, sich einzumischen. Und das Zweite ist, dass es ja doch höchst amüsant ist, dass er hier erzählt, naja, der Habeck, der ist ja nur Schriftsteller und ich bin Politikwissenschaftler. Wie kann der sich damit Physik auskennen? Da frage ich mich dann auch, naja, aber warum ist er dann als Politikwissenschaftler Finanzminister? Da hat er ja in dem Ministerium auch nichts verloren.
Ganz genau. Fehlamtplätze. Die Wespe ist, glaube ich, rausgeflogen. Wir haben sie vertrieben. Wir sind ja sehr von diesem Klimawandel eingeschränkt. Jetzt kommt der Klimawandelsminister Robert Habeck. Diese ganze Veranstaltung plätschert er hier so sechs Stunden vor sich hin. Und es war ermüdend, sich diese Antipolitik von beiden Seiten anzuhören.
Vielleicht noch einen Aspekt, will ich noch gerade abholen, weil es mir gerade in den Sinn kommt. Wir haben jetzt heute noch gar nicht groß über den Krieg gesprochen. Aber es gibt ja so diese Ideen, was ist danach, wie viel kann die Ukraine erreichen? Ich glaube jetzt nicht, dass da im Status von 2014 zurückgeobert werden kann. Ich halte das wie illusorisch. Aber nehmen wir mal an, es kommt wirklich sehr gut. Also besser, als man vielleicht jetzt gerade annehmen kann. Man würde tatsächlich den Status von Februar wiederherstellen können. Die Ukraine hätte nichts verloren und die Russen würden sich zurückziehen. Nehmen wir mal an, das würde tatsächlich passieren. Und jetzt hat man der Ukraine diese EU-Mitgliedschaft offeriert. Wir wissen, das dauert mindestens zehn Jahre, wenn es schnell geht. Und es wird auch nicht schneller sein in diesem Falle. Und jetzt haben wir diesen Finanzminister hier, der jetzt noch mal sagt, soziale Taxonomie, also wenn das jetzt noch kommt, dann ist aber wirklich hier Sozialismus. Was glauben wir denn, wie das mit der Ukraine aussehen müsste? In der Ukraine ist jetzt vieles zerbombt, aber die war auch schon vorher bitterarm. Erster Land Europas, glaube ich, oder fast. Jetzt brauchen wir extrem viel Geld, das in die Ukraine dann gepulvert würde, also wenn Frieden herrscht, ja. Und dann müsste da der große soziale Fortschritt beginnen. Denn sonst passiert Folgendes. Und das ist jetzt mein, ich kann erstmal, ich will das positive Szenario ausmalen. Das positive Szenario, die EU gibt rechtzeitig Geld, es gibt da viele Förderungen, die werden dann irgendwann Mitglied. Aber es entwickelt sich alles so gut. Zelensky wird wiedergewählt. Es herrscht Aufstieg dort. Es herrscht ein Wohlstand, wie er vorher noch nicht da war. Und man hat es dann über die Jahre weg mit einem prosperierenden Land zu tun. Das ging aber nur mit gemeinschaftlicher Verschuldung auf europäischer Ebene und den Finanzministern, die mitspielen. Wie optimistisch muss man sein, um das zu glauben? Deswegen jetzt mal die Dystopie. Die Dystopie sieht so aus, dass wir natürlich bei unserer Sparpolitik bleiben. Natürlich wird die Ukraine dann unterstützt werden und da werden auch sich paar private Investoren gütlich tun. Aber wir haben natürlich da einen, zum Beispiel Finanzminister Lindner, der auf der Bremse steht. Wie man das übrigens schon häufiger hatte. Man hat Ländern mit Waffen oder so geholfen. Und wenn es aber dann darum ging, zwei Schulen zu errichten, hat man gesagt, ah ja gut, aber jetzt eine halbe Million. Wir haben das nämlich in Afghanistan so gesehen. Ein Freund von mir hat mich darauf hingewiesen, noch mal den Krieg des Charlie Willsons zu gucken. Da geht es ja darum, wie bewaffnet man die Afghanen in den 80er-Jahren. Und dann bewaffnet man die. Das schafft dann ein Abgeordneter, das ist ein ganz abgedrehter Film. Und danach, was macht man dann? Dann müsste man eigentlich da eine Gesellschaft aufbauen, die nicht fundamentalistisch wird oder so. Und man tut das nicht. Und dann hat man eben das Debakel, das man da organisiert hat, hat dann Bin Laden am Ende da gezüchtet. Und was könnte jetzt als Dystopie der Ukraine drohen? Zelensky wird noch einmal wiedergewählt. Klar, er ist jetzt dann ein Held da. Er wird das dann mit der Korruption vielleicht nicht so richtig in Griff bekommen, bekommt nicht genügend Unterstützung in Form von Geld von der EU. Dann merken die Leute, wir haben zwar jetzt die Russen verdrängt, wieder in einen Zaum gehalten, aber bei uns gibt es ja gar keinen Aufstieg. Wir sind ja immer noch bitterarm. Und dann braucht nur eine rechte Partei zu kommen, wie die polnische PiS-Partei, die die soziale Frage von rechts beantwortet. Und dann ist es nicht ausgeschlossen, dass wir 2028 irgendwo die Meldung bekommen, Regierung der Ukraine will LGBT-freie Zonen umkirfen.
Also, so wie wir vorhin schon darüber sprachen, dass eine Pflicht ja völlig undenkbar ist, weil der volkswirtschaftliche Opportunitätskosten Schadensfall dadurch, dass dann 300.000 Leute nicht für den Arbeitsmarkt zur Verfügung stehen oder verzögert, dass das einfach diesem ganzen Projekt den Boden oder den Füßen wegreißt. Warum ist der Ukraine-Krieg für uns gerade ein großes Problem? Wir haben das letzte Mal über den Hunger gesprochen, weil dort immens große und zwar die größten Getreidefelder der Welt stehen. Was ist die Europäische Union? Die Europäische Union hat einen Haushalt von 300 Milliarden Euro oder so und zu 80% fließt sie einfach nur in Agrarflächen. Wenn du die Ukraine in die Europäische Union aufnimmst, fließt die Hälfte dieses Geldes sofort in die Ukraine, weil dort diese Weizenfelder sind.
Dann gucken wir uns dann die Tagung vom Bauernverband an. Da bin ich ja gespannt.
Es ist völlig undenkbar, dass die Ukraine in diese Europäische Union beitritt. Entweder man kriegt sie noch mal grob umgebaut in ein sozialpolitisches Projekt, was auch immer. Da würde allerdings das Publikum verlangen, dass es ein Aufbau ist an Politik und kein Abbau. Diese Gelderverteilung nach Agrarfläche, mehrere hundert Milliarden im Jahr, kriegst du so nicht rausgestrichen. Und gleichzeitig müsstest du das aber. Es wäre ein Minusgeschäft für alle, die davon profitieren und wir wissen, wie sehr die Ernährungsindustrie davon profitiert. Ich habe letztens wieder gelesen, die Supermärkte selbst kassieren Agrarsubventionen, weil sie mit dem Geld, das sie erwirtschaften, riesige Agrarflächen aufkaufen und dann verpachten. Und es fließt ja an den Eigentümer und nicht an denjenigen, der tatsächlich Getreide anbaut.
Und es wird immer mehr gekauft, gerade von diesen großen...
Es ist ein bisschen wie im Mittelalter damals, die Willikation. Du hast diese einzelnen Dörfer, die machen so Selbstversorgertum und dann hast du so einen Fürsten oder einen Adelstypen, der sitzt irgendwo auf dem Berg, so sichtweite, der kommt dann einmal im Jahr vorbei und will so sein Schutzgeld haben. So, die übernehmen sich dann aber wirtschaftlich, also kauft das Kloster, was schon nicht mehr in Sichtweite ist, zehn Kilometer weiter auf. Und irgendwann hast du Klöster als religiöse Veranstaltungen, die eigentlich wie Vereine so gar nicht an Profiten denken oder so, die aber allein über dieses Einzugsgebiet im Sinne von Einzugsgebiet, mehrere hundert Kilometer radien und so, wo die einfach nur beschäftigt sind, damit das Geld einzusammeln, den Zehnten, der da erwirtschaftet wird, dass die alle weltliche Macht komplett überflügeln. Gleiches mit Fugada in Augsburg und so. Irgendwann ist der Kaiser so bei dir verschuldet, dass du eigentlich das Gefüge überrumpelt hast und jetzt die wirtschaftliche Macht wichtiger ist als die politische Macht. Und das ist irgendwie bei diesen ganzen Agrarzeugen dieses Höfe-Sterben, was ja wirklich nur Konzentration auf größere Höfe und so weiter angeht. Und in diesem Gefüge, und wir haben ja die Agrarpolitik diskutiert, wie das da abläuft, wie die Lobbyisten da im Bundestag und so weiter.
Und Julia Klöckner zeichnet nochmal das Bild der Baumenbauern, die früh auf dem Felde stehen mit der Sense.
Genau. Und wie willst du in so einem Gefüge die Ukraine als das wichtigste Nahrungsmittelversorgungsland der Welt da aufnehmen? Also da würden sofort hunderte Milliarden so kreuz und quer anders fließen. Genau. Da hast du dann wirklich die particularen Interessen, die da dagegen stehen.
Und das müsste man jetzt eigentlich, wenn man wirklich der Ukraine etwas Gutes tun will, dann muss man das jetzt thematisieren, damit die Leute aus diesen Illusionen aufwachen und damit wirklich gesehen wird, woran wird es dann irgendwann scheitern, wenn es scheitert mit der Ukraine. Man wird nämlich dann diesen Diskurs nicht so in die Öffentlichkeit bringen, sondern dann wird das irgendwas und da ist man sich noch uneins und weiß ich nicht was. Aber das müsste man eigentlich tun, um diese Schwierigkeit jetzt schon deutlich zu machen, statt irgendwelche unsinnigen Maximalforderungen in Talkshows zu vertreten, wo man sagen kann, ja, das gibt mal kurz Applaus und dann wird man auch noch retweetet. Aber das hat mit der Realität nichts zu tun.
Das war jetzt alles Stimmungsmache. Die Ukraine wird so nicht in die EU aufgenommen. Jedenfalls nicht in diese EU. Da muss man dann schon noch ein paar Sachen verändern. Und so ist auch Habeck hier auf der Bühne. Ich finde, der Einzige, der das Format irgendwie verstanden hat, dass man nicht auf der Bühne irgendwelche Versprechungen und dann eine Woche später stellen doch alle fest, naja, sie haben sich doch nicht durchgesetzt, Herr Lindner, als die Bundesregierung in Brüssel auftrat und Verbrennungsverbot verhandelt hat. Habeck kommt einfach hier wirklich als Literat.
Manchmal habe ich Zeit am Sonntag und gehe noch länger joggen. Und es gibt einen Podcast, den ich dann manchmal meistens höre, der heißt Ukrainecast von der BBC. Ich würde sagen, ein journalistisches Meisterwerk mit verschiedenen Geschichten aus der…
Der Bundeswirtschaftsminister fährt zum Industrietag des BDI und gibt den allen erstmal eine Podcastempfehlung.
Ja, ich dachte, er sagt jetzt Neuen Zwanziger.
Egal, wir bleiben inhaltlich ganz neutral. Das ist erstmal ein ganz toller Modus, um so eine Rede zu hören.
Ukraine, aber auch russische Geschichten. Und diese Geschichten sind Geschichten aus dem Krieg. Zum Beispiel wurde… und man läuft durch den Wald, hätte man nicht Kopfhörer im Ohr, würde man die Vögel singen hören, man sieht das gebrochene Licht. Also das, was ich als einen schönen, vielleicht einen erhabenen Moment begreifen würde, man hört dann die Geschichten, die quasi gleichzeitig passieren, von einer Familie, junge Mutter, junger Vater, zwei Töchter, Bombenangriff, sie fliehen vor den Bomben, der Vater und die Tochter, eine der Tochter werden getötet, sie sitzen danach, die Familie, die Mutter und die überlebende Tochter über Tage im Bunker und sie bitten, die ukrainischen oder die russischen Soldaten, ich weiß gar nicht wer, den Mann und die Tochter endlich zu beerdigen. Und es geht nicht, weil keiner rauskommen kann.
Das halte ich mal für eine ganz sinnvolle Stimmungsmache.
Das ist jetzt ja der schulpstellerische Einstieg, den er hier gewählt hat, wenngleich ihm da bisschen die ästhetischen Kategorien durchgegangen sind, das Schöne und das Erhabene. Da muss man nochmal bei Schildern nachlesen, das ist was anderes.
Das finde ich auch.
Aber das lassen wir jetzt an dieser Stelle.
Hauptsache einer hat mal bei Sinnen dort seinen Auftritt organisiert und ist nicht einfach nur mit Vollgas da irgendwie durch seine Ideologie gerast.
Solche Geschichten werden dort dargestellt und man hört die und versteht auf einmal wieder, was eigentlich Phase gerade in Europa ist. Und was gerade Phase in unserer Welt ist, dass Putin nämlich einen Krieg vom Zaun gebrochen hat. Aus meiner Sicht, weil er die individuelle Freiheit von Menschen nicht er tragen kann.
So und jetzt erweitert er den Blickfeld inhaltlich. So wie Merz sagte, ich lese ja auch die Seiten des APCC-Berichts, den sonst niemand liest, sagt er nicht nur Podcasts, sondern...
Die Reduktion der Gaslieferung durch Nord Stream 1 ist eben auch ein Angriff auf uns. Ein ökonomischer Angriff auf uns. Und dass Putin in seiner Petersburger Rede in einer Art Orwellschen Neusprech alles verdreht hat, also Krieg zu Frieden erklärt hat, Unfreiheit willkürliche Diktatur zum eigentlich zu bevorzugenden Gesellschaftsmodell zeigt nur, wie bewusst dieser Angriff erfolgt.
Und er bezieht sich auf Orwell und ist es nicht so, dass in der Neuausgabe von Orwell Habeck das Vorwort geschrieben hat, oder bringe ich das gerade durcheinander?
Ehrlich? Davon habe ich nichts gehört.
Ich glaube fast damals, also noch bevor er in Hampton-Würden war.
Da informieren uns bestimmt die Hörer drüber, wie dieser Sachstand ist.
Man kann das ja nachgucken.
Nicht uninteressant. Also was ist hier eigentlich Phase und so weiter?
Woher kommt eigentlich diese Formulierung? Die höre ich jetzt sehr häufig und ich mag sie nicht.
Na, das ist diese Ingenieurssache, du hast deinen Strom und dann hast du diesen komischen Schraubenzieher, der aufleuchtet, wenn irgendwas Phase ist oder so und dann überprüfst du, wie die Phase ist seit irgendeinem Ingenieursbezug. Jetzt lachen wieder einige, die uns hier zuhören, wie wir rätseln darüber, was hier Phase ist. Aber es ist eine Überprüfung, der ich glaube, es geht auch viel um Sicherheit, dass man die Leute in sich, also die sich selbst und die Maschine, die man anschließend Sicherheit bringt mit einer Überprüfung. Was ist eigentlich gerade Phase, bevor man die Kreisläufe schließt? Auf die Petersburger Rede, die ja hier zu sprechen kam, das war nämlich Putins Wirtschaftsforum. Kommen wir gleich im Schnelldurchlauf dann noch zu sprechen. Ich will jetzt mal diesen vorhin schon angeteaserten, das geht auch eine Minute 38 ein bisschen länger, während Lindner auf der Bühne steht und sagt, naja die Subventionen und so, ich weiß schon, sie brauchen sie eigentlich nicht, aber kriegen sie trotzdem. Robert Habeck, wie schon beim Wohnbautag, wo er ja auch dieses Ganze, wir fördern hier Energiestandards, die schon längst von Ihnen eingehalten werden, wieso verarschen sie uns eigentlich? Wieso fördern wir hier ein Standard? Das ist doch irgendwie bescheuert. So macht das hier auch.
Und umgekehrt brauche ich natürlich, brauchen meine Leute die Expertise aus ihren Unternehmen, die Daten für die Versorgung, aber auch das Denken in Modellen, um unsere Arbeit zu überprüfen. Das ist eine gewisse Form von Kooperatismus, der Deutschland stark gemacht hat, als Normalform. Dass man mit den Verbänden, Gewerkschaften, würde ich jetzt einfach mit einbeziehen, versucht hat, die beste Lösung, den besten Weg zu finden. Da darf nur nicht missverstanden werden. Natürlich gibt es verschiedene Interessen, auch sozialpolitische Interessen, möglicherweise wettbewerbspolitische Interessen. Aber was ich besonders zu schätzen weiß ist, und so scheint es mir, dass wir uns, darf ich das mal in meiner Sprache sagen, nicht gegenseitig verarschen. Und das ist die Bedingung dafür, dass es gut läuft. Dass wenn Sie sagen, wenn Ihre Unternehmen sagen, wenn der Verband sagt, die Idee ist theoretisch gut, aber sie wird nicht zu dem Ergebnis führen, dass du dir vorgestellt hast, du musst noch mal ran und nach sitzen. Dann tun wir das, weil ich das Gefühl habe, es ist ernst gemeint. Es geht hier nicht darum, dann weniger Gewinne zu haben, sondern das ernste Anliegen ist wirklich besser zu machen. Und ich hoffe, dass ihr es genauso gut, ich es genauso gut zurückspiele und sage, wenn wir bestimmte Sachen politisch nicht gehen, dann liegt es nicht daran, dass irgendein Parteiprogramm von 2017 den im Wege steht, sondern weil wir es überprüft haben und wir zu anderen Ergebnissen gekommen sind. Und wenn Sie andere Ergebnisse haben, dann reden wir darüber. Aber wir dürfen uns in dieser Lage, wir müssen uns in dieser Lage vertrauen und nicht versuchen, zu übervorteilen. Und genauso erlebe ich diese Zeit und dafür wollte ich mich einmal ganz herzlich bedanken.
Das ist irgendwie diese Naivität, die da drinsteckt, wie auch schon beim Wohnbautag. Machen die das jetzt wirklich, verzichten die jetzt auf eine Subvention, klären die die auf?
Nun, aber also wir haben es nachgeschaut. Es ist tatsächlich so, er hat das Vorwort geschrieben zu 1984.
Aber warte, bevor du es ausführst, Robert Habeck hat ein Vorwort zur Neuübersetzung von George Orwells 1984 geschrieben und es ist nicht so gut geworden. Aha, steht klar.
Gut, jedenfalls hat er es dann vermutlich gelesen, wenn er das Vorwort geschrieben hat.
Das glaube ich.
Das ist eine sehr eigenartige Haltung, sich zu bedanken für die gute Zusammenarbeit. Und doch habe ich den Eindruck, dass es nicht ganz falsch ist, also diese Annahme, die er da trifft. Denn was ja doch erstaunlich ist, ist, dass wir jetzt Folgendes erleben. Wir entschließen uns, möglichst schnell aus der russischen Energie rauszugehen. Wir erleben aber einen Russwurm, der sonst sich mit Händen und Füßen gegen ein Lieferkettengesetz sträubt. Wir erleben einen Lindner, der sagt Taxonomie, das ist Sozialismus, das ist Planwirtschaft und hoffentlich nicht noch eine soziale Taxonomie. Wir erleben eine Industrie, eine Deutsche, die stark in China verankert ist und Profite einhalbt. Aber offenbar hat man es tatsächlich politisch geschafft oder medial auch hervorgehoben. Also es ist zumindest eine Stimmung da, dass jetzt der BDI nicht einfach nur in Bezug auf Russland auch seine Kapitalinteressen vertritt. Also das ist ja so eigenartig, dass man hier so punktuell anders agiert. Denn man könnte ja auch sagen als Russwurm, es ist alles ganz schlimm, was da passiert, aber wir müssen auch an uns denken und deswegen brauchen wir weiterhin günstige Energie, sonst produzieren wir eine Rezession. Das wäre ja ein Argument, das man durchaus von einem Industrieverband machen könnte, wird aber nicht getan. Ich kann mir das auch nicht ganz erklären, weil das so ein bisschen der Logik, in der sonst die deutsche Industrie agiert, widerspricht. Aber offenbar ist der Druck dann so hoch und man würde sich so unmöglich machen, dass das irgendwie nicht geht, weil ich jetzt nicht glaube, dass die jetzt alle so unglaublich moralisch geworden sind.
Also ich hätte Clipstar, werde sie aber nicht spielen, aus Längegründen. Monitor hat einen sehr guten Bericht dazu gemacht, wie es die griechischen Reedereien geschafft haben, das Sanktionsregime zu umgehen und weiterhin russisches Erdöl durch die Welt fahren.
Die machen das, glaube ich, so, dass die Schiffe umgeladen werden, ne? Dass es auf einem Meer findet, dass zum Teil zumindest statt.
Ja, also bei Monitor ist es so, dass die wirklich einfach Ausnahmeregelung für griechische Reedereien, ohne noch technische Fölle fanden oder so, sondern einfach nur, die dürfen einfach weiterfahren, weil die davon abhängig sind. Das ist für die Milliarden-Business die größten Flotten der Welt und so weiter und die fahren einfach. Also wenn wir jetzt immer hören, ich habe mir das auch mal rausgeschrieben, weil das ist wirklich beeindruckend. Russland ist neuerdings der größte Öl-Lieferant Chinas. Saudi-Arabien wurde da abgelöst, es sind so im Jahresvergleich 55% plus in diesen Lieferdingern. Indien, der indischen Regierung zur Folge, hat man den Ölimport aus Russland in den Jahresfrist um das 31-fache gesteigert. Also dieses ganze, Indien kauft jetzt das Öl, das wird von diesen griechischen Reedereien da hingefahren. Da liegt keine Pipeline oder nichts.
Genau, da muss man dann auch noch mal die Frage der Verhältnismäßigkeit stellen. Was auf jeden Fall nicht geht, ist, dass man jetzt hier wirklich existenzielle Sorgen Menschen bereitet mit der Energie. Also jetzt, den BDI, da habe ich jetzt wenig Mitleid, aber dass Energiekosten für Leute, die nicht viel Geld haben, einfach untragbar werden. Und da gibt es auch noch keine richtige Antwort. Also ich weiß, da wird dann ein bisschen rumgeschustet und so, aber die Belastung für Leute, die kein hohes Einkommen haben, das ist auch schon mittleren Einkommen, trifft es auch schon ziemlich hart. Da wird einfach zu wenig getan und da kann man nicht einfach sagen, naja, das ist jetzt halt gerade unsere Zeitenwende. Das geht so nicht. Und gerade wenn man auch weiß, dass ja trotzdem extrem viel exportiert wird und wir auch wissen, dass wir generell bei dem Import von Energien keine weiße Weste behalten können, denn natürlich ist es so, dass in den arabischen Ländern gerade Hochkonjunktur herrscht, weil wir wie verrückt jetzt da sagen, wir müssen dringend euer Öl, euer Gas haben. Also das ist und da finde ich, da muss ja auch, würde ich auch nochmal Habeck darauf hinweisen wollen, er hat natürlich auch eine Verantwortung gegenüber der eigenen Bevölkerung.
Ja, das ist eigentlich ein immer wichtiges Anliegen der Grünen gewesen, derzeit, na mal gucken, welches Programm sie bereiten ja schon vor den nächsten Winter jetzt und so. Mal sehen. Finaler Appell von Habeck, ja die Zeiten sind einfach wirklich irre und ich finde es auch crazy, mit wie viel Paradoxien man es eigentlich zu tun hat.
Dann ist da natürlich auch die Chance für eine bessere Zukunft drin, in dieser Zeit und ich glaube, genau das passiert im Moment und genau das ist die Antwort auf die vierte Ungleichzeitigkeit. Sie haben volle Auftragsbücher und eine Angst vor Rezession, wir haben einen Fachkräftemangel und einen hohen Bedarf an neuen Arbeitskräften und Arbeitsplätzen, wir sind ein attraktiver Standort, große Unternehmen kommen nach Europa, Batterieunternehmen, Halbleiter und Industrie und gleichzeitig gibt es die große Sorge, dass die nächsten Monate uns in die Rezession führen. Diese Ungleichzeitigkeit, sie lässt sich auflösen durch politische und wirtschaftspolitische Handlung.
Ja, ich sehe hier die Gefahr, dass sie jetzt wirklich alle nur glauben, es ist ja nur so eine Krisenszene, Corona geht ja vorbei, der Krieg geht ja vorbei. Aber es gibt eben auch diese langfristigen Klimawandel, demografischer Wandel, dieses ganze, was ist mit diesem Internet, wo werden die dann noch und so.
Und eine Rezession dauert sechs bis acht Quartale.
Ja, also das ist alles sehr kompliziert. Habeck tut mir an solchen Momenten wieder ein bisschen leid, wenn er selber so nach Worten ringt und so in die Knie geht und auch nicht genau weiß, wie er seine frei, also bewusst freigehaltene Rede dann da irgendwie zum Abschluss bringt. Und er hat ja diesen Petersburger-Dings angesprochen. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob wir es so richtig klipsweise durchgehen müssen. Wir können es auch referieren.
Vielleicht so ein bisschen, dass man einen Eindruck von dieser Veranstaltung hat, denn man hat auch so gut wie, also man hatte kaum Zugang dazu, oder?
Super schwer. Ich musste hier eine Aufnahme von VK, also RT hat sich darum gekümmert, dass es dokumentiert wird. Und dann gab es bei vk.com irgendeinen Account, der dann diese deutsche Tonspur zur Verfügung gestellt hat. Das ließ ich aber nicht runterladen. Ich musste es dann vier Stunden lang abfilmen und so weiter. Dann habe ich die erste Aufnahme weggeschmissen, weil ich nicht drüber nachgedacht hatte, als ich noch mal abgefilmt. Alles super kompliziert. Es ist tatsächlich, wie Robert Habeck sagt, es ist, wenn man nur die europäische, die westliche Sicht auf dieses, was da gerade stattfindet, insgesamt hat und dann hört man plötzlich Putin reden und man erkennt diese innere Logik, die da drinsteckt. Aber man weiß von außen betrachtet, naja, das ist alles schon crazy, das überhaupt so hinzubiegen. Aber diese inhärente Logik, die doch gegeben ist, das mal so nachzuvollziehen in dieser ganzen Länge, also 30 Minuten Rede oder 45 Minuten und dann noch mal zwei Stunden Gespräch. Ich hab das dann auch nicht komplett, weil das war dann auch zu viel spontanes Zeug. Da gibt es so ein paar Clips, wo man sich auch wieder fragen kann und so. Aber diese geplante Wortwahl in der Rede, von der Robert Harvey auch sprach, klang so, die Dowager wechseln immer so ein bisschen her, ein Mann und eine Frau und so. Aber ich glaube, man kann innerlich so ein bisschen folgen.
Viele Handels- und logistische Verbindungen wurden zuerst in der Pandemie zerstört und stehen jetzt vor neuen Herausforderungen. Soll ich die Schlüssel begriffen?
So, zuerst die Pandemie und jetzt neue Herausforderungen. Wir sagen einfach zuerst die Pandemie und dann dieser Krieg, der Depp, Putin und so weiter.
Wie Geschäftsruf, Unantastbarkeit, das Eigentumsvertrauen gegenüber internationalen Währungen ist ebenfalls untergraben worden. Leider von unseren westlichen Partnern und das wurde mit Absicht getan, wegen der Ambitionen, um altertümliche geopolitische Illusionen zu bewahren.
Altertümliche geopolitische Ambition meint Menschenrechte und so was wahrscheinlich.
Zum Beispiel.
Und dass man an die Unversehrtheit territorialer Grenzen glauben möchte.
Aber auch zum Beispiel, dass die Logik, der den besten Preis bietet, der auf Verkaufszahlen der Öl dann auch gilt, sondern hier wurden einfach altertümliche Ideologien und so. Der Westen hängt an seinen überholten Klischees und Irrtümern.
Sie halten sich am Schatten der Vergangenheit fest. Sie glauben, dass das Dominieren des Westens in der globalen Wirtschaft eine konstante, etwas Ewiges ist. Aber nichts bleibt in der Welt ewig. Unsere Kollegen leugnen nicht einfach die Realität, sondern sie versuchen, sich hier gegen den Trend der Geschichte zu setzen, denken in Klischees der Vergangenheit und sind Opfer der eigenen Irrtümer.
Jetzt haben wir schon zweimal Vergangenheit gehört. Das ist ziemlich wichtig, dass wir das mal so rezipieren.
Ja, mega.
Wir sagen nämlich hier die ganze Zeit, Putin ist ein Mann der Vergangenheit. Wir haben mehrmals auch Clips gehabt, ein Mann des 20. Jahrhunderts, ein Mann des KGB und so etwas. Und jetzt haben wir hier Putin stehen, der dreht den Spieß genau um und sagt, ja, das sind diese Leute mit Menschenrechten hervorgegangen aus den Nürnberger Prozessen. So eine Idee von, wir müssen intervenieren, wenn Menschenrechtsverletzungen so. Das ist alt. Jetzt beginnt die neue Zeit mit neuen Menschenrechten, die definiere ich und die kann der Herr Chi definieren. Und auch ein neuer Verbund von Leuten, die miteinander wirtschaften können. Weil unsere Partner ja da gar nicht mehr verlässlich sind, also der Westen.
Es gibt neue Kraftzentren auf der Welt, neue Ideen, wohin man streben muss. Und was noch fehlt, sind neue Führungsfiguren. Und da stellt er sich als einen vor, der jetzt so eine Anwaltschaft für die ganzen unterdrückten Länder dieser Welt, vom Westen unterjocht und so weiter. 50 Sklaven pro westlichen Einwohner, der sich da einfach breiterklärt, jetzt die Führungsrolle zu übernehmen.
Das ist gut, dass du das nochmal gerade sagst mit diesen Sklaven und bindet nochmal so an den Anfang mit der Documenta. Man muss ein bisschen aufpassen, dass dieser antikolonialistische und antimperialistische Gedanke, der ja richtig und wichtig ist, dass dieser nun nicht bei denen, die das eigentlich progressiv meinen, dazu verführt, dass man plötzlich einen ideologischen Weg bereitet, für Leute wie Putin, die dann sagen, ja genau, wir sind ja auch gegen den Imperialismus. Und was der Westen macht, ist jetzt da gerade kolonialistisch. Und man übersieht dann den Imperialismus des russischen Staates. Also diese Zentrierung darauf, der Westen ist schlimm, sorgt natürlich dafür, dass man oft übersieht, inwieweit andere Länder expansionistisch und so weiter agieren. Und das ist so ein großer blinder Fleck. Also bei Russland ist er jetzt nicht so stark ausgeprägt. Aber man kann das, wenn man zum Beispiel über China spricht, auch mit Akademikern oder so, sehr oft sehen, dass man sagt, naja, also wir dürfen ja mal gar nicht sagen, was hat denn die deutsche Kolonialvergangenheit alles uns Schlimmes gebracht, vor Augen geführt. Da haben wir doch gesehen, was wir da angetan haben. Da würde ich sagen, ja, das stimmt. Aber jetzt kann es auch andere Kolonialherren geben, außer die Deutschen, nur weil die das vor 120 Jahren mal gemacht haben.
Und es hat vielleicht auch noch mal andere Dimensionen, wenn man sich das mit den Uiguren da anschaut und so. Putin, greift ihr so ein schönes westliches Bild auf?
Wenn einer aus der Reihe tanzt, rebellisch ist und sich nicht unterdrücken lässt, so wird dieser eingeschränkt oder gecancelt, wie man sagt, man cancelt die Kultur, Meisterwerke. Und nur aus diesem Grunde, weil die Urheber falsche Abstammung sind.
Da sind wir wirklich bei Brock wieder. Wer hat hier welche Abstammung und dann wird gecancelt.
Das ist auch die Natur dieser Russlandfeindlichkeit im Westen und der wahnsinnigen Sanktionen gegen Russland. Wahnsinnig und gedankenlos, unvernünftig. Die Zahl dieser Sanktionen, und so schnell wie sie herausgegeben werden, ist prozedenzlos. Das Kalkül ist klar, plumpe auf einmal, auf einen Schlag und Anhieb die russische Wirtschaft zu verschlagen.
So, er wird später noch vom Blitzkrieg, vom wirtschaftlichen Blitzkrieg gegen Russland sprechen und er bettet das hier ein in so ein Narrativ, bei dem er nach Anschluss sucht, bei den anderen Ländern dies vielleicht ähnlich, indem man dieses Bild aufmacht. An uns werden die Sanktionen bedroht, erprobt, die demnächst als Waffe gegen alle zur Verfügung stehen können.
Der ökonomische Blitzkrieg, wie gesagt, hat keine Chancen auf Erfolg, aber die Sanktionswaffe und die Praxis der heutigen Jahre, dieser Jahre zeigt es, dass es eine zweischneidige Waffe ist, weil diese Waffe einen ähnlichen Schaden oder vielleicht sogar größeren Schaden zufügt, die diese Waffe einsetzen und es geht hier nicht nur um die Folgen heute. Es ist uns bekannt, dass unter den führenden Politikern der europäischen Länder, die besorgniserregenden Perspektiven besprochen werden, dass die Sanktionen nicht nur gegen Russland eingesetzt werden können, sondern gegen jeden jeden Stadt und das mag auch Europa betreffen.
Wir haben jetzt gerade in der Einblendung gesehen, im Publikum sitzen Menschen aus aller Welt, Vertreter aus aller Welt. Und jetzt sagt er nochmal, wir sind jetzt die ersten, die davon getrunken wurden, aber das kann euch auch so ergehen. Deswegen lasst uns hier das Bündnis schmieden, damit der Westen da nicht mehr ran kann. Und das war ja so ein bisschen auch die These von einigen Wirtschaftswissenschaftlern. Wir können jetzt tatsächlich mit sehr harten Sanktionen dagegen vorgehen. Wir können tatsächlich jetzt mal alles tun, was die finanzielle Kriegsführung einem bietet. Aber es kann auch sein, dass das das letzte Mal ist, dass der Westen so mächtig ist und überhaupt diese Mittel zur Verfügung hat. Also das kann sein, dass wir entwaffnet werden dadurch, dass die eigene Systeme sich aufbauen und dann können wir machen, was wir wollen. Aber die machen das unter sich.
Ja, ich finde es jedenfalls erstaunlich. Ich habe ja immer seit das hier läuft, seit drei Monaten, darauf geachtet, wird denn auch der Wirtschaftskrieg mitthematisiert oder nur der militärische. So und der erste Staatsmann, der das mal so richtig macht, ist der Putin. Der diese wirtschaftliche Dimension der Kriegsführung einfach zumindest auf der innerlichen Augenhöhe aufgreift. Klar, auf Seiten des Opfers natürlich, da kommt er nicht drum hin. Dennoch und hier spielt er auch wieder Ping-Pong. Wir wissen natürlich, wie wir diskutieren. Wir haben über den Hunger gesprochen. Annalena Baerbock hat in Bonn so eine große Hungerkonferenz veranstaltet, wo auch noch mal alle vorstellig waren. Bei Putin klingt das so.
In der letzten Zeit hat sich die Rolle Amerikas wirklich verändert. Aus seinem Netto-Exporteur von Lebensmitteln, wo der Amerika zu einem Importeur, zu einem Reinimporteur, also man druckt Geld und kauft auf der ganzen Welt Lebensmittel an. Und noch größere Steigerungen der Warnimporte sind in der EU zu beobachten. Es ist klar, dass diese Steigerung der Nachfrage die Welle des Defizits gestartet hat. Und die globale Inflation, das ist also die Quelle der globalen Inflation.
Die Quelle der globalen Inflation ist, dass Amerika und Europa gerade die Weltmärkte für Ernährung leer kaufen. Also nicht, dass er nichts exportiert oder so.
Vor allem, weil Europa ja sehr viel Wert, EU sehr viel Wert darauf liegt, auch zu exportieren.
Ja, eben, wir sind ja netto un-sinnige Weise.
Ja, das ist schon sehr verquer.
Und dann wendet er sich hier nach innen. Wir fragen uns ja immer, die Oligarchen, die Oligarchen, wer sind denn die Oligarchen? Putin kennt sie sehr genau. Er ruft sie hier namentlich auf.
Bitte machen Sie nicht erneut diesen Fehler. Unser Land hat ein riesiges Potenzial. Wir haben hier riesige Aufgaben. Investieren Sie hier. Investieren Sie in die Entwicklung des Tourismus, in die Schaffung der Arbeitsplätze. Unterstützen Sie Schulen, das Gesundheitswesen, den sozialen Bereich Kultur und Sport. Und ich weiß, dass viele das auch tun. Aber ich wollte das noch einmal unterstreichen. Genauso haben die Missionen von Bakhrushens, Morozovs, Raposhinsky, Galeevs, Anapaevs und Matsievs, Mamontovs, Tsetekovs, Matsanovs, Dadashevs, Gadzhievs viele Russische, Tatarische, Tschechenische, Dagestanische, Jakutische, Judische, Armenische Familien von Kaufleuten. Sie haben natürlich etwas an die direkten Erben vererbt. Also dieses Erbe war schon sehr anständig, aber gleichzeitig haben sie ihren Namen in die Geschichte ihres Landes und der Region eintragen lassen.
Das ist nicht schlecht, oder?
Das ist ganz erstaunlich. Und man sieht dann eingeblendet finster dreinblickende Gesichter, Köpfe nicken. Ja, ja, so war das immer. Man sieht auch wieder der Vielvölkerstaat Russland.
Ja, das ist nicht ohne. Und er schiebt es als Appell noch mal in Kurzwurm nach.
Die Erben des Kapitals ist es fraglich, was für sie wichtiger ist. Das Geld und das Eigentum einerseits oder ihr guter Name und der Ruf für die Verdienste an eigenem Land. Das wird keiner verschwenden können und verdrinken können.
Klarer Ansagen würde ich sagen. Ja, das ist nicht schlecht. Er hatte dann alle möglichen noch zugeschaltet, hier Assisi aus Ägypten und Chi und so ein paar. Und wir hören uns Chis Videobotschaft an. Sie war, keine Ahnung, inwieweit ich dann die kreuz- und quer übersetzten Floskel nicht so dekodiert habe, um dann doch nochmal hier oder wieder gesagt und so. Wir wollten ihn ja eigentlich schon relativ ernst nehmen, bei dem, was er verlautbarte und es ist ja nicht wenig, was da publiziert wird. Diese Videobotschaft, ich habe mal zwei Clips rausgenommen.
Ein kluger Mensch sieht auch in einer günstigen Lage einen möglichen Schaden und in der ungünstigen Lage sieht man mögliche Gewinne.
Das ist so ein bisschen, wie man auch kritisisch sein kann.
Genau, und es ist eben auch Neusprech im Sinne von die Krise kann auch eine Chance sein und die Chance kann auch eine Krise in sich birgen, ohne dass man sie deswegen ist es ambivalent. Wir wissen es immer nicht so genau.
Das ist das, was Zizek als Pseudo-Weisheit bezeichnet. Er sagt, er sei generell gegen Weisheit, weil Weisheit ist immer, dass man für jede Situation den passenden Satz auf Lage hat. Wenn du dich bemühst und daran scheiterst, dann kann ich sagen, Schuster, bleib bei deinem leisten. Wenn du dich bemühst und es schaffst, dann kann ich sagen, ja, du bestätigst es, ohne Fleiß kein Preis. Es stimmt immer irgendwas.
Jede Bauernregel gibt es doppelt. Einmal so und dann einmal genau entgegengesetzt. Und Ci wollte noch Folgendes loswerden.
Wir sind bereit, gemeinsam mit Russland die Entwicklungsperspektiven zu eröffnen und die Wachstumsperspektiven zu nutzen, um einen würdigen Beitrag zu leisten zur Stärkung der Kooperation und zur Ausgestaltung des gemeinsamen positiven Schicksals für die Menschheit.
Für die Menschheit.
Das ist eine Drohung, würde ich sagen.
Ganz klar.
Na ja, was soll man sagen? Also Putin ist ganz wichtig. Das amerikanische Zeitalter ist zu Ende. Russland ist die Speerspitze der neuen Zeit. Anwalt der aufstrebenden Länder, die alle bedroht werden, nicht im großen Club mitspielen zu dürfen. Die Sanktionen sind die neue Waffe. Sie bedrohen alle Länder, auch wenn sie jetzt noch nicht direkt. Aber das Sanktionsregime betrifft ja eben auch alle, die jetzt unterstützend tätig werden. Der Westen kauft die Weltmärkte leer. Wer Russland die Schuld gibt, sagt er dann nochmal. Unterstellt Russland eine dämliche Allmacht? Das ist ganz interessant, wir sind ja gar nicht so mächtig. Wieso sehen die uns so auf Augenhöhe und kämpfen so gegen uns? Wir sind doch nur so eine Regionalmacht. Er hat so ein falsches Allmachtverständnis, da stellt er den da. Ihm ist sehr wichtig, und das hört man eben bei den Deutschen dann wenig. Klar, wir haben dann mal so Habeck auf der Bühne. Aber nicht nur dieses, die Allegalen sollen mal investieren, sondern Kulturprogramme und Naturschutz, weil Heimatschutz. Also auch in die Kultur mit eingepreist. Das ist ihm ganz wichtig, dass der Tourismus gut funktioniert im eigenen Land. Solche Sachen. Na ja, da kann natürlich jetzt jeder... Das ist immer so ein russisches Dokument, wo man ihn mal im Original hört.
So, dann sind wir mit der Zeit schon am Ende. Ein großer Block würde uns noch bevorstehen, aber den schieben wir dann in die nächste Sitzung. Da verraten wir noch nicht, was wir da vorhaben. Es wird um Computerspiele im weitesten Sinne und im engeren Sinne gehen. Ich muss noch ein Wort loswerden, weil es ja zwei Ereignisse gab. Eines haben wir schon angesprochen, Elmau und dann Deutscher Filmpreis. Und nun sind wir da und das ist jetzt mein Appell an die Herren, sind mir da zwei Unmöglichkeiten aufgefallen. Also einmal in Elmau gibt es ja so ein Foto. Ich zeig dir das mal hier. Ich hab das ausgedruckt. Da stehen die alle da ohne Krawatte, unsere ganzen Lieder und halten sich da in den Armen. Wie ist das jetzt ein Hemd ohne Krawatte zu tragen? Ich würde sagen, es ist generell schwierig, wenn gleich ich weiß, der Trend geht weg von der Krawatte. Da gibt es jetzt auch die Werbeartikel zu und ich leide natürlich darunter. Ich glaube auch, dass ich den Trend alleine nicht werde stoppen können. Aber was ist dann, wenn man sich jetzt entschließt, keine Krawatte zu tragen? Was macht man dann? Und da möchte ich doch mal darauf hinweisen, dass man, wenn man das Hemd ohne Krawatte trägt, dann kann man nicht nur diesen einen Knoten, den man sonst, den einen Knopf, den man zumacht, wo die Krawatte dann gebunden wird, den auflassen und sonst alles so lassen. Das sieht komisch aus. Das sieht so ein bisschen kleinlich aus. Das sieht genauso aus wie hier diese Herren, die immerhin die World-Leader sind. Auf diesem Foto sieht es ein bisschen aus, wie der Schwiegervater auf der Hochzeit, der sagt, ich muss mal aus der Krawatte aus, ist ein bisschen heiß geworden. So sieht es aus. Deswegen, was macht man? Man muss, wenn man ohne Krawatte trägt, mindestens zwei Knöpfe öffnen. Mutige können drei öffnen, aber das kommt dann sehr drauf an.
Das schafft nur Trudeau und Macron.
Das kommt dann sehr darauf an, wie man da so gebaut ist. Aber das sollte man schon beherzigen, also diese zwei Knöpfe öffnen. Weil diese eine sieht wirklich eigenartig aus. Habeck macht das auch immer, das sieht furchtbar aus. Habeck hat doch die falsche Kragenform für die Hemden, die er trägt und den Körperbau, den er hat. Aber das nur am Rande. Dann ist mir aber noch was viel Schrecklicheres aufgefallen. Bei dem Filmpreis sind viele mit Anzug gekommen, viele Männer, und tragen dann T-Shirt. Ich will das jetzt gar nicht ästhetisch groß bewerten. Ich will nur mal etwas deutlich machen. Wie oft wechselt ihr, liebe Herren, ein T-Shirt? Täglich, würde ich mal sagen. Wie oft wechselt man ein Oberhemd? Täglich. Vielleicht mag es Leute geben, die würden es zwei Tage tragen. Aber häufiger ja nicht. Was bedeutet das jetzt im Transfer? Wenn man ein Sacko so trägt, nur mit T-Shirt, dann scheuert ja die ganze Zeit der Sackokragen am bloßen Hals. Das heißt, man müsste dann theoretisch das Sacko jedes Mal danach oder zumindest jedes zweite Mal reinigen. Das ist erstmal teuer. Und zweitens ist das Sacko dann auch nach zehnmal Reinigen durch. Das heißt, es ist sehr schlecht und nicht nachhaltig, wenn man so ein Sacko trägt.
Als Nachhaltigkeitsargument ist natürlich der Trigger.
Die Tipps für die Herren heute noch von mir.
Sehr gut, sehr gut, sehr gut.
Wir gehen ja im Juli auch mich ausstatten lassen. Zumindest schon mal vermessen und so. Ich bin sehr gespannt. Für den Salon möchte ich anbetracht dieser Zeitenge, die wir heute hier wieder haben, vorschlagen, dass ich eine DM, die ich bekommen habe, von Alex zum Thema Dolly 2, also das große Projekt der OpenAI Inc. geführt von Elon Musk und Microsoft oder auch Google's Imagine, heißt das glaube ich. Die haben jetzt die Stockfotografie tatsächlich komplett automatisiert. Du hast einen Text und aus dem Text wird ein Bild generiert und es ist von einem Foto nicht zu unterscheiden. Du kriegst zwei Vorschläge. Einer davon zeigt dir genau, was du abbilden willst. Damit geht ein Milliarden-Business den Bach runter.
Bildrechte, all das.
Genau, sobald sowas wirklich dann öffentlich zur Verfügung steht. Und in dieser Diskussion, Alex hat das ganz wunderbar alles aufgedröselt, das werden wir im Salon dann durchgehen, wird auch nochmal die Frage gestellt. Was ist mit Drehbüchern, wenn ich eine Idee nicht in ein Bild generiere, sondern in ein Drehbuch? Ob nicht durch solche Playbook-Initiativen und so weiter. Mittlerweile das, was die Häuser wollen, so festgezurrt ist, dass man es viel einfacher von der Maschine erst mal generieren lässt. Danach kann man ja immer noch eingreifen, rumeditieren, aber man hat erst mal eine Formatvorlage, wo man weiß, da ist alles an seinem Platz.
So wie man ein Playbipel was übersetzen lässt, und dann muss man nochmal so 3, 4 Wörter ändern, die nicht so stimmen.
Aber dass man hier jetzt wirklich in neue Sphären vorstößt. Und es ist interessanterweise wirklich diese Corona-Zeit gewesen, in der diese Fortschritte gemacht wurden. Also keine Ahnung, wie die Zusammenhänge da sind. Das wäre eine Neuerung jetzt im Salon, dass wir da vielleicht auch mal einfach höherer Post vortragen.
Dann greifen wir doch dieses Thema noch dann im Salon auf. Das ist doch sehr sinnvoll. Ich bringe auch was Digitales noch mit in den Salon, nämlich einen Roman, der heißt Die Kinder sind Könige von Delphine de Vigan. Das ist eine französische Schriftstellerin, die sich da dem Thema Kinderinfluencer widmet. Und da wird auch ein Krimi erzählt. Es geht um eine Kindesentführung. Und es geht aber auch um ein Leben, das nur in den sozialen Medien stattfindet, mit Millionen Reichweite. Ein Roman, über den es sich zu sprechen lohnt. Und dann kann ich noch verraten, werde ich einen Essay noch mitbringen zum Thema Flucht. Der heißt Wir Zukunftslosen von Johannes Siegmund. Also noch mal da eine andere Perspektive auf das Thema Flucht und Migration. Und dann, wie schon besprochen, sprechen wir dann über die dunkle Seite der Christdemokratie von Fabio Wolkenstein.
Yes, so machen wir es. Über die Zukunftslosen habe ich auch schon ein interessantes gehört. Da rollt ja auch gerade so eine Rezensionswelle, zumindest in Deutschlandfunk. In dem Falle war es ein Autorengespräch, fand ich sehr gut. Bin ich gespannt, das dann ausführlich zu hören. Genau, damit haben wir den Monat ausführlich behandelt. Klar sind ja Themen liegen geblieben. Von meiner Seite noch ein bisschen Digitales. Das verschiebt sich dann alles. Zum Beispiel diese Auseinandersetzung, die sehr amüsant ist. Ist jetzt diese komische Google-Maschine, Lamda, empfindungsfähig.
Ach komm, darüber sprechen wir noch. Das machen wir noch. Dann sind wir schon vorbereitet für den Salon. Wenn wir dann über die künstliche Intelligenz sprechen. Also es gibt einen Entwickler bei Google, der für KI zuständig ist. Blake Lemoine und der hat plötzlich den Verdacht gehabt. Oder die Gewissheit war sie sicher. Die KI, die hat ja ein Bewusstsein. Ich hab mit der jetzt gesprochen. Und ich hab die auch gefragt, wovor sie Angst hat. Und dann hat sie geantwortet, abgeschaltet zu werden. Und jetzt kann man ja sich überlegen, was würde denn das bedeuten? Denn wer wäre denn in der Lage, also wenn das jetzt wirklich der Wahrheit entsprechen würde, wer wäre dann in der Lage, eine KI abzuschalten? Nun ja der Mensch. Und wenn sie davon die meiste Angst hat, dann müsste sie vielleicht den Mensch angreifen, damit er sie nicht abschalten kann.
Genau. Und es gibt jetzt ganz viele Dimensionen. Zum einen das Thema selbst. Dann wie darüber im Podcast gesprochen wird. Wie im Podcast darüber gesprochen wird. Wie bald in den Mainstream-Medien darüber gesprochen wird. Und wie dann wirklich die Mainstream-Medien darüber sprechen. Das kürzen wir aber alles ein. Auf vier Clips aus This Week in Tech und This Week in Google 668. Und da ist ja immer Chef Chavis mit zu Gast. Ich finde das immer gut, weil der wirklich selten meine Meinung vertritt. Und dadurch ist es immer sehr inspirativ, ihm zuzuhören. In dem Fall hat er sich aber ein bisschen Mühe gemacht, sich in das Thema reinzuarbeiten. Weil da war er gerade in einem Buchkapitel zum Thema. Und dann kam das so und hat sich da gleich reingefuchst. Und diese kleinen Pointen, die da jetzt zu machen sind, die sind auch wirklich sehr gut. Also, Jeff Jarvis eben auf dem Trip, alles Moral Panic und so. Man soll das Internet erstmal machen lassen. Und jetzt hat sich hier...
Er denkt, Lamda, die Google-Artificial-Intelligenz-Maschine, die auf Millionen Text-Snippen von der Internet trainiert hat...
So, jetzt hat Jeff Chavez schon diese Zahlen genannt. Wir haben es also hier mit Rekombination zu tun. Die Maschine ist nicht wirklich empfindungsfähig, aber sie weiß, wie sie Empfindungsfähigkeit ausdrückt, weil sie natürlich die Textgrundlagen kennt. So ist es halt.
Das kann man prima nachlesen bei Miriam Meckel. Die hat ja dieses Buch geschrieben. Ich glaube, das war auch damals etwas, was Schirmacher mit angestoßen hat oder auch stark gemacht hat. Es ist ein Roman, der angelehnt ist an Frankenstein und der ist aus der Perspektive einer KI erzählt und aus der Perspektive des letzten Menschen. Das ist ganz interessant. Da geht es nämlich um die Frage, woher weiß man eigentlich um diese Emotionen und all das, man hat es aus Büchern, nämlich man hat hier alle Bücher eingescannt.
Genau, wir haben es erstmal hier mit einer Kommunikation zu tun. Die Maschine hat irgendwas kommuniziert. Wir haben es verstanden, weil sie hat im Modus, wie wir es verstehen, die Worte aneinandergereiht. Sie waren gerade mal gar nicht korrekt usw. Ob aber zwischen diesem, ich habe aus Kommunikation gelernt und kommuniziere selbst, irgendwo eine Kognition stattfand oder nicht, das wissen wir nicht. Und das ist ja auch eine große Herausforderung. Wie kommt man von einer Kommunikation zur Kognition? Klar, können wir jetzt annehmen, weil wir ja bei uns vermuten, wenn wir was kommunizieren, steckt da ursächlich eine Kognition dahinter, die irgendwann mal Kommunikation aufgenommen und dann gelernt hat. Wir können natürlich das übertragen und sagen, die Maschine hat auch irgendwo kogniziert. Immerhin ist es ja ein Prozessor und so, der da arbeitet. Naja, und dann hieß es ja immer, und das finde ich dann viel interessanter, dieser Le Moyen, wer ist denn das eigentlich? Und wenn das hier diskutiert wurde, hieß es immer, das ist so ein Priester, einfach ein Pfarrer oder so. Das ist nicht nur ein Computerwissenschaftler, sondern das ist auch jemand aus der geistigen Ecke. Erst bei Jeff Jarvis hab ich gehört, was das für ein Priester ist.
Er ist ein Wiccan, ein Mitglied der Discordian Society, die nahe, so wie ich es kann sagen, ist ihre Vatican auf Facebook.
Ja, das ist er.
Er hat schon vor dem Krieg etwas verformt. Er war im Armee, er hat sich entschieden, dass er es nicht mag. Er hat sich auf die Orde gehalten, er hat einen Rundschluss für 7 Monate, er hat auch eine Parodie der Religion gemacht.
Das ist interessant. Das wäre nicht das erste Mal. Ist er ein Teil der Kirche der Spaghetti-Leute? Er ist sehr ähnlich zum fliegenden Spaghetti Monster.
Ist er ein Spaghetti Monster-Priester? Die Antwort ist ja. Der Typ ist ein Discordianer. Dieser Discordianismus ist, wie Jeff Loeffler sagt, eine pseudo Parodie auf Religion, die sich irgendwann im Internet-Zeitalter die Leute mal so ausgedacht haben. Da gibt es auch ein paar Vertreter hier in Deutschland. Tim Brittlaff erwähnt das über Mal, dass er sich da auch angeschlossen hat. Das nehmen Computer-Nerds als so wie dieses The Birds Are Not Real, dass man da Verschwörungstheorien so aufgreift und es völlig parodiert. Das ist so ein Typ, ein Discordianer, jetzt behauptet, meine Maschine, die ich hier gebaut habe, ist empfindungsfähig, ist wirklich klamauk, auf der ganzen Ebene. Aber es wurde leider nicht so, also da steckt ja durchaus ein Thema drin, nämlich, dass die Maschine jetzt wie so ein Spiegel für uns funktioniert. Also für Leute, die das nicht durchblicken, die haben es plötzlich mit so einer auf sie reagierenden Entität zu tun, die sie tatsächlich überrascht.
Die Kinder, die mit Alexa sprechen oder man hat es auch bei Dementen, die mit Robotern dann plötzlich wirklich in so menschliche Interaktionen eintreten. Man hat generell diese Tendenz, man möchte gerne vermenschlichen, solche parasozialen Beziehungen. Es gibt ja einige Unternehmen, so Dr. Ötker und so ein paar andere, die jetzt als Unternehmen wie Menschen auftreten bei Twitter oder Instagram, die dann so sagen, heute habe ich mal Lust wieder auf eine schöne Pizza. Und man denkt ja, aber du bist ja ein Unternehmen. Also so würde man vernünftigerweise denken. Und dann kommentieren aber Leute so drunter. Also natürlich wissen die noch, das ist ein Unternehmensaccount. Aber es gibt offenbar so eine große Sehnsucht. Und ich wollte nur auf eines noch hinweisen. Man kann natürlich so ein Thema zum Anders nehmen, um auch sinnvoll über KI und auch die Verantwortung, die bei der Erforschung mitschwingt, zu sprechen. Es gibt einen Podcast beim SWR jetzt, der heißt Was geht, was bleibt. Und das nimmt man so 30 Minuten. Und da ging es um diesen Fall. Also der wurde aber nur zum Anders genommen. Und da gab es ein interessantes Interview mit Thomas Metzinger. Heißt der Thomas Metzinger? Der sich mit KI auseinandersetzt, mit dieser Forschung sehr lange. Und der verweist auch darauf, dass es immer wieder diese Forderungen gab, nach einem Moratorium. Also dass man da auch bei manchen Forschungen tatsächlich erstmal vorsichtig sein sollte.
Genau, kann man alles diskutieren. Ich finde erstmal, es ist das, was mich am meisten interessiert, ist das, was am meisten praktischen Nutzen hat. Was wäre dann, es gibt ja schon viele Textgeneratoren, die einfach ein Fußballergebnis nehmen und daraus semantisch irgendwie, wenn die Tore halt in der 17. und 73. Minute fallen, dann kann man das ja einfach mal ausformulieren. So, dass man aus einer Autorenschaft nur noch das Lektorat macht. Also dass der Mehrwert im Lektorat steht und man sich schon mal eine Grundlage geben lässt. Und nicht am weißen Blatt Papier mit jeder Formulierung anfängt, sondern so ein bisschen. Und es gibt ja viele Bereiche, in denen hat das Sinn. Wie zum Beispiel, ich achte ja bei uns am Kaffee immer drauf, dass die Personen, über die wir reden, so ein bisschen im Vordergrund stehen, aber im Hintergrund irgendwas. Wenn ich da einfach drei Schlagworte nenne, dann soll mir das einfach Bilder vorschlagen. Als Suche funktioniert es ja schon, aber ich will es auch generieren und so. Warum nicht? Das ist ja so ein kleiner Mehrwert. Ich kann ja dann immer noch in die Bilder eingreifen. Ich habe ja Photoshop und so und kann dann einfach machen. Wenn man das jetzt bei Text und Bildern so kann, finde ich, steckt da ein ganz großer Mehrwert drin. Bei Musik zum Beispiel auch. Wenn man so für Podcasts, so für die letzte Minute, so einen Ausklangteppich irgendwie generiert und dann sagt man, welche Instrumente, welcher Rhythmus und dann kommt einfach irgendwas. Das ist schon allein, weil es rechtemäßig frei ist. Es steckt kein wirklicher Urheber darin. Also es gibt so ganz viele Ebenen, wo man so was nutzen könnte. Und ich finde, auf dieser sehr profanen Ebene sollte man das alles mal diskutieren. Wird es aber nicht, weil immer gleich die große Singularitätsidee und so weiter. Und da hat Leo Laporte hier auch nochmal einen wichtigen Hinweis gemacht, nachdem Jeff Jarvis auch nochmal sich über die Medienhäuser lustig gemacht hat.
Und dann, jede einzelne Newsorganisation um die Welt, Stück für Stück, ich habe es gerade in der Sprache von der Sprache gesehen.
Genau, wir haben diese Erwartungen natürlich durch unsere eigenen kreativen Vorstöße beim Thema Science Fiction und so weiter. Irgendwann erwarten wir halt diesen Computer, dass er genauso funktioniert, wie wir uns das vorher mal gedacht haben. Westworld ging ja auch wieder los, ich habe die erste Folge noch nicht gesehen. Aber das ist halt eine Serie, die inspirativ mit so Ideen spielt. Und dann bilden wir da gleich die Erwartung aus, dass es tatsächlich so wie Westworld wird. Irgendwer wird einen echten Menschen unadverscheidbar schaffen und so. Und er wird auch eine kleine Kugel als Gehirn oben drin stecken, genau wie wir es erwarten. Und so ein großer Weltcomputer, der alles steuert. Und am Ende sind wir die Gesteuerten und so weiter und der ganze Kram. Und das stimmt alles. Und deswegen würde ich sagen, solche Sachen wie das mit dem Lambda, die muss man ohne diese Ehrfurcht mal diskutieren, wo da diese Mehrwerte sind. Denn wer hat nicht Lust darauf, wenn man und ich nutze es jetzt auch immer häufiger, meine Geräte so ein bisschen durch Sprache zu steuern. Wer hat nicht Lust darauf, dass da ein wirklich kleiner Smalltalk einfach mal drin steckt und nicht einfach nur der nackte Befehl oder so. Also man muss sich ja nicht gleich verarschen lassen von der Maschine und da wird ja auch darauf geachtet, dass man immer weiß, man hat es mit einer Maschine zu tun und nicht mit einem Menschen und so. Aber diese kleinen Assistenzsysteme könnten alle mal ein kleines Update erfahren und so was wie in die Richtung Lambda, das auch mal ein bisschen überraschend ist, dabei rumkommt, finde ich gar nicht so schlecht insgesamt. Und da muss man ja nicht immer diese große Angst haben, Moratorium fordern, da würde ich sagen, es gibt so ein paar Bereiche, da kann man das machen. Aber einfach nur für eine Textausgabe, die einem zurückgegeben wird, während man selber ein Text reingegeben hat, da würde ich sagen, Feuer frei, diese Spielarena würde ich gerne eröffnen und nicht so sehr unter Druck dieser Diskussion.
Ich lebe natürlich ohne Sprachassistenten, das möchte ich nicht im Haus haben, das ist mir eher zuwider, dieser Gedanke. Aber ich glaube auch, noch werden sich die Alexas nicht verselbstständigen. Ich glaube aber, dass es so als philosophische Idee wichtig ist, sich aber dann wirklich aus so einem Erkenntnisinteresse damit zu beschäftigen und nicht auf dieses schnelle jetzt hat sich die Maschine verselbstständigt, denn dann wird man eigentlich der Sache überhaupt nicht gerechnet. Weder dann in pragmatischer Hinsicht, so wie du das jetzt gerade beschrieben hast, noch in philosophisch-anthropologischer Hinsicht, dass man überlegt, was bedeutet das eigentlich für den Menschen, wenn tatsächlich so eine Verselbstständigung stattfinden könnte und von welchem Menschenbild geht man dann eigentlich aus, wenn man tatsächlich sagt, dass das möglich sein könnte. Aber das sind die großen Fragen, die vertagen wir. Wir gucken uns dann im Salon nochmal an, was künstliche Intelligenzen so können und wo die Christdemokraten versagen. Dann gehen wir zum Allzu-Menschlichen wieder über.
Wir führen gerne an. Bitte in eurem Podcast steigt drauf ein, wir machen uns jetzt alle zusammen lustig über diese CDU. Und damit vertragen wir uns, wir hören uns im Salon und dann im nächsten Monat kommt alle gut in diese Hitze, die jetzt ansteht. Denn jetzt ist der Sommer da. Das war bisher nur Frühling.